یادگیری ساخت بازی و جاوا اسکریپت
استفاده از کتابخانه Klay در این دوره JS
Legend Dev ابتدا به شما آموزش خواهد داد
جاوا اسکریپت که برای شروع باید بدانید
بازی‌ها را ایجاد کنید، سپس او به شما یاد می‌دهد که چگونه
برای ایجاد بازی‌ها، سلام به همه، خوش آمدید
این دوره فشرده که هدف آن این است که
به شما یاد می‌دهد که چگونه با جاوا اسکریپت برنامه‌نویسی کنید
تا بتوانید با آنها شروع به ساخت بازی کنید
این برخلاف تمام تصادف‌ها است
دوره‌هایی که در یوتیوب در مورد یادگیری پیدا می‌کنید
جاوا اسکریپت که معمولاً به شما آموزش می‌دهند
جاوا اسکریپت با هدف ساختن
وب‌سایت‌ها و کار در توسعه وب، همین حالا اینجا
این متفاوته چون من دارم بهت یاد میدم
اجزای اصلی جاوا اسکریپت به طوری که شما
می‌توانید شروع به ساخت بازی کنید و سپس می‌توانید
حتی شروع به تماشای فیلم قبلی‌ام کردم
آموزش‌هایی که همگی فرض می‌کنند شما دارید
درک اولیه از جاوا اسکریپت در حال حاضر
چرا برای ساخت بازی جاوا اسکریپت یاد بگیریم؟
این سوال خوبی است که ممکن است داشته باشید
از خودت پرسیدی و بله، من اینجام تا
پاسخ دهنده آن است، بنابراین جاوا اسکریپت بسیار
زبان قابل فهم، خیلی مزخرفه
بعد از مهارت که یعنی با
جاوا اسکریپت، شما می‌توانید به عنوان یک توسعه‌دهنده وب کار کنید، بنابراین
چرا از همین دانش‌ها استفاده نکنیم؟
ابزارهایی برای ساخت بازی و به خصوص بازی تحت وب
بازی‌ها، بنابراین بازی‌هایی که می‌توانند روی وب اجرا شوند
بدون نیاز به دانلود یا نصب
هر چیزی و این اولین تبلیغ است
مزایای بازی‌های تحت وب و استفاده از آنها
جاوا اسکریپت برای ساخت آن بازی‌ها
که لازم نیست چیزی نصب کنید
به عنوان بازیکنی که اصطکاک را کاهش می‌دهد
این به ویژه یک مزیت در بازی است
مربا و به خصوص یک مزیت برتر
وقتی یک توسعه‌دهنده بازی جدید هستید که سعی می‌کنید
برای ساختن شهرت خود، بنابراین با ساختن یک
دسته‌ای از بازی‌های وب کوچک‌تر که نمی‌توانید
فقط مهارت خود را به عنوان یک بازی بسازید
توسعه‌دهنده، بلکه راحت‌تر هم هست
مخاطب یا یک نقطه پتانسیل مشابه
بازیکنان اکنون از انجام این کار سود می‌برند
در جاوا اسکریپت به این دلیل است که جاوا اسکریپت
زبان رک و راست، فکر می‌کنم این‌طوری هستی
از وب بگویید که به این معنی است که وقتی
شما بازی خود را با جاوا اسکریپت می‌سازید
سریع بارگذاری می‌شوند و سریع هستند، بنابراین اگر فشار دهم
این بازی‌ای است که من به سبک پوکمون ساختم
بازی‌ای که من با جاوا اسکریپت ساختم، بنابراین حتی
مثل ۶۰ فریم بر ثانیه و غیره، پس آره اگه بخوای
همین بازی را در یونیتی بسازید که دارای ... است
صادرات وب معمولاً بسیار متورم است
من شروع کندی داشتم، فقط بد بودم
تجربه بازی کردن بازی‌های یونیتی روی
وب اکنون مزیت دیگر استفاده از
جاوا اسکریپت برای ساخت بازی این است که شما
در وب گیر نکرده است، بنابراین اگر می‌خواهید
یک بازی روی Steam بسازید که بتوانید نسبتاً
به راحتی بازی خود را منتقل کنید و آن را تبدیل کنید
تبدیل بازی به یک برنامه دسکتاپ با استفاده از
توری یا الکترون یا یکی دیگه
فناوری‌هایی که من یک آموزش در مورد آنها دارم
کانالی که به شما آموزش میده چطور اینو درست کنید
چگونه این کار را انجام دهیم تا یک بازی داشته باشیم که
با جاوا اسکریپت نوشته شده اما روی ... کار می‌کند
دسکتاپ، نمونه بارزی از این مورد بود
بازماندگان خون‌آشام که خیلی باحال بود
بازی محبوب روی کامپیوتر که یک بازی تحت وب بود
که به یک الکترون منتقل شد
برنامه‌ای که به شما امکان می‌دهد بازی‌های کامپیوتری داشته باشید
می‌توانید بازی‌های خود را در Steam منتشر کنید، بنابراین
این یک مزیت دیگر است بدون اینکه
برای تغییر ابزارهایتان، می‌توانید این کار را نیز انجام دهید
همین مورد برای وب، اوه، برای موبایل هم همینطوره، ببخشید
بنابراین با یک زبان جاوا اسکریپت می‌توانید
برای دسکتاپ وب بازی بسازید و
اکنون موبایل تنها بخش گمشده اینجاست
کنسول‌ها و برای کنسول‌ها، من این کار را نمی‌کنم
خیلی نگرانش باش چون اگه بتونی
ساخت یک بازی بسیار موفق روی کامپیوتر
معمولاً از نظر تجاری منطقی است که فقط
به یه شرکت حمل و نقل پول بده تا بازیت رو حمل کنه
به کنسول‌ها، بنابراین به عنوان یک توسعه‌دهنده مستقل
واقعاً باید روی ساختن تمرکز کنیم
بازی خیلی خوبیه و اگه میخوای پول دربیاری
معمولاً برای انجام این کار باید به استیم بروید
و شما می‌توانید این کار را با جاوا اسکریپت انجام دهید
و من می‌گویم آخرین مزیت این است که
دانش قابل انتقالی که شما با آن دارید
webdev، پس تصور کنید که یک توسعه‌دهنده تازه‌کار هستید
تازه شروع کردی، می‌خواستی یاد بگیری
برنامه‌نویسی و شما جاوا اسکریپت را یاد می‌گیرید و
متوجه می‌شوید که ساختن بازی سرگرم‌کننده است، اما
من قادر به انجام این کار نخواهم بود
شغل پایدار یا چیزی شبیه به آن
خب، این ابزار زبان جاوا اسکریپت است
شما یاد گرفتید که در واقع برای آن مفید است
ساختن برنامه‌های کاربردی وب و وب‌سایت‌ها به گونه‌ای که
دانشی که شما اینجا دارید این است
قابل انتقال به مهارت مورد تقاضا که
می‌توانید به عنوان یک مهندس نرم‌افزار و غیره استفاده کنید
بنابراین و برعکس اگر شما یک توسعه دهنده وب هستید
شاید همین الان بخوای امتحان کنی، اوه، درست کردنش
بازی‌ها و شما نمی‌توانید آنها را توجیه کنید
شاید سرمایه‌گذاری زمانی برای یادگیری
وحدت یا خوبی و غیره، بنابراین ممکن است این اتفاق بیفتد
در واقع برای شما بهتر است که فقط به آن پایبند باشید
به جاوا اسکریپت و ساخت بازی با آن
کتابخانه‌های زیادی وجود دارند که می‌توانید از آنها استفاده کنید
جاوا اسکریپت برای آسان کردن کارها و یکی کردن آنها
از آنهایی که در کانالم آموزش می‌دهم
بازی کردن واقعاً، واقعاً لذت بخشه و استفاده ازش لذت بخشه
واقعاً سریع برای استفاده که باعث میشه
خیلی سریع میشه باهاش ​​بازی ساخت، پس
این همونه، پس اون چیه؟ (or: این همونه، پس چیه؟)
قول این ویدیو را تا پایان
این ویدیو شما باید یک پایه داشته باشید
حتی اگر جاوا اسکریپت را درک کنید
قبلاً هرگز برنامه نویسی نکرده اید و شما
باید توانسته باشی اولین کارت را انجام داده باشی
بازی، بنابراین ما سعی خواهیم کرد که آن را بسازیم
پایان این ویدیو، اولین مورد ساده
بازی یا پلتفرمر یا چیزی شبیه به آن
خیلی ساده و بعد از آن شما
آماده‌ام آموزش‌های قبلی‌ام را ببینم.
من می‌توانم آنها را اینجا به شما نشان دهم، بنابراین من
آموزش‌هایی در مورد نحوه ساخت متروید دارید
بازی وانیا - چگونه یک بازی شبیه زلدا بسازیم
بازی مبارزه‌ای GES
و غیره و البته می‌توانید از موارد دیگر استفاده کنید
منابع و اساساً می‌توانید شیرجه بزنید
به داخل و سپس به داخل آن، بنابراین بعد از آن اگر
می‌خوای کاری کنی که اوه، بری سراغ توسعه وب، می‌تونی
آموزش‌ها و غیره را دنبال کنید و بخوانید
مستندات و غیره، بنابراین منظور این است
به عنوان یک درگاه
به جاوا اسکریپت بلکه مانند بازی
توسعه در جاوا اسکریپت، بنابراین یک ... است
دروازه‌ای به سوی حرفه برنامه‌نویسی شما
شاید پس بیایید شروع کنیم تا شما بتوانید
اینجا به کد ویژوال استودیو نیاز دارم، که هست
ویدیو، اوه، ویدیو ویرایشگر کد نیست
که من از آن استفاده خواهم کرد، تو به آن نیازی نداری
تو اگه تو اگه مبتدی نیستی، اوه
فرض کنیم شما از جای دیگری می آیید
زبان برنامه نویسی، مثلاً پایتون
شما می‌توانید از هر چیزی که دوست دارید استفاده کنید
آن یک ویرایشگر کد مانند Vim یا
هر چه که باشد، اما پیشنهاد می‌کنم اگر شما یک
مبتدی، یک مبتدی مطلق که شما دارید
قبل از اینکه اینو انتخاب کنی، هیچ‌وقت برنامه‌ریزی نشده بود
ویرایشگر، بنابراین شما هم همین را خواهید داشت
راستی، اگه تو چیزی مثل من رو در مقابل کد قرار بدی،
نمی‌دانم واقعاً مثل سرگرد است
ویرایشگر کد برای توسعه‌دهندگان وب، بنابراین
در اینجا من یک پنجره دارم که شامل VSS است
کد، بنابراین برای باز کردن یک پروژه جدید به
فایل را وارد کنید و سپس یک پوشه جدید باز کنید، بنابراین ابتدا
از همه توصیه می‌کنم که یک
پوشه و سپس آن پوشه را باز می‌کنید و
اینجا آن را برای شما باز خواهد کرد
پنجره خالی با پوشه خالی شما توسط
روشی که فراموش کردم ذکر کنم اما این
این آموزش فرض می‌کند که شما اطلاعات پایه دارید
مهارت‌های کامپیوتری، بنابراین این بدان معناست که شما می‌دانید
پوشه چیست و بله، ETC چیست؟
ممکن است تعجب آور به نظر برسد اما برای برخی
مردم این چیزی نیست که آنها بدانند
و غیره، بنابراین معمولاً اگر شما روی ... بزرگ شده باشید
ممکن است ندانید که یک فایل در آیپد چیست
سیستم نحوه کار آن است و غیره اگر شما
قبلاً به هر سیستم عامل واقعی مانند
به این معنا که یا ویندوز است یا
لینوکس یا مک او اس، شما باید در چه زمانی خوب باشید؟
با دنبال کردن این آموزش به دست میاد
دوره فشرده خیلی خب، پس چی؟
کوتاه‌ترین مسیر برای دریافت جاوا اسکریپت شما
کد در حال اجرا
بنابراین من قصد دارم یک فایل ایجاد کنم توسط
کلیک کردن روی آن
دکمه را فشار دهید و من آن را main.js می‌نامم.
این نقطه ورود ما خواهد بود
پروژه جایی که قرار است بنویسیم
کد جاوا اسکریپت ما، پس تا اینجا، من دارم میرم
برای ایجاد آن فایل ابتدا مقداری بنویسید
کد جاوا اسکریپت، بنابراین اگر من این کار را انجام دهم، اینجا هستم.
ممکن است فرض کنید که شما کد خود را در
آن فایل و سپس روی یک فایل بزرگ کلیک می‌کنید
دکمه سبز در جایی برای اجرای کد
و این روشی نیست که ما در آن انجام می‌دهیم
دنیای جاوا اسکریپت، پس نحوه انجام آن به خودتان بستگی دارد.
من معمولاً نیاز به ایجاد یک فایل HTML دارم
دوست دارم اسمش را index.html بگذارم، اما
مهم نیست برای تو، باید فراخوانده شود
HTML بنابراین معمولاً جاوا اسکریپت جفت می‌شود
با HTML و CSS که چیزهای دیگری هستند
زبان‌های برنامه‌نویسی، دامنه‌ی آنها
زبان برنامه نویسی خاصی که به معنی
که آنها یک هدف کلی نیستند
زبان‌های برنامه‌نویسی مانند جاوا اسکریپت
بنابراین اجازه دهید فقط یک مرور کلی توضیح دهم
از اینکه HTML و CSS چیستند اما من نیستم
من واقعاً آنها را به شما یاد نمی دهم
من فقط قصد دارم در آن شیرجه بزنم
حداقل HTML را به شما یاد می‌دهد
نیاز به اضافه کردن جاوا اسکریپت به وب خود دارید
مرورگر و در حال اجرا، بنابراین فهرست. HTML بنابراین
HTML زبانی است که برای ساخت وب استفاده می‌شود
صفحه، بنابراین یک صفحه وب که دارید را توصیف کنید
برچسب‌های زیادی برای مثال اولین
تگ پایه، تگ HTML است که
به این معنی است که شما قصد دارید
یک سند، یک صفحه وب ایجاد کنید و سپس
شما تگ بدنه را دارید که قرار است
نه تگ bot، تگ body که در حال رفتن است
برای قرار دادن محتوای صفحه وب شما
و غیره، بنابراین تگ بدنه به همان شکلی که تگ‌ها هستند، عمل می‌کند
html های نوشته شده به آن چیزها نیاز دارید و
پس شما به یک تگ پایانی نیاز دارید
یک تگ باز و یک تگ بسته و سپس
اینجا بدن ضروری است و سپس
درون بدن، من قصد دارم یک
تگ اسکریپت که تگی است که برای بارگذاری استفاده می‌شود
جاوا اسکریپت، اوه، آره، فایل‌های جاوا اسکریپت، پس
نحوه کار تگ‌های اسکریپت به این صورت است که شما
اینجا تگ را داشته باشید و منبع را دارید
ویژگی را کجا تعریف می‌کنید؟ کجا پیدا می‌شود؟
فایل جاوا اسکریپت شما اینجا است، چون ما ...
در همان سطح درون پوشه
مسیر خواهد بود
main.js بنابراین حتی می‌توانید آن را حذف کنید
و سپس اگر خواستید main.js را انجام دهید
یک پوشه درون آن ایجاد کنید که JS را یاد بگیرید
پوشه‌ای که من برای آن ایجاد کردم
این پروژه شما را هنگام ایجاد
پروژه‌ای که قرار بود اینجا انجام دهید
شاید یک پوشه را باز کنید و سپس شما
اسم دیگری داشته باشید اما در صورت تمایل
اسمش را هر طور که می‌خواهی بگذار، نمی‌شود
اصلاً مهم نیست، بنابراین اگر قرار بود یک [چیز] ایجاد کنم
پوشه‌ای که اینجا هست و من اسمش رو گذاشتم منبع (Source)
یا فقط قراره صداش کنم
کد را وارد می‌کنم و سپس dod های اصلی‌ام را درون آن قرار می‌دهم
اینجا مسیر با کد SL خواهد بود.
اصلی
جاز، پس این روشی است که الان کار می‌کند
اولین بیانیه‌ای که قرار است بنویسیم
اولین خط کد، ما عمومی هستیم
درست است که خواهد بود
کنسول وارد شوید و همانطور که از نامش پیداست
قرار است چیزی را ثبت کند، آن چیز
شما اینجا داخل پرانتز وارد می‌کنید
به کنسول، کنسول در اختیار شماست
مرورگر وب وقتی فشار می‌دهید
F12 این کنسوله، پس اگه من بودم
بسته به مرورگرتان باید
یک نماد داشته باشید، بنابراین در اینجا این را دارید
کنسول نماد این به این دلیل است که من من
واقعاً فونت بزرگی دارند، بنابراین معمولاً
آنها را اینجا نمایش می‌دادم اما از آن زمان
من فونت را خیلی بزرگ کرده‌ام
برای انجام این کار باید روی علامت بعلاوه کلیک کنم.
کنسول را اینجا ببینید، بنابراین اگر من این هستم
کنسول و اینجاست که شما
خروجی کد جاوا اسکریپت شما خواهد بود
ظاهر می شود، بنابراین اکنون اینجا بیایید بگوییم که می خواهم
یه پیام به کنسول بنویس، اوه، من بهش نیاز دارم
برای ارسال آنچه در برنامه‌نویسی نامیده می‌شود
یک رشته، رشته‌ای از کاراکترها
بنابراین دسته ای از شخصیت ها که تشکیل می دهند
رشته پس سلام
جهان رشته‌ای از کاراکترهاست، بنابراین ما
دارای کاراکتر H، کاراکتر el، lo، o باشد.
کاراکتر فاصله و سپس W، بنابراین این یک
شخصیت حتی اگر قابل مشاهده نباشد
چشم، اوه، این یک شخصیت است و غیره
و غیره و باید درون آن قرار گیرد
علامت نقل قول، بنابراین حالا همه چیز باید
خوب باشه اما ما هنوز نداریم
راهی برای اجرای کد به طوری که بیشترین بهره را ببرد
راه اساسی که به نظرم میرسه اینه که شما فقط
این را در یک مرورگر وب باز کنید و شما
نتیجه خود را بگیرید اما معمولاً
رویکرد ترجیحی این است که داشته باشیم
یک وب سرور محلی که از سرور شما اجرا می‌شود
کامپیوتری که قرار است برنامه را اجرا کند
کد را اجرا کنید و صفحه وب را نمایش دهید.
این سرور محلی معمولاً نامیده می‌شود
میزبان محلی و تعداد زیادی وجود دارد
راه‌هایی برای اجرای یکی اما ساده‌ترین راه اگر
شما از کد vs برای رفتن به
نوع بازار افزونه در Live
سرور
و شما این افزونه را دریافت خواهید کرد
که همانطور که از نامش پیداست، راه‌اندازی
سرور محلی را توسعه دهید، بنابراین نمی‌توانید
واقعاً اینجا را ببینید، پس آن را اینجا نصب کنید
باید نوشته شود نصب شود اما
چون من قبلاً آن را نصب کرده‌ام، اینطور است
درست است که حذف نصب شده است، بنابراین آن را نصب کنید
پس از نصب این، به سیستم خود برگردید
پروژه و سپس در اینجا در زیر باید
یک دکمه پخش زنده را ببینید، بنابراین برای اجرای آن کلیک کنید
اگر روی سرور زنده کلیک کنید، شروع می‌شود
برای باز کردن یک پنجره، حالا من فقط می روم
به
کپی کنید
آدرس چون قرار است آن را باز کنم
این صفحه، پس ما اینجاییم، پس اتفاقاً
برای مشاهده همه موارد به توضیحات مراجعه کنید
لینک‌هایی که نیاز دارید، مثلاً چطور، کجا
کد VSS و غیره را نصب کنید، بنابراین این است
سرور میزبان محلی آدرسی که
داده شد به
من و سپس روی آن کلیک کنید تا به طور پیش فرض
سرور زنده باید به روی شما باز شود
پیش‌فرض
مرورگر اما در اینجا من از یک مرورگر دیگر استفاده می‌کنم
مرورگر برای ضبط این آموزش
برای همین دستی کپی پیست کردم
آدرس اینجا، الان اینجاست، ما اینجا یک
صفحه خالی چون همونطور که گفتم HTML
در واقع زبانی است که برای نوشتن استفاده می‌شود
محتوای یک صفحه وب اما جاوا اسکریپت
زبانی است که برای ساخت انیمیشن‌ها استفاده می‌شود
و منطق و غیره بنابراین در ابتدا چه زمانی
جاوا اسکریپت طوری ساخته شده بود که فقط اجرا می‌شد
در صفحه وب مانند آن به عنوان پشتیبانی
شخصیتی که فقط برای اضافه کردن میگم
انیمیشن‌ها به صفحات HTML تا
صفحات وب واقعی همزمان با تکامل زبان
و میشه باهاش ​​کارهای بیشتری انجام داد
اکنون می‌توان با آن بازی ساخت، بنابراین
بفرمایید، پس حالا می‌خواهم بحث را باز کنم
همچنین می‌توانید با فشردن کلید F12 به تب کنسول دسترسی پیدا کنید.
فکر می‌کنم با استفاده از این، این تب کنسول را باز کنید
اگر روشن هستید، فرمان shift I را فشار دهید تا کنترل شود.
سیستم عامل مک اما در ویندوز F12 است و شما
می‌بینیم که می‌توانیم دنیای سلام خودمان را داشته باشیم.
پیام خروجی اینجا ظاهر می‌شود، این است
کنسول، بنابراین ما کد خود را در آن می‌نویسیم
فایل main.js را اینجا قرار دهید و سپس به
بنابراین اگر به جای سلام دنیا، من ظاهر شوم،
سلام دوستان!
افسانه و شما می‌توانید ببینید که به‌روزرسانی می‌شود
اینجا، بنابراین اکنون ما آماده‌ایم، ما [این کار را] انجام داده‌ایم
برنامه‌نویسی برنامه‌نویسی پایه ما
محیط آماده است، بعداً می‌رویم
برای دیدن ابزارهای پیشرفته‌تر و ...
تنظیمات متفاوتی که بیشتر و نزدیک‌تر است
به آنچه که در واقع چیست، آنچه که استفاده می‌شود
از نظر حرفه‌ای، همه چیز درست است، پس
حالا بیایید واقعاً یادگیری را شروع کنیم
مفاهیم اصلی برنامه‌نویسی در
جاوا اسکریپت، بنابراین اولین مفهوم اصلی من
می‌خواهم اشاره کنم که این مفهوم اصلی است
به نظر من صفر، نحوه اجرای کد است.
بنابراین فرض می‌کنم که شما صفر دارید
دانش برنامه نویسی و سپس آن
یعنی کد لایک معمولاً به صورت لایک اجرا می‌شود
یک دستور غذا، آن را به عنوان دستور پختی از مراحل تصور کنید
شما باید دنبال کنید و آن مراحل عبارتند از
بسیار دقیق زیرا اگر
شما آن مراحل را با جزئیات بیان نمی‌کنید
کامپیوتر نمی‌داند چه کاری باید انجام دهد
مثل دستور پخت غذاهای انسانی نیست
چیزی که دستورالعمل‌ها در آن قرار دارند
بیشتر عمومی است و انسان می‌تواند آن را پر کند
شکاف‌ها اما با برنامه‌نویسی این‌طور است
متفاوت است، بنابراین کد معمولاً اجرا می‌شود
به ترتیب، بنابراین خط اول و سپس
خط دوم خط سوم
و غیره، بنابراین حالا این مثل این است که اصل مطلب این است
مفهوم به صفر می‌رسد اما واقعیت
اولین مفهومی که قرار است در مورد آن صحبت کنیم
متغیرها و ثابت‌ها چیستند؟
یک متغیر و یک ثابت چیست؟ بنابراین یک
متغیری که می‌توانید آن را به عنوان اولین مورد تصور کنید
تصور کنید تمام کامپیوتر شما حافظه دارد
اسلات‌هایی که می‌توانید داده‌ها را در آنها قرار دهید
متغیر است، آیا شما برچسبی روی آن می‌زنید؟
با یک نام، مثلاً اسم من
متغیر و سپس ذخیره سازی در آن سلول
بنابراین تصور کنید سلول‌هایی دارید که می‌توانند
حاوی داده‌ها در رایانه شما باشد، بنابراین
اساساً نمایشی از شماست
حافظه و سپس یکی از آنها را انتخاب می کنید
جعبه‌ها یا آن اسلات‌هایی که اسمش را می‌گذارید
اساساً دانستن اینکه بتوانیم روی آن کار کنیم
آن را از خاطره‌ی دیگر متمایز کن
اسلات‌ها و سپس داده‌ها را در آن قرار می‌دهید تا
نوع داده‌ای که می‌توانید درون یک قرار دهید
متغیرها تعداد زیادی هستند که می‌توانید اعداد را در آنها قرار دهید
جاوا اسکریپت، بنابراین این نوع عدد است
نوع داده، بنابراین شما انواع داده‌ای دارید که
به عنوان مثال I I نوع داده نامیده می‌شوند.
چهار تا را داخل اسلات‌ها قرار می‌دادم
از اسلات متغیر من و اگر این کار را انجام دهم
و دوباره از پیام console.log استفاده می‌کنم
و نام متغیر my را وارد کنید.
متغیری که قرار است آن را چاپ کند
محتوای آن، بنابراین اگر به آن نگاه کنم
نتایجی که قرار است چاپ شود
چهار نفر در کنسول در
همین الان به روشی که تو گفتی، بهم دلداری بده
یک متغیر تعریف کنید تا یک متغیر ایجاد کنید
متغیری است که باید از let استفاده کنید
کلمه کلیدی، بنابراین شما معمولاً کلید مهم هستید
کلمات کلیدی در جاوا اسکریپت به رنگ آبی هستند مانند
که اگر از کد VSS بدون آن استفاده می‌کنید
هر موضوعی اما به هر حال بیایید ببینیم چطور
یک متغیر را پس از داشتن، تعریف کنید
متغیری را تعریف کنید که بتوانید آن را فراخوانی کنید
در جای دیگر اما و شما حتی می‌توانید تغییر دهید
محتوای آن، بنابراین اگر من آن را داشته باشم
متغیر و پنج قرار دهید
در عوض پس
متغیر من console.log است که می‌توانید آن را ببینید
اگر بروم، محتوا متفاوت خواهد بود
اینجا اولش چهار بود، خط دو بود و
سپس وقتی کامپیوتر به اینجا می‌رسد،
محتوای فایل my my را تغییر می‌دهد.
متغیر و سپس دوباره وارد کنسول می‌شویم
در خط چهارم و محتوا اکنون
متفاوت باشه، حالا یه سری از اینا هست
سوالی که ممکن است برای شما پیش بیاید این است که چرا
متغیر من را نامگذاری کنید تا وقتی که شما
یک متغیر را اعلام کنید که اساساً می‌توانید
هر اسمی که می‌خواهی آنجا انتخاب کن
نمادهای خاصی هستند که مجاز نیستند
برای مثال، شما نمی‌توانید از اعداد استفاده کنید
یک متغیر نامگذاری کنید، بنابراین خواهید داشت
خطوط کج و معوج که به شما بگویند اینطور نیست
مجاز است، نمی‌توانید از خط تیره برای نامگذاری استفاده کنید
شما
متغیر uh با این حال حروف از A به
Z شما در واقع می‌توانید از a z l استفاده کنید تا بتوانید
به نظرم از اعداد استفاده کن
درون آه، با حروف مخلوط شده اما
معمولاً ترجیح می‌دهم نگه دارم
متغیرهام رو نگه دار، امم، واقعاً می‌تونی؟
در واقع این کار را می‌کنم، من هرگز تقریباً هرگز
این کار را انجام دهید، بنابراین بیایید بگوییم z0 به عنوان نام
متغیر و سپس اینجا و سپس بنابراین
من فقط قصد دارم آن را حذف کنم و ببینم آیا
کار می‌کنه، باید کار کنه، اما من فقط
مطمئن شدن از اینکه بله، اساساً وجود دارند
اسم‌های خاصی که نمی‌توانید انتخاب کنید
شما نمی‌توانید متغیر letl را فراخوانی کنید زیرا
این یک کلمه کلیدی رزرو شده است، بنابراین آن دسته از
کلمه کلیدی رزرو شده در جاوا اسکریپت
زبان را نمی‌توان برای اعلام کردن به کار برد
متغیرها و همانطور که دیدید، من نوشتم
متغیر this یک قرارداد است که
در کد جاوا اسکریپت استفاده می‌شود که در آن وقتی شما
اگر چندین متغیر دارید، یک متغیر نامگذاری کنید
کلماتی که این نام را تشکیل می‌دهند، نام
از آن متغیر، سپس اولین
حرف کلمه دوم استفاده شده در
نام متغیر همیشه با a شروع می‌شود
سرمایه، بنابراین برای مثال فقط برای نشان دادن شما
اگر به من زنگ بزنی
نام متغیر، پس می‌توانم آن را رها کنم
مثل این اگر من آن را مال خودم بنامم
نام، من باید با حروف بزرگ اینجا بنویسم، این است
این قوانین واقعی نیستند که به این معنی است که اگر
تو به این قانون احترام نمیذاری، قانون
هنوز اجرا خواهد شد اما آن است، اما آن است
علیه کنوانسیونی که نامیده می‌شود
کمل کیس (camel case) چون شبیه شتر است
میدونی، مثلاً من
نام کامل، بنابراین حروف بزرگ اینجا نوشته می‌شود. حروف بزرگ اینجا نوشته می‌شود
مثل اینه که یه کار شتری انجام میده، کوهان شتر
فکر کنم اسمش به انگلیسی اینه
آره، حیوون تویی، اون چیزی که پشتشه
به هر حال، پس آره، اینجوریه که تو
متغیرها را تعریف کنید، بنابراین اکنون دیدیم که
می‌تونی اممم، می‌تونی شماره بذاری
در آن اما شما در واقع می‌توانید متن قرار دهید
رشته‌ای از کاراکترها، همانطور که گفتم رشته‌ها
ما آنها را اینجا صدا می‌زنیم، می‌توانم اسمی روی آنها بگذارم
مثال
و اگر آن را چاپ کنید، پس ...
هنگام نوشتن کد خود فقط مراقب باشید
متغیرهای تعریف شده را قرار دهید، نه تصادفی
نام‌ها و سپس اینجا اگر به آنها نگاه کنم
نتیجه‌ای که می‌توانی داشته باشی، همانطور که می‌توانی
خب، حالا دیگه می‌دونی چطور
یک متغیر تعریف کنید، اما می‌توانید کارهای زیادی انجام دهید
چیزی فراتر از اعلام کردن
متغیرها، شما همچنین می‌توانید ثابت‌ها را تعریف کنید
بنابراین یک ثابت مانند یک متغیر است اما
محتوای آن نخواهد بود
تغییر و نکات ظریفی در آن وجود دارد
بعداً، اما فعلاً فقط آن را نگه دارید
برای مثال، من می‌خواهم به عنوان یک
ثابت
امم، بیایید بگوییم عرض، عرضِ
برای مثال، من آن را صفحه نمایش می‌نامم.
عرض صفحه نمایش
عرض و سپس بیایید بگوییم 1080 این است
مفهومش اینه که اگه چیزی رو نمیخوای
تغییر دادن یعنی اگر سعی کنم تغییر دهم
مقدار را با آن اسکرول کنید و سپس چیزی قرار دهید
وگرنه بگوییم
۷۲۰، پس اگر نگاه کنی، بگذار آن را حذف کنم
اگر به کنسول نگاه کنید، متغیر است.
به من اجازه نمی‌دهی و تو قرار است
یک انتساب خطای نوع بدون برش دریافت کنید به
متغیر ثابت که به این معنی است که
شما مجاز به تغییر محتوا نیستید
از یک ثابت، درست به نظر می‌رسد، بنابراین این
بنابراین قاعده کلی این است که اگر
اگر مطمئن هستید که از آن استفاده می‌کنید
شما به طور پیش فرض تغییر نخواهید کرد
کاری که من می‌کنم این است که همیشه اعلام می‌کنم
همه چیز به عنوان یک ثابت فقط وقتی که من
می‌دانم که باید تغییر کنم
خودِ محتوا
متغیر است، بنابراین پیش‌فرض برای من Con I است.
همیشه از const استفاده کنید مگر اینکه نیاز به تغییر داشته باشم
محتوای متغیر
اسلات، سلولی که بعدش استفاده کردم
بگذارید بتواند این کار را انجام دهد
خیلی خب، امیدوارم واضح بوده باشه، حالا بریم سراغش
سعی کن مطالب مفیدتری بنویسی
فرض کنیم شما یک
ثابت به نام باشه آره من دارم
ثابتی به نام شماره یک و آن
راستی، وقتی تو باشی، پنج تا رو نگه می‌داره
ببینید من یک نقطه ویرگول اضافه می‌کنم، این است
این چیزی در جاوا اسکریپت است و
حتی در جاوا که هر بار شما
یه خط کد رو که مینویسی تموم کن، اه
پس از بیانیه آن زیرا وجود دارد
برخی دیگر از انواع سازه‌ها در
برنامه‌نویسی‌هایی که نیازی به
نقطه ویرگول بگذارید اما معمولاً ترجیح می‌دهم این کار را نکنم
از آن استفاده کنید زیرا بیشتر آن اینطور نیست
بیشتر اوقات اجباری است، بنابراین من معمولاً
این کار را بکن اما تو فقط به این خاطر می‌دانی که
اگر سعی در استفاده دارید، گیج نشوید
منابع دیگری که از این به بعد به آنها خواهم پرداخت
همیشه وقتی که [علامت] است، نقطه ویرگول را بنویسید
مورد نیاز است، بنابراین ثابت شماره یک، بیایید یک
مثلاً یک عدد ثابت دوم دو
چهار و بعد می‌توانید ریاضی انجام دهید، پس بیایید
دیگری داشته باشید
ثابت و سپس می‌توانیم عدد داشته باشیم
سه یا می‌توانیم آن را صدا کنیم
نتیجه و شماره یک خواهد بود
عدد بعلاوه
دو، بنابراین این حساب پایه است، پس هست
یک جمع و این یعنی نتیجه باید
حاوی
اساساً نه، بنابراین اگر من کنسول کنم
لاگ می‌کنم و می‌خواهم نتیجه را چاپ کنم
و سپس به نتیجه نگاه کنید، اینجا است
حالا نه ساله می‌شوی، برعکس تو
می‌تواند ضرب را انجام دهد، بنابراین ضرب می‌کند
در جاوا اسکریپت برای ضرب از نقطه استفاده می‌کنید
نماد ستاره نه یک نماد X بلکه
این یکی، پس حالا این باید باشد
20 و این است و سپس می توانید تقسیم کنید
در اینجا با استفاده از اسلش، آن دسته از
عملیات‌ها همان عملیات ریاضی هستند اما
نمادهای استفاده شده متفاوت هستند، بنابراین ممکن است
به آنها عادت ندارم، به همین دلیل است که من
به شما می‌گوید که مثلاً کدام، کدام است؟
اینجا
۱.۲۵ و بعد فکر کنم اینجا، اوه، این اممم
بله، فعلاً بیایید اینها اصول اولیه باشند
عملیاتی که می‌توانید توان‌ها را به صورت زیر داشته باشید
خب، بنابراین برای توان‌ها از این استفاده می‌کنید I
این نماد رو نه، من نمی‌دونم چطوره
بنابراین اگر به نتیجه نگاه کنم، بنابراین نامیده می‌شود
اوه یه لحظه صبر کن، اینطور نیست، اینطور نیست
درست فکر می‌کنم مثل دو تا دو نقطه است
آره، اینجوری اکسپون می‌کنی
توان‌ها، بنابراین اگر دارید، مثلاً ۲
توان
دو دو تا از دو میشه چهار تا اه
عملیاتی که من همین الان انجام دادم این است
چیزی متفاوت است و من فکر می‌کنم این است
یه چیز متفاوت، اوه، در واقع اینطور نیست
به یاد داشته باشید اما عملیات بیتی وجود دارد
اما الان فکر نمی‌کنم واقعاً اینطور باشه
فعلاً مربوط به بازی جاوا اسکریپت است
همه
باشه، باشه، حالا ما داریم، تو داری؟
به عنوان اولین مفهوم اصلی دیده می‌شود که چگونه
اعلام کردن
متغیرها و نحوه تغییر محتوا
از یک متغیر اما شما نمی‌توانید این کار را برای
ثابت‌ها و اینکه می‌توانید اعداد را قرار دهید
و حالا چه اتفاقی می‌افتد اگر رشته‌هایی در آنها وجود داشته باشد
شما مثلاً یک ثابت به نام uh دارید
متن است و رشته‌ای به نام hello دارد.
جهان و سپس شما یک عدد دارید، بیایید
بگو چهار یا شماره یک، من که قراره بریم
شاید فقط عدد باشه اما من فکر می‌کنم عدد
یک کلمه کلیدی رزرو شده است، شاید هم نباشد و
اگر نتیجه را بخواهم چه اتفاقی می‌افتد؟
به روشی که لازم نیست آن را ذخیره کنید
نتیجه‌ی عملیاتی درونِ
یک ثابت یا متغیر که می‌توانید انجام دهید
داخل پرانتز است، بنابراین متن
به علاوه، این را به هر زبان دیگری شماره گذاری کنید
با یک سیستم تایپ معقول
اوه، این باید شکست بخورد اما در جاوا اسکریپت اینطور است
آیا واقعاً سعی در محاسبه آن ندارد؟
و اینجا، اممم، کاری انجام خواهد داد
به آن الحاق می‌گویند، بنابراین قرار است
برای چه چیزی با hello world الحاق کنیم؟
آیا به معنی الحاق کردن است که شما اگر
می‌خواهید متن را به هم وصل کنید
رشته‌هایی از شخصیت که با هم ترکیب شده‌اند، شما
معمولاً از علامت جمع برای آن استفاده کنید تا
ممکن است گیج کننده باشد زیرا این ... است
معمولاً به عنوان اضافه کردن چیزی درک می‌شود
با چیزی جز اضافه کردن متن با متن
چطور کار می‌کند، پس اگر من داشته باشم
سلام دنیا و بعد من می‌گفتم
سلام دنیا ۲ شما باید به عنوان
نتیجه در کنسول، یک رشته واحد است
با هر دوی آنها، بنابراین اینگونه است که
عملگر الحاق که از
همان نماد است
به علاوه حالا دلیل اینکه گفتم اینه
وقتی یک عدد و یک رشته وجود داشته باشد، باید با شکست مواجه شود.
از شخصیت ها به هم اضافه می شوند
که بی‌معنی است که شما اول باید
برای مثال در پایتون، ابتدا باید
این را به یک کاراکتر تبدیل کنید و سپس
شما آن را به هم وصل می‌کنید اما جاوا اسکریپت
این چیز را ندارد و این
چیزی که CR از آن انتقاد کرده است
خیلی زیاد، پس فقط این را در نظر داشته باشید که
مراقب آن عملیات باشید، بنابراین این کار را نکنید
این کار را انجام دهید یا اگر اینطور نیست، اگر این کار را نکنید
بدان چه می‌کنی؟
پس آره این باحاله و همه چی به جز اینه که
وقتشه که واقعاً همون ثانیه اول یاد بگیرم
یا مفهوم اصلی سوم که
عبارات شرطی هستند و این
چقدر شبیه یک برنامه خواهد بود که واقعاً دوست داشته باشد
زنده شدن به این معنا که
در واقع قرار است خیلی کار کند
چیزهای جالب، بنابراین ما چند مورد داریم
سازه‌هایی که می‌توانیم از آنها استفاده کنیم، سازه اصلی است.
اگر
بنابراین یک دستور if به شما اجازه می‌دهد
داشتن کد شرطی که
فقط در موقعیت‌های خاص اجرا شود
به عنوان مثال، فرض کنید من قرار است یک
این بار متغیر و این متغیر است
قرار است ام نامیده شود، یعنی ام. ام.
درست مثل یه اسم یا شاید من دارم میرم
برای صدا زدنش
یک نوع دیگر را که دنبال می‌کنم اجرا کن، فراموش کردم
گفتن این است که شما چیزی دارید
یک نوع بولی نامیده می‌شود، بنابراین بولی می‌تواند
یا درست یا غلط، بنابراین در اینجا می‌توانید
یه جمله‌ی درست داشته باش، پس یعنی درست
اینکه این درست است و دلیل آن
چیز درست و غلط اینجا مفید است
زیرا به ما اجازه می‌دهد که شرطی داشته باشیم
منطق شرطی، کدی است که
فقط تحت شرایط خاصی اجرا خواهد شد
شرایط یا انجام کار دیگری
در غیر این صورت، در اینجا در دستور if من
می‌تواند اجرا را در اجرا داشته باشد
متغیر و حالا اگر اجرا درست باشد، آن را اجرا کنید
قرار است آنچه درون براکت‌ها است را اجرا کند
بنابراین در اینجا می‌توانم یک console.log داشته باشم.
بیانیه
console.log و می‌توانم بگویم
سلام و حالا اگر به اعدام نگاه کنم
نتیجه کدی که می‌توانید ببینید
سلام
الان اینجا همه چیز درسته، مسئله اینه که
که بیایید چیزی پیچیده‌تر داشته باشیم
خب، اگر EX اول از همه نادرست باشد، چه؟
قرار دادن false در هیچ چیز نخواهد بود
اتفاق بیفتد پس هیچ اتفاقی نخواهد افتاد هیچ اتفاقی نیست
اکنون اتفاق می افتد شما می توانید از این استفاده کنید
کد پیچیده‌تری داریم، پس بیایید
فرض کنید اگر دو ثابت ایجاد کنیم، بیایید
بگو اگر سن، بیایید بگوییم
۲۵ و قد ۱۸۲
بنابراین شما می‌توانید داشته باشید، می‌توانید داشته باشید
عبارت را اجرا کنید و سپس به جای آن
شما می‌توانستید مستقیماً یک مقدار بولی را وارد کنید
انجام F
فرض کنید سن از شما بالاتر یا مساوی است
من قصد دارم آن نمادها را به شما یاد بدهم
آنها در این مورد مثل این است که ما این را می گوییم
عبارات مقایسه‌ای بولی مانند را فراخوانی کنید
نمی‌دانم آیا این اصطلاح واقعی من است یا نه
فراموش کردم اما به هر حال اگر سن بالاتر باشد
۱۸ سپس اجرا خواهد شد
اینجا هستی، پس تو
برای مثال، بزرگسال و سپس اگر شما اینجا هستید
کدی را خارج از محدوده مورد نظر خود قرار دهید
یه خردسال، خیلی خب، پس شروع می‌کنیم و حالا
اگر کد را اجرا کنم، می‌توانید ببینید
هر دوی آنها اعدام شده‌اند زیرا
سن اینجا در واقع بالای ۱۸ سال است، بنابراین اگر شما
می‌خوام فقط این رو اجرا کنم و نه این رو
شما از افزونه‌ای به نام
دستور else، دستور else چیست؟
آن
آیا این است که اگر این شرط نباشد
درست است که قرار است آنچه در درون من است اجرا شود
بیشتر ترجیح می‌دهم از آن استفاده نکنم، بنابراین من می‌روم
تا جایگزینش رو بهت نشون بدم، اوه، درسته
پس از آن، در اینجا می‌توانیم ببینیم زیرا
ثابت سن به صورت دستی روی ۲۵ تنظیم شد
اعلامیه به همین دلیل است که من می‌توانم، تو می‌توانی
به روشی که می‌توانید یک ثابت را تغییر دهید، آن را اصلاح کنید
اینجا به صورت دستی آن را فعال کنید، چه چیزی مانع آن می‌شود؟
کاری که باید انجام دهید این است که بعداً آن را تغییر دهید، مثلاً
سن، سن جدیدی رو تعیین می‌کنه، فقط مطمئن شو که من آره
این توسط سازمان ملل درک شده است، بنابراین گفتم که این کار را خواهم کرد.
یک جایگزین برای استفاده از lse به شما نشان می‌دهم
چیزی که ترجیح می‌دهم انجام دهم این است که
راستش را بخواهید، من نمی‌توانم این کار را اینجا انجام دهم، بنابراین...
قبل از اینکه بهت نشون بدم صبر کن چون
مفهوم دیگری هم هست که شما نمی‌دانید
هنوز این کار را نکرده‌اید، بنابراین شما آن را درک نخواهید کرد
ترفند، بنابراین اساساً برای الان، وگرنه اگر شما
نمی‌خواهم، پس اگر می‌خواهی بیشتر داشته باشی
از یک شرط اگرچه به عنوان مثال اگر
تو اینجایی و اگر و آنگاه بتوانی
دیگری داشته باشید
اگر و سپس در غیر این صورت اگر بتوانید وارد شوید
یک شرط دیگر و سپس آن را داشته باشید
اینجا، پس، پس این درست‌ترینه
و سپس شما آن را ارسال می‌کنید
برای مثال، در اینجا شرط بگذارید.
قرار دادن این درون یک متغیر
که نیازی به آن نیست، فقط همین بود
برای اینکه به شما نشان دهم می‌توانید این عبارت را قرار دهید
معمولاً در عبارت F چه چیزی وجود دارد
در یک کد واقعی اتفاق می‌افتد، بنابراین اگر سن
بالاتر از ۱۸ سال یا اگر سن برابر باشد
۱۸ اوه مساوی مساوی اما اوه تا ۱۸ و بعد
شما به اینجا نقل مکان می‌کنید تا به طور خاص
موقعیت‌هایی برای مثال دستور if
شما نقطه ویرگول را اضافه نمی‌کنید
چیز خاصی نیست، به همین دلیل است که من معمولاً ترجیح می‌دهم
نه اینکه از آن استفاده کنم، اما به هر حال من این کار را خواهم کرد
از آن استفاده کنید، بنابراین در اینجا ابتدا باید سن را در نظر بگیرید
بالای ۱۸ سال است، بنابراین می‌خواهم این را حذف کنم
این عبارت دیگر معتبر نیست
عبارت جاوا اسکریپت بنابراین اگر سن باشد
برتر از
۱۸ سپس اگر AG باشد، آن را چاپ خواهد کرد
برابر است با ۱۸ که می‌توانستید داشته باشید
یه پیام دیگه میگم کنسول. شما را ثبت نام کنید
فقط تبدیل شدن به
بزرگسال از نظر قانونی
بیایید
برو و حالا امم اگر من بروم
بیایید اینجا را ببینیم و محتوا را تغییر دهیم
بگو
۱۸ خواهی دید که داری میری
برای داشتن پیامی متفاوت و می‌توانید
در واقع شروع به ساخت بازی‌هایی مثل آن کنید
جایی که بسته به آن تغییر می‌دهید
چه بازیکنی را متفاوت دارید؟
ثابت‌ها یا متغیرها و سپس نشان می‌دهید
چیزهای مختلف اما این اساسی است
از یک دستور if if که اکنون در اینجا برابر است
مساوی که شاید عجیب به نظر برسد، خیلی مساوی
مساوی به این معنی است که از آنجایی که در جاوا اسکریپت شما
ما از علامت مساوی برای اعلام a استفاده می‌کنیم
متغیر یا مقداری را در آن ذخیره کنیم، um ما
به نماد متفاوتی نیاز دارید تا
اگر دو چیز برابر باشند، مقایسه کنید و
دو برابر مساوی چیزی است که استفاده می‌شود اما در واقع
این درست نیست، چیزی که استفاده می‌شود این است
سه برابر مساوی است زیرا در جاوا اسکریپت بنابراین در
هر زبان برنامه‌نویسی Pro San دیگر
برای مثال، شما پایتون را انتخاب می‌کنید.
دو مساوی برای تعیین اینکه آیا
چیزی برابر است با
دیگری و این خطایی است که من انجام می‌دهم
خیلی زیاد، پس اتفاقاً فقط وقتی هستی
وقتی شروع به نوشتن کد می‌کنید، مطالعه کنید
باید خیلی مراقب این نماد باشید
ذخیره کردن چیزی درون یک
متغیر یا ثابت هنگام تعریف
اما از دو مساوی برای آن استفاده می‌شود
چیزها را مقایسه کنید اما در جاوا اسکریپت
مخصوصاً شما که استفاده نمی‌کنید، هرگز
از این استفاده کنید از مساوی سه گانه استفاده کنید زیرا a
سه برابر مساوی دلیل اینکه ما یک
سه برابر مساوی است با این که اگر شما
برابر برابر و بیایید به جای آن بگوییم من هستم
قرار است همه اینها را حذف کنم و یک
اگر عبارت شرطی باشد و سن برابر باشد، برابر است.
۱۸ پس اینجا اگه این وضعیت باشه
در واقع اتفاق می افتد، ما می خواهیم بگوییم من
چیزی شبیه به BC نمی‌دانم
مهم نیست پس
اگر اینجا این را داریم، یعنی شما
می‌توانست a a رشته‌ای به شماره ۱۸ را تعریف کند و
پس این واقعاً درست خواهد بود
و با این وجود چاپ خواهد شد
این یک رشته و دیگری یک عدد است، بنابراین
اگر اینجا بروم، چاپ خواهد شد
ABC و این یک مشکل است زیرا
معمولاً وقتی این شرط را می‌نویسید
شما انتظار دارید که سن یک
شماره، به همین دلیل است که اگر از
سه برابر مساوی که بعداً اضافه کردم
در طول عمر جاوا اسکریپت همانطور که بود
انگار سال‌ها بعد توسعه پیدا کرده، اینطور نیست
قرار است آن را چاپ کنم، بنابراین به طور پیش‌فرض من
همیشه از سه‌گانه استفاده کنید
برابر است، بنابراین حالا اگر من یک
شماره واقعاً کار خواهد کرد، بنابراین
چه چیزی را تضمین می‌کند که سه برابر مساوی می‌شود؟
که نه تنها ارزش‌ها، بلکه
یکسان است اما نوع آن یکسان است، بنابراین
نوع داده می‌تواند رشته، عدد، بولی باشد.
و غیره هستند
همینطوره، پس من اینجا میرم، ABC قراره چاپ کنه
بیرون
همه
در حال حاضر چیزهای مختلف زیادی وجود دارد، ام
عباراتی مانند وقتی که مثلاً از آنها استفاده می‌کنید
شما نمی‌توانید انجام دهید
در واقع بله، شما نمی‌توانید این کار را انجام دهید، بنابراین
وقتی از above یا equal استفاده می‌کنید
و غیره، شما از علامت نقل قول تکی استفاده می‌کنید
اممم، یه علامت مساوی، ببخشید، قبلاً
یا بزرگتر است یا بزرگتر از
نمادی پایین‌تر از نماد و همچنین یک نماد جدید
یکی که شاید شما با آن آشنا نباشید
با نماد بنگ مساوی است، پس بنگ
مساوی یعنی مساوی نیست و اه
اگر به اینجا بروم، پس نماد را با بنگ مساوی می‌کنم
اساساً اینگونه است که شما می بینید ma در
کلاس‌های ریاضی که در آن دارید
الف) تو این را می‌دانی
نماد بله، اساساً اینطور نیست
مساوی، شما همچنین می‌توانید فقط بیشتر داشته باشید
بزرگتر از خودش است و دقیقاً به همین معنی است
یعنی چی؟
اوه پایین تر از
و غیره، اوه، بله، و همین، پس همه چیز همین است
در سطح پایه اینطور است، پس
فقط
به طور خلاصه، همه نمادها در اینجا آمده است
ما
کمتر و یا مساوی، بیشتر یا مساوی دیده شود
بیشتر پایین‌تر
برابر نیست برابر برابر بلکه برابر برابر است
سختگیرانه‌تر است یا کدام را ترجیح می‌دهید؟
روی این موضوع، پس حتی فراموش کن که این
خب، وجود داره، پس همینه، همینه
که حالا یک بله وجود دارد، پس این برای
دستورات شرطی دیگری هم وجود دارد
نوعی از گزاره شرطی به نام The
دستور switch به این صورت است که دستور switch
آیا این است و مثلاً طول می‌کشد؟
سن شما و سپس با آن مطابقت خواهد داشت
علیه پرونده
من ترجیح می‌دهم که پرونده‌ها حتماً ... باشند
به طور خاص برای مثال برای مورد 18 شما
آیا اینجا کمی منطق می‌نویسید و بعد؟
شما باید با استفاده از استراحت، از آن خارج شوید
کلمه کلیدی و غیره، فکر می‌کنم به عنوان یک مبتدی
زیاد بهش فکر نکن واقعا
می‌دونی که می‌تونی بنویسی، فقط ازش استفاده کن
اگر عبارات و شما باید خوب باشید برای
حالا بعداً در پایان ویدیو من هستم
من شما را به یک جاوا اسکریپت عالی ارجاع می‌دهم
منابع، آه، منبعی برای اگر می‌خواهید
الان عمیق تر برو، چیزهای بیشتری وجود دارد
انواع پیچیده‌ای از داده‌های U که می‌توانید قرار دهید
درون یک ثابت یا یک
متغیر و آن ها آرایه هستند و
اشیاء، پس بیایید با آرایه‌ها شروع کنیم، پس
آرایه‌ها به روشی که شما آنها را اعلام می‌کنید، برای
به عنوان مثال، من معمولاً ترجیح می‌دهم از const و
پس بیایید بگوییم که من یک دسته از آنها را دارم
اعداد و من می‌خواهم آنها را در داخل ذخیره کنم
یک ثابت واحد که قرار است از آن استفاده کنم
آرایه، روشی که شما یک آرایه را اعلان می‌کنید
ساده‌ترین راه استفاده از براکت‌هایی مانند
و سپس برای هر اسلاتی که می‌روید
داشتن یک عنصر بنابراین ۱ دو سه و
سپس آنها را با کاما از هم جدا می‌کنید، بنابراین این
این است که چگونه شما اعلام می‌کنید
ببخشید، شما یک آرایه تعریف کردید. (متاسفم، شما یک آرایه تعریف کردید.)
بنابراین ۱ دو سه این آرایه من است
شامل اعداد یک، دو و سه است
شما می‌توانید آرایه‌هایی داشته باشید که بتوانید
یک عنصر، یک عدد، و سپس
دوباره یک رشته و یک عدد و غیره اما
بیایید آن را ساده نگه داریم برای
حالا، بنابراین در اینجا ما یک آرایه و یک داریم
چیزی که مشکل ساز است این است که شما
یادتان هست که گفتم عدد ثابت
یعنی شما نمی‌توانید بعداً این را تغییر دهید
این یعنی شما نمی‌توانید بعداً
کد شما به اینجا بیاید و سپس با آن تغییر دهید
برای مثال یک آرایه دیگر که می‌گوید ۱ ۴
6 این به شما اجازه نمی دهد
این کار را انجام دهید، با این حال شما واقعاً می‌توانید تغییر دهید
هر um چگونه هر عنصر را به خودی خود می گوییم
هر کدام از محتوای هر یک از اسلات‌ها
اینجا ممکن است کمی پیچیده باشد زیرا
ممکن است فکر کنید که چیزها ثابت هستند
باید ثابت بماند اما در اینجا آرایه
خودش ثابت است، فقط محتواست
از آرایه‌ای که در حال تغییر است، به این صورت
شما به عناصر خاصی از یک آرایه دسترسی پیدا می‌کنید
این است که شما نام ... را می‌گیرید
آرایه‌ای که تعیین کردید و سپس در
پرانتزهایی که توی فهرست گذاشتی، پس اوه
نحوه کار آرایه به این صورت است که ابتدا
اسلات در ثانیه اول اندیس صفر دارد
اسلات دارای اندیس یک و یک و سوم است
اسلات دارای اندیس دو است و به همین ترتیب
به این معنی است که عنصر اول نیست
اولین اندیس با یک شروع نمی‌شود اما
با صفر، بنابراین اگر اعداد را صفر کنم، اینجا
و من آن را چاپ می‌کنم
بیرون، قراره یه چیزی داشته باشی
اینجا خیلی تسلی‌بخشه. لاگ و اعداد
اگر به آن نگاه کنم، برابر با صفر است
نتایجی که می‌توانید ببینید، یکی از آنها قرار است اتفاق بیفتد
اگر من یکی انجام دهم، منحنی را چاپ کن.
به عنوان شاخص نه عنصر، شاخص
از آن به سمت دو اشاره خواهد کرد
قرار است دو را چاپ کند و سپس اگر
من دو تا انجام میدم، میشه سه تا، پس تو
باید واقعاً دوست داشته باشید، به خاطر داشته باشید که
اینها ارزش‌ها و عناصرِ [...] هستند.
آرایه و اینها شاخص‌ها هستند، بنابراین
اساساً آدرس هر یک از آن
اسلات‌هایی که شامل یک، دو و سه هستند، بنابراین
اگر قرار بود به جای آن از اسامی استفاده کنید، فقط برای
نکته را به خوبی بیان کنید، بنابراین در اینجا یک
مجموعه‌ای از نام‌ها، بنابراین من آن را اینگونه می‌نامم
نام‌ها و سپس اینجا می‌توانید مثل من داشته باشید
نمی‌دانم
جان
اوه، فرض کنیم من هیچ ایده‌ای ندارم برای
نام‌ها اینجا مکس
شاید آنوقت
کریس، تو سه تا اسم داری و بعدش اینجا
اینها اساساً رشته هستند و اگر
شما تسلی می‌دهید. نام‌های ثبت شده در اندیس صفر
قراره تو رو چاپ کنه جان
جان، اگر به جای آن یکی انجام دهی، همین کار را خواهی کرد.
قرار است مکس و غیره را چاپ کند.
و غیره، پس حداکثر اینجا
و غیره، خب، حالا که آرایه‌ها را داریم
تو میتونی، میدونی که میتونی اینو داشته باشی
پس چطور میشه به جای قرار دادن
یک نکته منفی برای انجام دادن که به شما اجازه می‌دهد بتوانید
کل آرایه را جایگزین کنید، بنابراین شما
می‌تواند یک متغیر مانند زیر را دوباره تعریف کند
اما اینجا من یک آرایه خالی قرار می‌دهم
این یعنی وقتی که قرار است
کنسولی که به آن لاگین می‌کند
کنسول خواهد بود
خالی، قرار است تو را در آن خالی چاپ کند
پرانتز بله خالی
آرایه خیلی خب، امیدوارم فهمیده باشید
که نحوه کار آرایه‌ها در ... به این صورت است
سطح پایه اکنون عملیات وجود دارد
که در آرایه‌ها موجود هستند، بنابراین برای
به عنوان مثال، فرض کنید می‌خواهید مورد زیر را حذف کنید
آخرین عنصر یک آرایه، کاری که می‌توانید انجام دهید
آیا شما اسم‌ها را می‌نویسید؟ پاپ
این یک تابع یا بله، یک متد است، بنابراین من
اول باید توضیح بدم که تابع چیه
خب، پس می‌دونی چیه، بیا قبلش صبر کنیم
بهت یاد میدم که اون عملیات خیلی
حالا میدونی چی میگم
بهشون میگی عملیات، چون، چون
به هر حال console.log تابعی است که
تو به من میگی یه
روش اوه اما شما ممکن است، بنابراین من فقط هستم
فعلاً می‌روم به آنها زنگ می‌زنم
عملیات، بنابراین موارد خاصی وجود دارد
عملیاتی که می‌توانید انجام دهید
روی آرایه‌ها و یکی از آنها در
جاوا اسکریپت pop است که آخرین مورد را حذف می‌کند
اگر به اینجا بروم، می‌توانید ببینید که ما
جان مکس را دارم اما کریس دیگر نیست
اگر می‌خواهید اضافه کنید، ما Push را داریم.
عنصر به یک آرایه موجود، آنچه شما
می‌توان از عملیات push استفاده کرد و
از داخل پرانتز می‌توانید عبور دهید
در مرحله بعد عنصری که می‌خواهید
برای اضافه کردن به آن آرایه، بنابراین در اینجا می‌توانم
تصمیم بگیرید که اضافه کنید اوه، بیایید بگوییم امم
تاکویا و حالا اینجا اگر دلداری بدهم. ورود به سیستم
اون اسم‌ها می‌تونن آرایه رو ببینن
حالا قرار است یک دو سه چهار داشته باشیم
عناصری که می‌توانید طول یک
آرایه با انجام نقطه
طول، بنابراین این به شما طول
یک ARR، این همه چیز است مفاهیم برای R
ضمناً تجدید نظر کنید زیرا فکر نمی‌کنم
آنها را اینگونه به خاطر خواهی سپرد
اگر استفاده نکنید
همه آنها درست هستند، بنابراین نوع دیگری از داده
نوع شما می‌توانید در یک ثابت ارسال کنید.
یا متغیر نوع شیء است، بنابراین در اینجا
فرض کنید من یک شیء دارم
داده‌های من ثابت هستند و من آن را اینگونه می‌نامم
روشی که می‌توانید با استفاده از آن یک شیء را تعریف کنید
براکت‌هایی مثل اون، اوه، من همیشه فراموش می‌کردم
ستون نیمه‌خطی را اینجا در انتها قرار دهید.
روشی که ویرایشگر من جایگزین خواهد کرد، قرار خواهد گرفت
برای من به طور خودکار این اتفاق میفته، به همین دلیله که
به هر حال همیشه اونجا بود، اممم، اینجا، اوه، و
می‌توان به شیء طوری فکر کرد که انگار آنجاست
شما می‌توانید ویژگی‌ها و داده‌ها را ذخیره کنید، بنابراین
فکر می‌کنم بهترین راه این است که فقط به شما نشان دهم
یک مثال، بنابراین شما جفت‌های کلید-مقدار دارید
شما یک کلید را که می‌خواهید تعریف کنید، def
استفاده کنید و سپس مقداری که قرار است
با آن جفت شود، بنابراین برای مثال بیایید
بگو ما یک اسم داریم که تو می‌توانی در موردش تصمیم بگیری
نام کلید شما، می‌توانید آن را بنویسید، مثلاً
که بدون رشته با این حال اگر شما
می‌خواهم از چیزی به عنوان کلید استفاده کنم که
بیشتر از یک کلمه، مثلاً دو تا اسم ببرید
شما باید این را داخل پرانتز قرار دهید.
در داخل U چگونه علامت نقل قول را می گویید؟
اینجا هستیم زیرا ما از آنها در داخل استفاده نمی کنیم
ما فقط از یک نام پیش‌فرض استفاده می‌کنیم، اه
تکی بدون فاصله
اوه، ما به اسم نیازی نداریم و بعد تو ازش استفاده می‌کنی
دو نقطه و بعدش چی شد چی شد
به سمت راست می‌آید، مقدار است و اینجا
چیزی که می‌توانید اینجا قرار دهید دقیقاً یکسان است
می‌توانید داخل یک متغیر یا a قرار دهید
ثابت است، این همان نوع داده است، بنابراین
برای مثال، اسمی که می‌توانم انتخاب کنم
جان برای
به عنوان مثال و سپس در اینجا شما همیشه باید
فکر می‌کنم اگر شما کاما را قرار دهید، کاما را قرار دهید
فقط یک عنصر داشته باشید که ممکن است به آن نیازی نداشته باشید
اما معمولاً از کاما و سپس استفاده می‌کنید
می‌توانید یک چیز دیگر مثل سن اضافه کنید
بگو ۲۵ ۲۴ بیا
بگو و بعد همینطور ادامه بده و همینطور ادامه بده
یک روش مفید برای ذخیره حجم زیادی از داده‌ها
پس سن ام
برای مثال می‌توانیم بگوییم ملیت
آمریکا یا ایالات متحده
ایالات متحده آمریکا
و غیره، پس نکته جالب در مورد آن اشیاء این است که
که شما می‌توانید داده‌های من را طوری انجام دهید که به آن دسترسی داشته باشید
شما می‌توانید console.log را انجام دهید، یا می‌توانید
با استفاده از داده‌های من، کل آن را چاپ کن
بنابراین اگر نام شیء را داشته باشم،
شما قرار است سنی داشته باشید که
نام ببرید
ملیت یا می‌توانید آن را چاپ کنید
قطعات خاص اینجا با استفاده از نقطه
نمادگذاری بنابراین نقطه و سپس می‌توانید ببینید
خواص مختلف، بنابراین سن من فقط
می‌خواهید سنی را که می‌توانید داشته باشید چاپ کنید؟
یه چیزی که اینجا جالبه اینه که
با ام
شیء این است که می‌توانید موارد جدید را تعریف کنید
رکوردها یا ویژگی‌هایی که با استفاده از
خودِ نمادگذاری نقطه‌ای، بنابراین می‌توانم در موردش تصمیم بگیرم
یک ملک جدید پس از اعلام من
شیء، بنابراین در اینجا من آن را اینگونه می‌نامم
شاید
بیایید بگوییم قد و سپس برابر قرار دهیم
امضا و
پس شاید ۱۸۲، احتمالاً باید در CM قرار داده شود
یه اینچ میشه، پس فرض کن پنج اینچ
شش شش ۶
فوت، بنابراین ارتفاع داده من ۶ است.
پا و سپس شاید باید باشد
رشته اینجا 6 است
FD بنابراین اکنون اگر کنسول را چاپ کنم
با استفاده از
با استفاده از console.log در داده‌های من می‌توانید آن را ببینید.
یک رکورد جدید اضافه شده است، بیایید ببینیم
ارتفاعی که می‌توانید ببینید، حتی با اینکه
یک ثابت مانند آرایه‌ها که خواهد بود
به شما اجازه می‌دهد ویژگی‌های جدیدی را از درون اضافه کنید
همان آرایه‌ای که اجازه نمی‌دهد
کاری که باید انجام دهید این است که کل چیز را جایگزین کنید
با یک شیء جدید، بنابراین با انجام داده‌هایم اگر
اگر این کار را انجام دهید، دیگر این اتفاق نخواهد افتاد
به شما اجازه می‌دهد این کار را انجام دهید، بنابراین اینگونه است
شیء کار می‌کند و من می‌گویم آرایه‌ها و
اشیاء یکی از مفیدترین داده‌ها هستند
ساختارهایی که قرار است استفاده کنید
البته دلایل دیگری هم وجود دارد، آه، دلیلش چیست؟
تصمیم گرفتم اینجا در موردشون حرف نزنم...
فقط برای اینکه بار اضافی روی دوشت نذارم
پیچیده است و من واقعاً دارم بهت یاد میدم که بهت یاد بدم
فقط مفاهیمی که باید بسازید
بازی شما، یک بازی ساده و سپس به عنوان
تو عمیق تر خواهی شد، تو خواهی شد
احتمالاً جستجو کنید و سپس موارد جدید پیدا کنید
دارای ساختارهای داده جدیدی است که می‌توانید از آنها استفاده کنید
و غیره، خیلی خب، حالا که این کار را انجام داده‌اید
این جفت‌های کلید-مقدار و غیره، اوه، وجود دارد
یه راه دیگه هم هست که یادم رفت بگم
که شما می‌توانید از طریق آن به خواص دسترسی پیدا کنید
یک شیء که می‌توانید داده‌های من را انجام دهید و سپس
علامت گذاری را در یک براکت قرار دهید که به صورت زیر است:
مشابه چیزی که با آن دیدید
آرایه اما به جای ارسال عدد
اوه، کدام اندیس را می‌توانید ارسال کنید؟
نام ویژگی به صورت رشته‌ای
اینجا باید یک رشته باشد، پس این است
مخصوصاً وقتی مفید است که
خاصیتی که مثلاً از دو کلمه تشکیل شده است
بنابراین برای
مثال اوه، خوبه، من نمی‌دونم، من نمی‌دونم
ایده‌ای دارید که اینجا چه کار کنیم، بیایید بگوییم
ام سال تجربه، سال سابقه کار
XP و بعد فرض کنید دو
سال‌ها و سپس اینجا نمی‌توانید دسترسی داشته باشید
این با استفاده از نماد نقطه‌ای است
شاید تو واقعاً بتونی آره تو نمیتونی
قرار است منتقل شود، تو قرار است
عملیات خود را به یک
نمادگذاری آرایه، اوه، من نمی‌دانم چیست؟
نام آن اما این دیگری است
راه دسترسی به یک ویژگی خاص و
وقتی ملکی دارید، اجباری است
که یک رشته به شکل رشته است با
بیش از دو بیش از یک
کلمه، بنابراین شما واقعاً می‌توانید از آن روش استفاده کنید
دسترسی به خواص این با
موارد دیگر فقط با عبور از آن به عنوان یک
به جای age از string و سپس name از Etc استفاده کنید.
امیدوارم واضح بوده باشه، پس بعدی
به نظر من که خیلی قشنگه
درک حلقه‌ها بسیار مهم است، بنابراین حلقه‌ها
به شما امکان می‌دهد همان خط را تکرار کنید
کد یا چندین خط کد چندگانه
این کار خیلی مفید است، چون
به شما این امکان را می‌دهد که مطالب را تکرار کنید
و اه، تعمیم بده، پس تو این کار رو نکن
مثلاً اگر من مجبور باشم حرفم را تکرار کنم
می‌خواهم ۱۰۰ عدد را چاپ کنم، من نیستم.
قرار است یک console.log بنویسم.
console.log 2 3 4 5 100 بار که میشه
من را برای همیشه ببر و اینجا جایی است که چهار
حلقه‌ها مفید هستند، بنابراین چهار حلقه وجود دارد
اینگونه تعریف شده است، بنابراین برای چیزی، بنابراین
برای یک شرط بیان، چه کاری انجام دهید
داخل اینجا، پس برای اینکه بگیم اوه، این
جایی که یک
زیرا فرض کنید I برابر با z i کوچکتر از
۱۰۰ من ++ باشه، این ممکنه عجیب باشه و
من قصد دارم آن را توضیح دهم، بنابراین ما اعلام می‌کنیم
متغیری که قرار است به عنوان یک عمل کند
معمولاً برای مقابله با این قرارداد از آن استفاده می‌شود
یک حرف مثل I یا J یا چیزی شبیه به آن
مثل آن، و بعد قرار است
شامل می‌شود، بنابراین حلقه for شامل سه مورد است
عباراتی که اولین آنها ... است
اعلامیه آن شمارنده، شمارنده
مورد دوم، شرطی است که باید به دنبال آن باشید
بنابراین برای من که از ۱۰۰ پایین‌تر هستم، تا زمانی که من
اگر از ۱۰۰ پایین‌تر باشد، آنگاه
اجرا کن چی اونجاست و سومی
عبارت اینجا بعد از اجرای چیست؟
در آنجا افزایش می‌یابد، بنابراین اضافه کنید
با استفاده از Plus+ به مقدار I برسید
امضا کن، یه چیزی هست که یادم رفت بگم
آموزش این است که فرض کنید من یک
متغیری به نام شماره یک و آن
شامل پنج مورد است که می‌توانید با استفاده از آن به آن اضافه کنید
عدد یک به علاوه بعلاوه یعنی
محتوای شماره یک خواهد بود
پنج، اوه، راه دیگری که می‌توانید این کار را انجام دهید این است
جمع و تساوی را انجام دادن و سپس یک کردن
این یه راه دیگه برای انجام دادنشه، اوه تو
همچنین می‌تواند منها مساوی یک یا ضرب را انجام دهد
اگر می‌خواهید ضرب کنید، برابر با یک است و غیره.
شکل طولانی آن انجام دادنِ
محتوای شماره یک به علاوه یک که
پرگوترین روش انجام کار
این فقط یه چیزیه که به من مربوط میشه، آره به من مربوط میشه
یادم رفت درست و حسابی بهت یاد بدم، پس اینجام، پس
اگر اجازه داده باشم که با Z برابر باشد، باشه، پس بیا
چیزی اینجا بنویسید تا کنسول لاگ
و من فقط می‌خواهم اطلاعات واقعی را ثبت کنم
بنابراین اگر من به اینجا بروم، شما اینجا هستید.
می‌توان دید که از ۰ تا ... اجرا خواهد شد.
۹۹ بنابراین صفر است زیرا شمارنده شمارش بود
از صفر و ۹۹ شروع کردم چون می‌دونی
اگر قرار بود به جای آن یکی انجام دهم
اینجا هنوز تا ۹۹ اجرا میشه اما
اگر می‌خواهید چاپ کنید، از یک شروع کنید
اعداد از یک تا ۱۰۰ را که باید داشته باشید، استخراج کنید
به جای اینکه حقیر و حقیر جلوه کنی، این را تغییر بده
شما باید یا پایین‌تر باشید یا مساوی
پس اگر بروم
در اینجا شما تا
۱۰۰ پس بله، این همونه، پس این همونه
روش سنتی اولیه، شکل اولیه‌ی ...
حلقه و حالا با در نظر گرفتن یک چیز بیایید
مثلاً یادت هست که ما یک آرایه داشتیم، پس
فرض کنید آرایه‌ای از نام‌ها داریم و
شما می‌خواهید هر نام را چاپ کنید
فردی، بنابراین من دارم
جان جان مکس
کریس و و ما می‌خواهیم هر کدام از آنها را چاپ کنیم
آنها از یک حلقه for استفاده می‌کنند، پس شما چطور؟
انجام این کار، راه اساسی انجام آن است
اندیس I شمارنده به سمت صفر و پایین
اینجا ما فقط مطمئن میشیم که شاخص
شمارنده متاسفم که قرار است باشد
پایین‌تر از نام‌ها. طول اگر شما
به یاد داشته باشید با استفاده از طول نقطه ای که هستید
قرار است طول یک آرایه را بدست آوریم و
در اینجا طول یک آرایه سه است
چون سه تا هست
عناصر، بنابراین در اینجا در لاگ کنسول، من
می‌توانید اسم‌ها را بنویسید و اگر یادتان باشد،
شما می‌توانید اندیس را اینجا ارسال کنید، بنابراین از آن زمان
از صفر شروع میشه و قراره همینطور هم باشه
پایین‌تر از طولی که به معنای رفتن است
صفر یک و حداکثر دو باشد، بنابراین اگر من
اینجا انجامش بده و من می‌تونی جان مکس رو داشته باشی و
چی، این همونیه که قراره اینجا ظاهر بشه
‎‏ ...
صفحه نمایش، پس در کنسول، متاسفم، پس فقط
برای نشان دادن آنچه اتفاق می‌افتد این است که
اگر این را برای
مثال و بیایید اوه، پس کی حالم خوب است؟
فقط قراره اون رو کپی کنم که
کدی که قرار است اینجا به تخته بروم
قرار است آن را بچسبانید
اینجا و بیایید زوم کنیم
بنابراین آنچه در اینجا اتفاق می افتد این است که من قصد دارم
از قلم اینجا استفاده کنید تا ما
سه عنصر داشت شاید باید
فونت را افزایش دهید
سایز XL اینجا مناسب شماست، پس اینجا
باشه باشه پس اگه یادت باشه داشتیم
آن سه نام درون آرایه
و کاری که حلقه for انجام می‌دهد این است که
اگر این کار را انجام دهم، به
اعدام، این من هستم که اول قرار است باشم
برابر با
صفر، بنابراین در طول آن عبور اول
اسم اینکه قراره چی بشم چیه؟
اساساً برابر با نام‌ها
با صفر و اگر اندیس را به خاطر داشته باشید
صفر اولین اندیس آرایه است
چون ما یکی داریم و
دو، بنابراین اگر I بعد از آن برابر باشد با I
یکی از اسم‌ها برای من متاسف خواهد شد
فقیر
یکی اینجا با دست خط خودش نوشته، منظورم اینه که اسمش هست
یکی خواهد بود و چاپ خواهد شد
مکس را بیرون بیاورید، بنابراین اولین باری که چاپ می‌کند
کریس جان، ببخشید، دفعه دومه که این اتفاق می‌افته
چاپ مکس سوم به عنوان سومین بار من
برابر خواهد بود با
دو و اینجا، پس اتفاقی که می‌افتد این است که من
برابر با صفر باشد، جان را چاپ می‌کنیم و
سپس I ++ را برابر با I فعلی قرار می‌دهم.
یک و سپس در اینجا I برابر خواهد بود
به یکی که قراره چاپ بشه اه
مکس جان اینجاست
و سپس i++ وارد عمل خواهد شد
که اینجاست به یاد داشته باشید و این یعنی من
حالا برابر با دو است و سپس من اینجا هستم
برابر با دو است که به معنی مربع نام است
براکت ۲ به سمت ... اشاره خواهد کرد.
اسم کریس، پس کریس قراره باشه
چی چاپ شده؟
خارج می‌شود و i++ باعث می‌شود که I برابر با
سه و حالا
داریم I برابر با ۳
اینجا و اگر شما
یادت باشه ما اینو تا وقتی که من هستم اجرا می‌کنیم
پایین‌تر از نام‌ها. طول و نام‌ها.
طول به این معنی است که نام آرایه دارای یک
طول سه سه عنصر که
یعنی اینکه این وضعیت وجود ندارد
دیگر درست است، یعنی ما فرار نخواهیم کرد
حلقه for را دفعه دیگر به خاطر اینکه من
پایین‌تر از
نام‌ها طول دارند که همان است
آرایه اکنون false برابر با است با
غلطه، پس امیدوارم که اون شماتیک کوچیک باشه
اوه، نقاشی خیلی واضح بود، پس این درسته
چگونه یک حلقه for کار می‌کند و اکنون یک حلقه وجود دارد
نسخه ساده‌تر حلقه for که
جایی که نیازی به فکر کردن ندارید، نیست
مثل اینکه، این برای حلقه هنوز هست
در موارد خاص مفید است
موقعیت‌ها، اما نسخه آسان‌ترِ
حلقه for فقط برای انجام این کار در اینجا است، بنابراین const
نام نام‌ها و سپس می‌توانید فقط
هر یک از نام‌های موجود در آن را چاپ کن
آرایه و سپس اگر نگاه کنم
در اینجا در نتیجه می‌توانید آن را ببینید
همه چیز چاپ شد
اکنون این ممکن است گیج کننده باشد زیرا
نام از کجا آمده است، بنابراین در اینجا
ساده‌ترین نسخه حلقه for این است که
شما یک ثابت به نام name ایجاد می‌کنید، اما
لازم نیست اسمش باشه، می‌تونه باشه
هر اسمی اینجا هست، این فقط یه قرارداده
زیرا این منطقی‌تر است زیرا در
آرایه نام‌ها، آنچه برای هر کدام دارید
عنصر یک نام است، بنابراین شما باید مقدار ثابت را تعیین کنید.
نام متغیری که شما فقط انتخاب کرده‌اید
از و سپس آرایه و هر کدام ایجاد شده است
عنصر به آن اختصاص داده خواهد شد
ثابت است و سپس می‌توانید به آن مراجعه کنید
از درون حلقه for، خب، پس
حالا که حلقه for را دارید،
یک حلقه دیگر است که بسیار مفید است
حلقه while را حلقه while می‌نامیم.
چه کاری انجام می‌دهد؟ به طور مداوم ادامه دارد
اگر کد داخل آن را چاپ کنی، آن را اجرا می‌کنی.
شرط تا زمانی صادق است که
شرط درست است، حالا معادل I است.
به یک حلقه for فکر کنید که در آن فقط انجام می‌دهید
عبارت خالی اینجا عبارت خالی
راستش مطمئن نیستم که بتونی
در واقع این کار را در جاوا اسکریپت انجام دهید، بنابراین این
بی نهایت اجرا خواهد شد زیرا اینطور است
بی‌نهایت اجرا می‌شود، پس بگذارید امتحانش کنم
من به ندرت از این استفاده می‌کنم، پس همین کار را خواهم کرد
ضمناً این چیزی است که من فقط می روم
اگر می‌خواهی همین الان به تو یاد بدهم،
فقط برای آزمایش می‌خواهم خالی کنم
برخی از کدها از برخی موارد جلوگیری می‌کنند
اجرا شده می‌تواند کنترل شیفت را انجام دهد و این
بعداً آن را به یک نظر تبدیل خواهم کرد
من بهت یاد میدم که چی هست
کاربرد نظرات اما نظرات
مواردی که توسط کامپایلر نادیده گرفته می‌شوند
بنابراین شما این کار را نمی‌کنید، بنابراین با آنها مانند آنها رفتار نمی‌شود
کد، بنابراین اساساً راهی برای اضافه کردن است
یادداشت‌ها توضیح می‌دهند که چرا اوضاع این‌طور است
آنها به شکلی در کد هستند اما شما، شما
نباید زیاده‌روی کرد، اما این
ابزار و شما می توانید از آن برای خالی کردن استفاده کنید
بخش‌های خاصی از کد را که شما می‌نویسید،
نمی‌خواهم فقط برای آزمایش اجرا کنم
برای مثال، اگر من این کار را انجام دهم، اهدافی دارم
console.log فقط برای آزمایش آنچه که
اتفاق می افتد و نه من هیچ اتفاقی نمی افتد پس
هیچ چیز چاپ نمی‌شود
یا شاید آره، واقعاً قراره تموم بشه
مرورگر را از کار می‌اندازد، بنابراین اگر این کار را بکنم
این چیزیه که باید مراقب باشم، من نمی‌خوام
تصادف کردن
و اوه، فکر کنم خراب شد
مرورگر را می‌بندم و
صفحه وب را خراب می‌کند، نه مرورگر را، بلکه
پس اگر این کار را بکنم
این
اوه، باشه، پس اجرا میشه.
بی نهایت
بنابراین اگر فقط به شما نشان دهم که چگونه در حالی که
حلقه فقط یک حلقه for است اگر من یک حلقه داشته باشم.
شرط، فرض کنید داریم، بگذارید I برابر باشد
صفر، بنابراین مانند یک حلقه for
اساساً و سپس تا زمانی که من هستم
پایین‌تر از نام‌ها.
طول، بنابراین من قصد دارم آن را به عقب برگردانم، بنابراین من هستم
می‌خوام اینجا حذفش کنم، می‌خوام بذارمش
ثابت را برگردانید
تا زمانی که نام از طول آن پایین‌تر باشد
کاری که قراره انجام بدم اینه که من قراره
کنسول نام‌ها را ثبت می‌کند. با این شاخص، بنابراین
عنصر خاص واقعی و من هستم
قصد افزایش
شمارنده، بنابراین اگر این کار را انجام دهم، می‌توانید آن را ببینید
دقیقاً همان نتیجه‌ای را به شما می‌دهد که انگار
شما قرار بود از for استفاده کنید
حالا یه چیزی رو حلقه کن که فقط می‌خوام نشون بدم
اگر من هم همین کار را می‌کردم، تو همانی بودی
با یک حلقه for به جای آن، بنابراین من اینجا هستم
قصد دارم در مورد این یکی نظر بدهم، من می روم
راستی، برای ذخیره، کنترل را بزنید
مرتباً و در مقابل کد برای به‌روزرسانی موارد
فراموش کردم ویرایشگر کد را به‌روزرسانی کنم
کدی که قرار است اجرا شود چیست؟
در واقع به دلیل سرور زنده اجرا شود
کاری که انجام می‌دهد این است که هر بار که شما ذخیره می‌کنید
صفحه و شما را رفرش خواهد کرد
میزبان محلی، اوه محلی
سرور، بنابراین اگر من به جای مدتی اینجا باشم
از یک حلقه for استفاده کنید و در اینجا من از آن استفاده می‌کنم
چیز خالی، بنابراین عبارت «من این کار را نمی‌کنم»
اینجا تعریفش کن. من هم تعریفش نمی‌کنم.
دیگر
بیان من فکر می‌کنم در واقع باید باشد
دقیقاً مانند حلقه while عمل می‌کند
و همه کار را انجام می‌دهد
درست است، فقط برای نشان دادن آن، اما معمولاً ما
از حلقه for اینجوری استفاده نکن
یه جورایی عجیبه اما ما معمولاً ترجیح میدیم
از حلقه while استفاده کن اما فکر کنم go lank باشه
زبان برنامه نویسی دیگری که
حلقه while اختصاصی ندارد.
فقط از حلقه for در مسیر استفاده کنید
بهت نشون دادم که در موردش مطمئن نیستم
هرچند فکر می‌کنم به هر حال اینطور است، پس
این نحوه عملکرد حلقه while معمولاً است
برای شرایط خاص، آه، شما می‌خواهید
بررسی کنید که می‌خواهید شرط را به صورت زیر اجرا کنید
مادامی که شرط نادرست باشد، درست است
یا false شما می‌خواهید آنچه در Y است را اجرا کنید.
حلقه معمولاً به چه چیزی عادت ندارد
برای مثال، روی یک آرایه تکرار کنید
این اصطلاحی است که به آن iterate می‌گویند
وقتی می‌خواهید از جایی عبور کنید، از آنجا عبور کنید
آرایه و دریافت هر عنصر بنابراین برای
به عنوان مثال، می‌توانید اینجا محاسبه کنید
اگر محاسبه موفقیت آمیز باشد، آنگاه
شما متغیری مانند a را به from تغییر می‌دهید.
درست به غلط و سپس متوقف می‌شود
بنابراین این مورد استفاده برای حلقه while است
اما فعلاً خواهید دید چه زمانی
ما قصد داریم بازی‌هایمان را آنجا بسازیم
بسیاری از ویژگی‌های جاوا اسکریپت را ما نداریم
قرار است استفاده شود و برخی دیگر که
ما قصد داریم از یک
زیاد است اما فکر می‌کنم خیلی مهم است
ساخت، به همین دلیل است که من می‌خواستم
بهت یاد میدم که خیلی خب، فکر کنم یکی از
مهمترین مفاهیم این است
مفهوم تابع، بنابراین یک تابع عبارت است از
بسیار مهم است زیرا در واقع
چه چیزی به شما امکان می‌دهد که قابل استفاده مجدد داشته باشید؟
کد منطقی قابل استفاده مجدد که می‌توانید به جای آن
از کپی کردن و چسباندن کد خود در هر جایی که هستید
معمولاً با استفاده از یک تابع، آن را ایجاد می‌کنیم.
تابع
کلمه کلیدی و سپس تابع چیست؟
کلمه کلیدی does ابتدا برای اعلام کردن است
عملکرد و سپس باید در مورد آن تصمیم بگیرید
یک اسم، بنابراین اینجا اسمی است که می‌خواهم به آن اشاره کنم
تصمیم در مورد این خواهد بود که من نمی‌دانم.
بیایید آن را صدا بزنیم، بیایید تابع را صدا بزنیم
اضافه کردن یا جمع کردن یا شاید، اوه، می‌دونی
بیایید آن را چه بنامیم؟ اضافه کردن و قرار است
برای جمع دو عدد استفاده می‌شود، بنابراین این است
تابع پایه، بنابراین تابع اینجا چیست؟
شما می‌توانید از آن به همین دلیل استفاده کنید
قدرتمند این است که می‌توانید آن را به عنوان یک
الگو، بنابراین می‌توانید از الگویی که دارید استفاده کنید
داده‌ها را اینجا وارد کنید و سپس آنها را قرار دهید
درون منطق خود و سپس می‌توانید
منطق خود را با آنچه نیاز دارید تطبیق دهید، بنابراین
در اینجا ما به یک تابع نیاز داریم
که به شما امکان می‌دهد هر دو عدد دلخواه را جمع کنید
هر کدام از آنها، بنابراین اینجا پرانتز را اینجا قرار دهید
مفید است زیرا جایی است که ما تعریف می‌کنیم
پارامترها پارامترهایی هستند که
تابع قبول خواهد کرد و اساساً
می‌توانید آن را به عنوان یک تغییر کوچک در نظر بگیرید
مقادیر، بنابراین می‌توانید مقادیر را به آن منتقل کنید
تابعی برای تطبیق آن با وضعیت شما
بنابراین بیایید بگوییم که شماره یک را داریم
اولین پارامتر ما، بنابراین روشی که شما تعریف می‌کنید
پارامتری که هنگام تعریف یک تابع استفاده می‌شود، به صورت زیر است:
فقط تماس بگیرید، فقط در مورد یک نام تصمیم بگیرید و
بعد اینجا تصمیم گرفتم بهش بگم شماره
و سپس با ویرگول از هم جدا کنید.
پارامتر دومی که می‌خواهید استفاده کنید، آه
تابع می‌تواند هیچ pam نداشته باشد یا می‌تواند داشته باشد
یک پم دو پم و غیره، پس به خودت بستگی داره
اینجا در شرایط ما، ما می‌خواهیم بتوانیم
برای جمع کردن دو عدد، به همین دلیل است که من ابتدا
عدد اول را بگیرید و سپس
عدد دوم و سپس در اینجا یک تابع
معمولاً می‌تواند یا برگردد یا نه
هیچ چیز یا شما می‌توانید یک مقدار را برگردانید، بنابراین
اینجا من فقط قصد ندارم برگردم
هر چیزی اما من قصد دارم وارد کنسول شوم، بنابراین
من قصد دارم در کنسول چاپ کنم
نتیجه‌ای که عدد یک به علاوه است
شماره
دو، حالا اینجا باید مراقب باشید
زیرا می‌توانید یک رشته را اینجا ارسال کنید
این به تو بستگی نداره که مراقب باشی اه
اگر قرار بود از برنامه‌نویسی تایپی استفاده کنید
زبانی که متفاوت خواهد بود زیرا
شما باید نوع را مشخص کنید، بنابراین
برای مثال اگر قرار بود استفاده کنید
در تایپ اسکریپت، شما مشخص می‌کنید که این
باید یک عدد نوع و دیگری باشد
یکی هم همینطور، پس فقط یادت باشه، یادت باشه
که وقتی از یک دینامیک استفاده می‌کنید
زبان، زبانی که الزام‌آور نیست
تایپ کردن مثل جاوا اسکریپت چیزیه که بهش نیاز داری
مراقب باش چی به بقیه میدی
توابع یا عملیاتی که شما انجام می‌دهید
این کار را انجام دهید، بین این دو تفاوت وجود دارد
تعریف تابعی که از
کلمه کلیدی تابع و فراخوانی آن
تابع، بنابراین فراخوانی تابع همان چیزی است که
در واقع تابع تعریف شده را اجرا می‌کند
مثل یک متغیر است، مثل چیزی که شما دارید
متغیری که می‌توانید آن را در جایی که می‌خواهید تعریف کنید
مقدار را تعریف کنید و سپس می‌توانید فراخوانی کنید
اسمشو نمیذارم ولی بهش نگاه کن
محتوای آن را تغییر دهید یا با استفاده از آن را اصلاح کنید
علامت مساوی فقط نام بدون
کلمه کلیدی که قبل از آن آمده است، بنابراین در اینجا
برای تابع، تابع را اعلان می‌کنم
و سپس می‌توانم با استفاده از add و ... آن را فراخوانی کنم.
سپس عبور از یک و دو یا سه یک
و دو و آنچه باید چاپ شود
کنسول نتیجه است
سه، حالا یک چیز که باید نگه دارید
نکته این است که در حالی که اجرای کد
متوالی است، بنابراین شما ۱ ۲ ۳ ۴ ۵ ۶ و غیره دارید
توابع را می‌توان گام به گام تعریف کرد
به هر ترتیبی که باشد، یعنی اینطور نیست
مهم نیست که تابع را قبل از آن فراخوانی کنم
اعلام شده است. فکر می‌کنم این هنوز باید باشد
کار کن، پس اگر بروم، به آن نگاه می‌کنم، دارد می‌رود
تا هنوز هم دلیلش را به تو بگویم
دلیل این امر این است که روش جاوا اسکریپت
کدی که اجرا می‌شود این است که ابتدا تجزیه می‌شود
کد شما و قرار است ابتدا لایک شود
به عملکردهای مختلفی که دارید نگاه کنید
و آنها را تجزیه کنید، بنابراین قرار است
اساساً آنها را ثبت کنید که وجود دارند
پس به همین دلیل مهم نیست
ترتیب زمانی که آن تابع را فراخوانی می‌کنید
می‌توانم قبل از اعلام، آن را فراخوانی کنم
زیرا نحوه تجزیه توابع
ترتیبی نیست، اما کدی است که
به صورت متوالی اجرا می‌شود، امید است که
تمایز این است که
واضحه اما معمولاً ترجیح میدم خودت بدونی
ابتدا یک تابع تعریف کنید و
پس ازش استفاده کن به جای اینکه بدونی چیکار میکنی
حالا که این را داریم، من نیاز دارم که
در مورد دستورات return صحبت کنید، همانطور که من
گفت یک تابع می‌تواند چیزی را برگرداند یا
اگر به جای کنسول باشد، اینجا چیزی نیست.
من می‌خواهم نتیجه را گزارش کنم (loging)
می‌تواند برگردد و قرار است برگردد
مقدار، بنابراین چه چیزی را برمی‌گرداند؟
یعنی اینکه قراره فقط بده
شما ارزش را دارید، بنابراین برای مثال اگر من فقط
تابع را اینجا فراخوانی کن، الان هیچی نیست
قراره توی کنسول اتفاق بیفته
زیرا هیچ چیز قابل مشاهده نیست، هرچند شما
می‌تواند انجام دهد
console.log و
سپس تابع را از درون آن فراخوانی کنید
console.log و سپس شما قصد دارید
نتیجه رو داری، اوه، نه یه عدد، اوه
این اوه آه نیست چون من قبول نشدم
پارامترهایی که به آنها نیاز داریم، یکی هستند و
دو، بنابراین انجام این کار به ما می‌دهد
نتیجه الان چیه که برگردی اینجا؟
این است که اغلب اینطور نیست که شما
آیا واقعاً می‌خواهید لاگ کنسول را بدانید؟
بلافاصله ممکن است بخواهید، برای مثال
برای داشتن یک نتیجه ثابت در اینجا، را فراخوانی کنید
تابع تبلیغ، فرض کنید ۱ + ۲ و سپس um
و سپس با نتیجه‌ای که می‌خواهید به دست آورید
یک فراخوانی دیگر برای تابع تبلیغ داشته باشید
با یک نتیجه قبلی به علاوه، فرض کنید
دوباره دو سه و بعد می‌خوای
نتیجه نهایی را چاپ کنید، بنابراین این یک
مورد استفاده، یک مورد استفاده بسیار ساختگی اما
این یک مورد استفاده است
با این وجود، همینه، همینه
اینگونه است که شما یک تابع را اعلام می‌کنید، چگونه
شما اعلام می‌کنید که کالسکه و غیره، این
اصول اولیه آن اکنون یکی دیگر از موارد بسیار مهم است
بخشی و مفهوم دیگری که می‌گویم این است
بسیار مهم است که ما نیاز داریم
بدانید که چگونه چیزها به چه چیزی منتقل می‌شوند
‎‏ ...
تابع، بنابراین چیزی در آن وجود دارد
برنامه‌نویسی به نام ارسال با ارجاع
یا عبور از مقدار، بنابراین عبور از کنار
مرجع زمانی است که فرض کنیم من دارم
یک عدد ثابت به عنوان عدد یک تعریف کنید
بیرون به نام پنج، من یکی دیگر را اعلام می‌کنم، اوه
به نام بیایید بگوییم چهار عدد برای وقتی که من
اینجا اضافه کن، بیا اوه، بیا برای
برای شروع بحث، فرض کنید شما یک
بگذارید اینجا و سپس اگر من اینجا را هم بگذارم
شماره یک و شماره را وارد کنید
دو و بیایید بگوییم به جای اینجا از
فقط اضافه کردن کاری که من انجام می‌دهم این است که واقعاً سعی می‌کنم
برای تغییر محتوای شماره یک اگر من
به جای شماره یک، اینجا انجام بده، داره میاد
مثل این است که شش را بلد باشی و بعد عدد را بشماری
دو خواهد بود، می‌دانی که خواهد بود
بودن
پنج وقتی که می‌خواهم چاپ کنم
بیرون کنسول. لاگ شماره یک و
شماره console.log
دو اگر به نتایج نگاه کنید،
قراره پنج تا داشته باشیم و چهار تا، هیچی نداره
تغییر کرد، پس بیایید بگوییم حتی
مثلاً بیایید حتی این را هم نادیده بگیریم، بیایید بگوییم
دیگر تابع تبلیغ نامیده نمی‌شود
بیایید آن را اصلاح بنامیم، من قصد دارم
سعی کنید این دو متغیر را تغییر دهید
نمی‌توان این کار را انجام داد و دلیل آن چیست؟
این است که آنچه به یک تابع ارسال می‌شود،
منظور از مقدار این است که مقدار را می‌گیرد
از متغیر یا ثابت خود و سپس
قرار است درون آن خلق شود
تابعی از یک متغیر محلی به نام number
یک و شماره دو در این مورد که
یعنی حتی اگر از درون آن را تغییر دهم
تابعی که قرار نیست روی آن تأثیر بگذارد
الان از بیرون چی میاد؟ این یه کم پیچیده‌ست
زیرا در جاوا اسکریپت می‌توانید موارد زیر را داشته باشید:
چیزهای خاصی که از کنارشان رد می‌شویم
ارجاع در یک تابع، بنابراین توسط مقادیر
وقتی شما مقداری را ارسال کردید که
یعنی مهم نیست درونت چه کار می‌کنی
تابعی که هرگز تغییر نخواهد کرد
محتوای بیرونی که خوب است اما در
حالت خاص با آرایه‌ها و اشیاء
در واقع قرار است تغییر کند
محتوا، بنابراین این چیزی بسیار پیچیده است
فرض کنید یک پارامتر واحد داریم که
قرار است یک آرایه باشد که من می‌خواهم
اسمشو بذار من
آرایه و من قصد دارم این را حذف کنم و
من هم همه اینها را حذف خواهم کرد
بنابراین این تابع را اصلاح کنید، فرض کنید ما
سعی خواهم کرد آرایه را با استفاده از ... بازنویسی کنم.
آن را به عنوان یک آرایه خالی قرار دهید و سپس
بله، فقط همین کار را می‌کند
که حالا کاری که قراره اینجا انجام بدم اینه که
من قصد دارم یک آرایه به نام تعریف کنم.
در واقع من فکر می‌کنم
اگر من اینجا از const استفاده کنم، مثلاً فرض کنید من
آرایه و فرض کنید یک آرایه داریم
دو سه فکر می‌کنم این واقعاً ممکن است
مانع از انجام این کار توسط ما شوید زیرا ما
اگر تماس بگیرم، به هر حال از یک ثابت استفاده می‌کنم
آرایه من را تغییر داده و ارسال کنید زیرا
آرایه‌ها و اشیاء توسط ... ارسال می‌شوند.
اگر تسلی دهم، به آن رجوع کن. آرایه را لاگ کن
باید اصلاح شود مگر اینکه به دلیل استفاده من باشد
ثابتی که قرار است از آن محافظت کند
در برابر اصلاح، بنابراین اگر این کار را انجام دهم
ببینیم
یک دو سه و شما می‌توانید آن را ببینید
هیچ چیز تغییر نکرده، باشه، همین
اوه باشه، اوه اوه، بیخیال، اممم
اینطور نیست، اینطور نیست، این طبیعیه
وقتی آرایه را ارسال می‌کنید
خودش قرار نیست آن را تغییر دهد، بنابراین
شما نمی‌توانید آرایه را تغییر دهید، بنابراین آرایه
انگار از ارزشش گذشته‌ای
نمی‌توان آرایه را بازنویسی کرد، تنها...
قسمت سختش این بود ببخشید اگه گیجتون کردم
پس چنان گذشت که گویی از کنارش گذشته‌اند
ارزش دارد اما با این حال اگر فشار دهید، این بدان معناست
فرض کنید شما محتوایی را به آن آرایه اضافه می‌کنید
۱۲۱ قرار است نسخه اصلی را تغییر دهد
آرایه به این معنی است که به همین دلیل است که می‌گویم
با ارجاع ارسال شد، بنابراین اگر من به اینجا بروم، شما
می‌توان دید که به خارجی اضافه شده است
آرایه در اینجا عددی را که بود اضافه کرد
از درون um اضافه شد، اصلاح کنید
توابعی که به این معنی است که آرایه‌ی my
اینجا کپی نیست، اوه، این یک کپی نیست
یک کپی مستقل از آرایه‌ی my که
خارج از تابع است و این
مشکل است زیرا اگر مراقب نباشید،
شاید فکر کنی که تو اینطور نیستی
آرایه را تغییر می‌دهید اما در واقع شما
تغییر آرایه اصلی به طوری که شما
ممکن است فکر کند که شما در حال تغییر نیستید
آرایه اصلی که امن است اما
اینطور نیست و عملیاتی مانند فشار دادن پاپ
و غیره، محتوای آرایه را تغییر دهید
آرایه حتی در خارج به طوری که آن باشد
با ارجاع ارسال شد، اما شما نمی‌توانید
در واقع آرایه را بازنویسی می‌کنم، بنابراین اگر این کار را انجام دهم
این قرار نیست پخش شود، بنابراین
آرایه من خارج از تغییر چیست؟
عملکرد هنوز هم یکسان خواهد بود
اوه، همان مقدار اوه، بنابراین به شما می‌دهد
به آن اشاره کنید اما اگر آن را حذف کنید
محتوا قرار نیست پخش شود، بنابراین
این یک چیز فریبنده و چالش برانگیز است، بنابراین اگر شما
نیاز به گرفتن یک آرایه از بیرون داریم
و انجام مجموعه‌ای از عملیات درون یک
کاری که من به شما توصیه می‌کنم انجام دهید این است که
شما یک کپی از آن آرایه ایجاد می‌کنید، بنابراین یا
می‌توانید از عملگر اسپرد و غیره استفاده کنید
بنابراین عملگر اسپرد چیزی شبیه به این است
که پس مال منه
آرایه می‌تواند انجام دهد
این من فکر می‌کنم این
باید انجام دهد
ترفند این کار را از درون یک آرایه انجام می‌دهد که
بنابراین محتوای آرایه را می‌گیرد و
عنصر خود را درون یک آرایه جدید prad می‌کند
سه نقطه این کار را انجام می‌دهد، بنابراین این یک
فقط چیزی که می‌خواهم
خب، حالا که یاد گرفتی، همه چیز را درست بیان کن
در مورد این تفاوت ظریف باید مراقب باشید
فکر می‌کنم ما از این مرحله عبور کرده‌ایم
من به شخصه میگم مفاهیم Bare Bones
شما نیاز دارید
برای یادگیری جاوا اسکریپت وجود دارد
یکی دو تا از مفاهیم آخری که به نظرم میاد
اولین
متغیر محلی در مقابل متغیر سراسری است، پس در
توابع با استفاده از توابعی که شما
احتمالاً به طور شهودی فهمیدم
مفهوم، بنابراین اگر ما یک تابع داشته باشیم
بیایید بگوییم آن را اصلی بنامیم و شما یک
مثلاً ثابتی خارج از جان، بنابراین اگر
تو اسمی به اسم جان داری، می‌تونی داشته باشیش
دسترسی به آن از داخل یک
تابع با چاپ نام اینجا، بنابراین اینجا
منسوخ شده، اوه، باشه، پس این یه چیزیه
با جاوا اسکریپت، بنابراین بیایید بگوییم من
فقط برای متفاوت بودن، نامی انتخاب کنید، مطمئن شوید که
اسم منحصر به فرد است، پس اشکالی ندارد، پس ما داریم
در اینجا، بنابراین اگر تابع اصلی را برای آن فراخوانی کنم
مثال بزنید و به نتیجه‌ای که می‌توانید نگاه کنید
ببینید جان چاپ شده است، یعنی اینکه
این چیزی است که در خارج اعلام شده است
به صورت جهانی قابل دسترسی است، به این معنی که
حتی از درون توابع نیز قابل دسترسی است
که نزدیک یا خارج از آن اعلام می‌شوند
بنابراین این یعنی چه؟ اگر
شما اینجا یک تابع تعریف می‌کنید
توست اوه من
نام مکس برای
مثال، سپس این، این، متغیر این
ثابت از طریق قابل دسترسی نیست
بیرون از اینجا نمی‌تونم با کسی همدردی کنم. نام من را ثبت کنید
اینجا اگه حذفش کنم کار نمی‌کنه
این در واقع فقط برای آزمایش آن است
قرار است جان را چاپ کند اما مکس را نه.
از درون تابع اصلی، این است
قرار است مکس را چاپ کنم
بنابراین نزدیکترین مقدار را می‌گیرد
نزدیکترین اعلامیه، بنابراین اگر من این کار را انجام دهم، شما
می‌تونم جان مکس رو ببینم، پس این چیزیه که تو باید ببینی
اگر می‌خواهید در این مورد محتاط باشید
چیزی که در سطح جهانی برای شما قابل دسترسی باشد
اگر می‌خواهی باید آن را بیرون بگذاری
چیزی محلی که شما آن را قرار می‌دهید، اعلام می‌کنید
متغیر، ثابت از
درون تابع و این کار می‌کند
همین کار را با دستور if و غیره انجام دهید، بنابراین اگر شما
یک دستور if داشته باشید، فرض کنید من فقط
این را به حقیقت تبدیل خواهم کرد، یعنی اینکه
اگر اعلام کنم، به هر دو صورت خواهم دوید، امم
یک سن فراخوانی متغیر و فرض کنید ۱۲
سپس تسلی دهید. ثبت کردن
سن، اوه، این جواب میده اما اگه من بخوام
کنسول، سن را از خارج از if ثبت می‌کند.
اگر این کار را بکنم، بیانیه کار نخواهد کرد
این سن نیست
تعریف شده، پس امیدوارم اینو فهمیده باشی اه
تفاوت بین یک سیستم محلی جهانی
متغیر و نحوه عملکرد دامنه بنابراین
خودِ مفهوم، دامنه نامیده می‌شود.
از متغیرها و ثابت‌ها
پس بله، اگر چیزی می‌خواهید،
فقط به صورت محلی که اعلام می‌کنید قابل دسترسی باشد
تا حد امکان نزدیک به جایی که شما هستید
بهش نیاز دارم، پس همینه که هست و بعد
بالاخره نظراتی وجود دارد، بنابراین در [بخش نظرات] شما [اینجا] هستند.
کدی که می‌توانید با استفاده از آن نظرات را اضافه کنید
نماد داس (Das) و سپس نوشتن آن
متن و معمولاً نظرات شما چیست؟
آنها را برای دیگران و خودتان به
توضیح دهید که چرا اوضاع به این شکل است
هستند و نه کاری که کد انجام می‌دهد زیرا
کدش چیه، می‌تونی بخونیش؟
خودتان وقتی برای اولین بار شروع می‌کنید
برنامه نویسی برای شما خیلی سخته
برای اینکه بدونم کد واقعاً چیه
باید بشینم خط به خط بخونم و غیره
اما وقتی باتجربه‌تر می‌شوید
برنامه نویس، تو واقعاً میتونی فقط همین باشه
خواندنش خیلی ساده است
تکه‌ای از کد را بررسی کنید و بفهمید چیست
اتفاق می افتد بنابراین نظرات مفید هستند
نظراتی که توضیح می‌دهند چرا اوضاع این‌طور است
آنها اینطور نیستند که چگونه کار می کند، پس چرا برای
به عنوان مثال، شما مجبور بودید از این وضوح استفاده کنید
بنابراین شما مجبور بودید const را با عدد ۱۰۰۰ تعریف کنید.
چیزی به دلیل این محدودیت و ...
ما باید این نسبت ابعاد و غیره را داشته باشیم
که برای کسی که می‌خواهد بداند، مشخص نیست
کد را بخوانید، اینجا جایی است که یک نظر وجود دارد
اضافه کردن یک نظر بسیار مفید خواهد بود
خیلی مفید، اوه، همین. فکر کنم ما
مفهوم اولیه را داشته باشید و سپس ما
میشه یه نکته آخر هم بگم؟
در واقع یک مفهوم جاوا اسکریپت نیست
خودش، اما خیلی مهم است که چگونه
کد خود را ماژولار کنید، موارد دیگری نیز وجود دارد
مفاهیم جاوا اسکریپت رو عمداً دارم
بدون توضیح گذاشتمش و تو این قسمت نیست
البته فقط برای اینکه بهش نرسم
به عنوان مقدمه برای شما سنگین است اما اکنون
این خیلی چیز خیلی مهمی است
فرض کنیم می‌خواهی، اما نمی‌توانی
برنامه‌های کوچکی که می‌توانید شرکت خود را بنویسید
همه را در یک فایل واحد کد کنید اما به محض اینکه
تو بیشتر مالِ پروژه‌های خودت می‌شوی
پیچیده‌تر خواهد شد، قرار است
وقت آن رسیده که بتوانیم آن را تقسیم کنیم
به چندین فایل مختلف و
روش انجام این کار در جاوا اسکریپت با استفاده از این
راه اندازی ساده است، روش قدیمی وجود دارد و
یه راه جدید هست، راه قدیمی اینه که
اگر می‌خواهید از چندین فایل استفاده کنید،
روشی که شما این کار را انجام می‌دهید این است که شما، مثلاً من،
یک فایل کد دیگر ایجاد کنید و من می گویم
برای مثال دم‌های UT. JS که در حال رفتن است
شامل چند تابع باشد که اجازه می‌دهد
عملیات خاصی مانند شماره یک
شماره
دو، بنابراین این قرار است مجموع را برگرداند
بین آن دو عدد، عدد ... است
قطعه کد قابل استفاده مجددی که می‌خواهم از آن استفاده کنم
فایل main.js من، همانطور که شما انجام می‌دهید
آیا شما آن را به روش قدیمی وارد می‌کنید؟
به HTML شما برمی‌گردد، اضافه می‌کردید.
یک منبع تگ اسکریپت و سپس مسیر
به سوی آن
فایل را ذخیره کنید و سپس فراموش نکنید
پرانتز را می‌بستیم و بعد می‌رفتیم
به سمت دسر اصلی‌ات و بعد تو، تو
قادر به فراخوانی آن تابع خواهد بود
اعدادی که می‌خواهید کجا هستند، بنابراین می‌توانید
بتواند از آن تابع در آن استفاده کند
در فایل utils از داخل خودتان
فایل main.js بنابراین اگر به نتیجه نگاه کنم
می‌بینید که الان واقعاً کار می‌کند
این روش قدیمی است و این هم خواهد شد
به سرعت کثیف می‌شوید، همانطور که پیش می‌روید
تعداد زیادی تگ اسکریپت اضافه کنید، این مورد مناسب نیست.
راه درست این است که برویم زیرا اخیراً خوب است
نسبتاً اخیراً چیزی وجود دارد
یک ماژول جاوا اسکریپت نامیده می‌شود، بنابراین جاوا اسکریپت
ماژول کاری که به شما امکان می‌دهد انجام دهید این است که
از یک ایمپورت استفاده کنید
بنابراین به جای داشتن فایل شما، sytax
اینجا اوه، شما فقط می‌توانید از add استفاده کنید
یهویی اینجوری شد
چون قبلاً تگ اسکریپت را اضافه کرده‌اید
و ضمناً با این روش قدیمی
به ترتیبی که اسکریپت خود را وارد می‌کنید
برچسب مهم است زیرا اگر من را وارد کنید
بعد از آن به تگ اسکریپت فکر کنید، پس بیایید
فقط برای درست کردنش امتحانش کن
مطمئنم اگر این کار را بکنم
کدهای کمکی، بنابراین فرض کنید من این را وارد می‌کنم
از تابع add بعد از تعریف استفاده می‌کند
حالا که کار نمی‌کند، پس اگر من اینجا باشم
به نتیجه‌ای که می‌توانید بگویید جمع است نگاه کنید
تعریف نشده است، بنابراین این یکی از موارد بسیار مهم بود
چیزهای پیچیده این است که شما باید باشید
به ترتیبی که در آن قرار دارید دقت کنید
شما تگ‌های اسکریپت خود را وارد می‌کنید، بنابراین
به نظر من این واقعاً راهش نیست
امروز، بنابراین راه رفتن استفاده از آن است
ویژگی ماژول جاوا اسکریپت که چیست
اتفاقی که می‌افتد این است که شما یک نوع را مشخص می‌کنید
ویژگی نوع
و چیزی که به H میگی
مرورگری که این نوع JS را دارد
فایل از نوع ماژول خواهد بود
یعنی اینکه شما میتونید از نسخه جدید استفاده کنید
نحوه‌ی کار آن به چه صورت است؟
دنبال کردن، بنابراین من در
.js می‌توانم اضافه کنم
کلمه کلیدی export را export کنید و سپس از
main.js که می‌توانم انجام دهم
وارد کنید و سپس با استفاده از براکت، بذر را اضافه کنید
از ابزارهایی که باید اضافه کنید
JS بنابراین UIL اینجاست
مسیر، مسیری که تابع در آن قرار دارد
اگر تعریف شده باشد، در اینجا داخل پرانتز قرار می‌گیرد.
شما فقط از export استفاده می‌کنید اما اگر استفاده کنید
صادرات پیش‌فرض، یعنی تنها چیزی که
اکسپورت نام‌گذاری شده اکسپورت شده است
مستقیماً اضافه خواهد شد، بنابراین شما در حال رفتن هستید
برای انجام این کار و حالا تابع add
در دسترس خواهد بود و ادامه خواهد داشت
برای اجرای توکن غیرمنتظره‌ی export، اکنون
صادرات uh صادرات پیش‌فرض
اه چرا چرا کار نمیکنه
اممم، بذار اینو بردارم، ببینیم چی میشه.
اگر واقعاً
UIL خروجی ارائه نمی‌دهد.
نام
پیش فرض، اوه، یه لحظه صبر کن، اگه این کار رو بکنم
خب، باشه، پس اگه صادر کنی
و سپس باید این را درون آن قرار دهید
براکت ها
اگر به نتیجه بروم، چاپ می‌شود اما
خطای نحوی غیرمنتظره در اکسپورت توکن
راستی، اگه اینجا فایل .js بذارم، اشکالی نداره.
باید این را حذف کنید در غیر این صورت شما
با این کد جدید، خطایی دریافت خواهید کرد.
روشی که فقط باید ورودی را وارد کنید
نقطه‌ای که فایل JS یعنی main.js است
لازم نیست این واقعی شما باشد
به نام main.js، این فقط نامی است که شما دارید
در مورد نقطه ورود تصمیم بگیرید و سپس شما
وقتی هستی، ماژول نوع را به آن بده
آن را با استفاده از دستور زیر به HTML خود وارد کنید
برچسب اسکریپت و سپس می‌توانید دسترسی داشته باشید
به نحو واردات، بنابراین شما می‌توانید در موارد دیگر
فایل‌های JS که می‌توانید با تابع export انجام دهید
و غیره و سپس می‌توانید با آن وارد کنید
اگر براکت نمی‌خواهید، از براکت استفاده کنید
مستقیماً وارد کنید، می‌توانید پیش‌فرض داشته باشید اما
فکر می‌کنم فقط در این صورت می‌توانی یکی داشته باشی
بنابراین ممکن است بخواهید یک فایل داشته باشید
جایی که چندین کارکرد دارید
می‌خواهید به‌صورت جداگانه صادر کنید، می‌توانید از
کلمه کلیدی export برای آنها، بنابراین export
تابع اضافه کردن خروجی تابع خروجی
ضرب و غیره اما اگر می خواهید داشته باشید
فقط یکی را می‌توانید به صورت پیش‌فرض انجام دهید و سپس
و شما می‌توانید مخلوط کنید، فکر می‌کنم می‌توانید مخلوط کنید، بنابراین
شما می‌توانید یک پیش‌فرض داشته باشید و سپس می‌توانید
فرض کنید تست تابع خروجی داریم
بیایید یک تابع خالی مثل این را در نظر بگیریم
و این یعنی در حالی که
تابع اضافه خواهد شد، شما می‌توانید عمل کنید
مستقیماً آن را اضافه کنید، بنابراین اگر نگاه کنم
در نتیجه اینجا شما همچنین می‌توانید یک کار انجام دهید
ویرگول و سپس تست و همچنین
اگر من بروم، می‌توانید از نام دیگری برای صادرات استفاده کنید.
باشه، من ازش استفاده نکردم ولی آره، پس
این راهیه که باید رفت، اوه، به نظر من همینه
بسیار خوب، حالا آماده‌ایم که شروع کنیم
ساخت بازی‌ها و قبل از آن
وقت آن است که فقط در مورد آنچه که هست صحبت کنیم
کتابخانه و من به طور خلاصه آن را پوشش دادم.
بعداً، اوه، قبلاً، ببخشید، پس
کتابخانه کدی است که توسط آن نوشته شده است
شخص دیگری که می‌توانید در کارتان از او دوباره استفاده کنید
پروژه‌های شخصی که به شما اجازه نمی‌دهد
باید چرخ و کتابخانه ۱ را از نو اختراع کنم
واقعاً دوست دارم از آن برای ساخت بازی استفاده کنم
به هر حال، این CAP playay نامیده می‌شود
کتابخانه و اه، من کاملاً از کار افتادم
دوره ای که به شما نحوه استفاده از آن را آموزش می دهد
همه توابع نه همه آنها
اما موارد اصلی و شما یک
زمین بازی که در آن می‌توانید نمونه‌ها را ببینید
و غیره، پس این واقعاً خیلی باحاله
کتابخانه‌ای که برای ساخت بازی‌هایی که
کلی چیز بهت میده
از جعبه برای ساخت بازی‌ها، پس بیایید از آن استفاده کنیم
و یک پلتفرم ساده بسازید
بنابراین اینجا جایی است که اوضاع قرار است پیش برود
متفاوت شدن این است که فعلاً داریم
کد خود را با استفاده از این تنظیمات نوشتیم که در آن
ما یک سرور میزبان محلی ایجاد می‌کنیم و سپس
فقط با اندیس و HTML می‌توانید
در واقع شروع به کار روی بازی خود کنید.
همه اینها خوب است اما این راهش نیست
توسعه وب مدرن انجام شده است، آه ما
از nodejs و پکیج npm استفاده شده
مدیر و دسته‌ای از سلیقه‌های دیگر به
خب، کد وبمون رو بنویس، من می‌خوام
نحوه تنظیم آن را هم توضیح دهید
شما می‌توانید از K playay فقط با یک
تگ اسکریپت، روشی که شما برای انجام این کار استفاده می‌کنید،
تو فقط برو به ... فکر کنم باید ادامه بدم
‎‏ ...
گیت‌هاب یا در نصب کی پلی شما
راهنمای نصب را داشته باشید، چه کاری انجام می‌دهید
میشه اینو اینجا کپی کنی؟
که و سپس اساساً می‌توانید داشته باشید
که
اینجا و سپس ضمناً حتی من فقط
اساساً به این جمله اول نیاز دارید، پس
در اینجا من ساده‌ترین راه برای وارد کردن را توضیح می‌دهم.
capay این است، بنابراین من فقط می روم
به صفحه اصلی ما برگردید، اینجا می‌توانید به اینجا بروید
بالا من می‌توانم از دستور import با استفاده از
ماژول‌های بومی و قرار است وارد شوند
کتابخانه پخش کننده C که قرار است
این اسم کاپل رو برات میارم که قراره
آن را از این لینک، این URL که
میزبان، کتابخانه را به عنوان یک فایل MJS میزبانی می‌کند.
که برای فایل جاوا اسکریپت ماژول است، بنابراین
حالا که این را دارید، واقعاً می‌توانید
شروع به ساختن بازی خود کنید، بنابراین اگر من تماس بگیرم
کاپل
تابعی که توسط capl it's ارائه می‌شود
قرار است یک بوم نقاشی را در وب شما راه‌اندازی اولیه کنیم.
صفحه، بنابراین بوم یک عنصر HTML است که
به شما امکان می‌دهد با گرافیک کار کنید و
این اساساً چیزی است که شما برای آن استفاده می‌کنید
ساخت بازی در
جاوا اسکریپت، بنابراین شما اینجا بوم نقاشی را دارید
حالا این اه اه این تنظیمات همه چی اوکیه
می‌توانید شروع به کار کنید و خودتان را بسازید
بازی‌هایی که معمولاً ترجیح می‌دهم دانلود کنم، آه
فایل در این لینک و سپس به صورت محلی
اون رو توی پروژه‌ام بذارم و بعد ایمپورتش کنم
از آن به صورت محلی و بدون نیاز به تکیه
در غیر این صورت اگر لینکی فعال باشد
یه روزی خراب میشه، اوه، بازی تو دیگه خراب نمیشه
کار می‌کنم اما می‌خواهم چیزی را امتحان کنم
متفاوت، فقط برای اینکه بهت یاد بدم، می‌خوام
در واقع آن را به روشی که وب انجام می‌دهد، انجام دهید
توسعه به شیوه مدرن انجام می‌شود
با استفاده از
nodejs بنابراین nodejs همان چیزی است که شما می خواهید
باید روی دستگاه خود نصب کنید
به شما امکان می‌دهد جاوا اسکریپت را روی
کامپیوتر واقعی خارج از
مرورگر اکنون ما از nodejs استفاده می‌کنیم زیرا می‌توانیم
از npm و کلی مدیر بسته استفاده کن
به شما امکان می‌دهد از مجموعه‌ای از کتابخانه‌ها استفاده کنید
و غیره اما خدای من در پایان روز
کد ما هنوز روی آن اجرا خواهد شد
مرورگری که فقط از آن عبور خواهد کرد
node.js قرار است در آن کامپایل شود
جاوا اسکریپتی که می‌تواند روی وب اجرا شود، بنابراین
جاوا اسکریپتی که روی کامپیوتر اجرا می‌شود
با استفاده از nodejs و جاوا اسکریپت که روی آن اجرا می‌شود
وب متفاوت است، آنها عمدتاً ... هستند
یکسان هستند اما آنها متفاوت هستند و این
چرا به یک مرحله کامپایل نیاز دارید که در آن
کد جاوا اسکریپت شما را که اجرا می‌شود، کامپایل می‌کند.
در node.js و سپس آن را به صورت کامپایل می‌کند.
کد جاوا اسکریپتی که می‌تواند در ... اجرا شود
مرورگر، بنابراین دلیل اینکه ما این کار را انجام دادیم این است
چون امم در گذشته جاوااسکریپت نه J
جاوا اسکریپت، جاوا اسکریپت را پیاده‌سازی کرد.
استاندارد من فکر می‌کنم اوه بیشتر در یک
روش پیشرفته‌ای بود، بنابراین پیاده‌سازی شده بود
فکر می‌کنم ویژگی‌های جدید سریع‌تر هستند و اگر
شما می‌خواستید پیشرفت خوبی داشته باشید
تجربه‌ای که برای به دست آوردنش مجبور به استفاده از nodejs بودید
و این کد را دوباره کامپایل می‌کند
به جاوا اسکریپتی که می‌تواند روی آن استفاده شود
مرورگری که کمتر بود
پیشرفته، پس فکر می‌کنم این همونه
خلاصه کلام و اما واقعاً برای این
تو تنها چیزی هستی که نیاز داری
درک این است که ما به هیچ JS نیاز نداریم
npm که همراه آن می‌آید
nodejs و ما به یک bundler نیاز داریم که
قرار است واقعاً کار را انجام دهم
کامپایل کردن کد جاوا اسکریپتی که اجرا می‌شود
روی nodejs به کد جاوا اسکریپت که اجرا می‌شود
در مرورگر، بنابراین این bundler در حال اجرا است
به آن ویت گفته می شود و خیلی شبیه آن است
این یه چیز نسبتاً جدیده و خیلی شبیه الانه
همه جا استفاده میشه، بنابراین خیلی
راحت برای استفاده و بعد از اینکه تدریس می‌کنم
شما چگونه پلتفرمی را که می روم درست کنید
تا در واقع به شما یاد بدهد که چگونه آن را بپوشید
.io یا موارد دیگر، چگونه فایل خود را قرار دهید؟
چگونه آن را در وب منتشر کنیم و آن
پایان این دوره فشرده خواهد بود
خیلی خب، حالا چیزی که لازم دارم
شما باید نصب کنید
nodejs بنابراین چیزهای زیادی برای یادگیری وجود دارد
مواد و راهنماهایی در مورد چگونگی انجام آن
بنابراین من نصب را انجام نخواهم داد
با شما فرآیند را انجام می‌دهد، بنابراین وقتی این کار را انجام دادید
حالا که کارت تموم شده برگرد، پس
خب، بریم سراغ ویرایشگرمون، من فقط دارم میرم
برای حذف هر آنچه که ایجاد کرده‌ایم
تا اینجا، پس اینجا را حذف می‌کنم
همه چیز
همه چیز را به طور دائم و این
جایی که قرار است ترمینال را باز کنم
توسط
می‌توانستید مکان‌نما را اینجا بکشید
با سر خوردن به اینجا، شما این را خواهید داشت
ترمینال مثل این است، بنابراین حالا من قصد دارم
این را حذف کن، من آن را حذف خواهم کرد.
قرار است این را حذف کنیم، بنابراین ما قصد داریم
اینجا فقط پنجره ترمینال هست خدای من
صفحه نمایش عمداً بزرگ است، من این کار را نمی‌کنم
در واقع اینگونه توسعه می یابد اما فقط
برای ویدیو تا بتوانید یک
دیدگاه خوبی نسبت به چیزها دارید، بنابراین اگر
nodejs نصب شده است، شما باید node را انجام دهید
اوه-- نسخه‌ای که باید ببینید چیست
در واقع nodejs نصب شده است، بنابراین من این را دارم
نسخه
۲۰.۱۱ فکر می‌کنم جدیدترین و به‌روزترین
نسخه ۲۲.۵ امتیاز ۱ است، بنابراین من باید
احتمالاً به زودی به‌روزرسانی می‌شود، در درازمدت مشکلی نیست
پشتیبانی، بنابراین من پشتیبانی بلندمدت دارم
نسخه خیلی خوب، حالا چی می‌خوام؟
برای انجام این کار، زمانی که node.js را دارید، این کار را انجام دهید
نصب شده، به npm نیز دسترسی دارید
و شما همچنین دسترسی اضافه خواهید کرد
به دستورات مبتنی بر npm، بنابراین من این کار را انجام می‌دهم
برای ایجاد پروژه، بنابراین من ... را دارم
پوشه learn JS که پوشه I است
در تمام آن زمان‌ها بود و من چه هستم
من قصد دارم npm create را انجام دهم.
vit در آخرین نقطه، بنابراین این دستور npm
ایجاد V در آخرین نقطه، یک شروع سریع است
دستوری که توسط ویت ارائه می‌شود
bundler همان چیزی است که من به آن اشاره کردم
قبلاً و من اینجا از نقطه استفاده می‌کنم، بنابراین
قرار است از آخرین نسخه استفاده شود، بنابراین
به همین دلیل است که حداقل می‌توانید
نسخه خاصی را مشخص کنید اما من ترجیح می‌دهم
برای این کار از آخرین نسخه استفاده کنید
به این معنی است که قرار است ایجاد کند
همه چیز از درون پوشه‌ای که ما هستیم
اگر می‌خواهید آن را ایجاد کنید، در حال حاضر موجود است
در پوشه خودش، شما تایپ می‌کنید
نامی که می‌خواهید پوشه در آن قرار گیرد را اینجا بنویسید
و بعد اینجا اگر فشار دهم
وارد کن، چندتا بهم میده
گزینه‌ها، بنابراین یک چارچوب را انتخاب کنید و سپس
اینجا ما با وانیل شروع می‌کنیم.
نه، ما قرار نیست از react preact استفاده کنیم.
و غیره که چارچوب‌های وب هستند، بنابراین به
اوه، روی گزینه وانیلی اینتر بزنید
با استفاده از کلیدهای gar و سپس انتخاب then
را وارد کنید و سپس بین تایپ اسکریپت و
تایپ‌اسکریپت جاوااسکریپت مانند جاوااسکریپت است
با انواع مختلف، داره بیشتر و بیشتر میشه
فکر کنم آیتوس، اوه، به صورت حرفه‌ای استفاده شده
زیرا کد شما را آسان‌تر می‌کند
دلیل اینکه ما قصد داریم از آن استفاده کنیم
جاوا اسکریپت برای این پروژه، بنابراین توسط
اگر جاوا اسکریپت بلد باشید، این روش این است
بعداً برای شما آسان تر خواهد بود
اگر می‌خواهید همین حالا تایپ‌اسکریپت را یاد بگیرید
که ما جاوا اسکریپت خود را انتخاب کرده‌ایم
یک پروژه داربست داریم، بنابراین چند مورد داریم
پوشه‌ها و من قصد دارم آنها را مرور کنم.
اینجا به شما می‌گوید که دستور npm install npm را اجرا کنید.
دستور کلی install است.
تمام وابستگی‌های موجود را نصب کنید
در package.json فهرست شده است و
package.json فایل واقعی است که
درک آن بسیار مهم است زیرا
وابستگی‌های شما را تعریف می‌کند و
دستورات مختلفی که به آنها دسترسی دارید
در اینجا package.json ما نامی دارد که
نام پروژه و نسخه آن است
شما می‌توانید تصمیم بگیرید که کدام نسخه
ماژول نوع این به ما اجازه می‌دهد
با استفاده از جاوا اسکریپت، سینتکس uh را وارد کنید
ماژول‌های این بخش، ورودی و خروجی هستند.
چیزی که اینجا وارد شده از
و غیره، بنابراین package.json اسکریپت‌هایی که داریم
دسترسی به اسکریپت توسعه است که
دستور vit را اجرا کنید، بنابراین دستور npm run Dev را در آن تایپ کنید.
ترمینال ما یک ویت است که بسته نرم افزاری است
ما از آن استفاده می‌کنیم که اساساً کد ما را کامپایل می‌کند
کدی از جاوا اسکریپت که روی NOS اجرا می‌شود
در جاوا اسکریپت که روی مرورگر اجرا می‌شود
حالا ما دستور ساخت را هم اینجا داریم
برای ما قابل دسترسی است که به ما اجازه می‌دهد
در حال حاضر پروژه خود را برای وب می‌سازیم
برای اینکه وقتی می‌رویم مفید باشد
قرار است واقعاً پروژه را بسازیم و
اوه، آن را جایی منتشر کن و سپس V
پیش‌نمایش، پیش‌نمایشی از ساخت را نشان می‌دهد، بنابراین Dev
پیش‌نمایش چه زمانی در حال توسعه است؟
پروژه‌ای را که می‌خواهید ببینید، ساخته‌اید
اگر همه چیز درست کار کند و
سپس وابستگی‌های توسعه‌دهندگان (Dev dependencies) همان بسته‌بند V است.
ابزار
اینجا، پس اینجا واقعاً چیز زیادی برای گفتن وجود ندارد
مگر اینکه مانند نصب npm انجام دهیم
بنابراین بیایید نصب npm را در سیستم خود انجام دهیم
ترمینال قرار است آن را نصب کند
وابستگی‌ها وابستگی‌های توسعه
احتمالاً بله و قرار است اضافه شود
ماژول‌های زیرخط گره
این پوشه در واقع ماژول‌های nodecore است.
جایی که کد مربوط به کتابخانه‌های مختلف قرار دارد
شما استفاده می‌کنید ذخیره خواهد شد
معمولاً شما یک عدد دارید که آن را نادیده می‌گیرید
آن پوشه را نادیده می‌گیرد، بنابراین git پوشه‌ی دیگری است.
چیزی که باید در موردش یاد بگیری، آه، من هستم
این را برای ویدیوی دیگری می‌گذارم
اما گیت خیلی مفیده وقتی که تو
روی پروژه‌ها کار می‌کنی، اوه، تو اونا رو تحت فشار می‌گذاری
به عنوان مثال، می‌توانید به گیت‌هاب دسترسی داشته باشید
شاخه‌ها، کامیت‌ها و غیره به شما اجازه می‌دهند
خیلی خوب پیشرفت و غیره خود را دنبال کنید
امروز به فایل دست نمیزنم
من توضیح نمی‌دهم که get چیست
امروز اما توصیه می‌کنم یک ویدیو تماشا کنید
روی کیت، اوه، فکر کنم داری یه ... رو تماشا می‌کنی
ویدیو یا خواندن در مورد آن بسیار مهم است
مفید باشه، پس بسته‌بندی کن. قفل کردن. جیسون است
خیلی مهم نیست اما شامل موارد زیر است
نسخه‌های هر یک از ماژول‌های ما و غیره اما
اگر پروژه‌ای دارید، package.json
کسی به شما یک پروژه nodejs می‌دهد و
یک package.json دارد که خیلی زیاد خواهد بود
خیلی ساده‌ست، تو فقط npm هستی
نصب کنید، لیست خواهد شد
وابستگی‌ها و غیره، بنابراین واقعاً عالی است
حالا اینجا یک index.html با a داریم.
انبوهی از HTML که به موضوع ما ربطی ندارد
پروژه کاری که قرار است انجام دهم این است که من هستم
می‌خوام همه چی رو حذف کنم، می‌خوام همه چی رو حذف کنم
برای حذف هر چیزی که قرار است بگذارم
اگر HTML و برچسب بدنه را برگردانید
می‌خواهید بیشتر به توسعه وب بپردازید
من یادگیری HTML و CSS را به عنوان یک روش جایگزین توصیه می‌کنم.
خب، اینجا بیشتر در مورد تگ اسکریپت توضیح می‌دهیم.
ما دقیقاً از همان کد استفاده خواهیم کرد
ساختار ساختار متاسفم، من هم دارم میرم
برای حذف جاوا اسکریپت SVG که با آن است
فقط یه لوگو هست که می‌خوام s رو حذف کنم. سی اس اس
من قصد دارم همه اینها را از شمارنده حذف کنم
برای یک مورد ضروری نیستند
ما پروژه عمومی داریم، همانطور که برای
پوشه عمومی، من قصد دارم آن را همین جا نگه دارم
جایی است که دارایی‌هایت را می‌گذاری، اما
در واقع برای این لازم نیست
پروژه‌ای که فکر می‌کنم قرار است انجام دهیم
بدون اما بیایید فعلاً آن را نگه داریم، پس
کاری که من قرار است انجام دهم این است که در
index.html امم، من هم در همان سطح هستم.
قصد دارم یک پوشه ایجاد کنم که قرار است
مثل من اسمشو بذار کد و من اینجام
قصد داریم فایل JS اصلی خود را ایجاد کنیم.
احتمالاً باید فقط می‌کشیدم و
افتاد اما چون ما قصد نداریم
از هر کدی که می‌خواهم استفاده کنم
اون یکی رو از ایندکس حذف کن. HTML من دارم میرم
برای استفاده از سورس به عنوان کد uh
main.js و سپس به عنوان مسیر و
فراموش نکنید که نوع را واقعاً تنظیم کنید
برای این به عنوان یک
ماژول و بعد اینجا فکر نمی‌کنم شما
به اون نیاز دارم، اممم، اگه من
بذار فقط به چیزی که اونجا بود نگاه کنم
قبلاً اصلی بود، بله، همینطور بود
اشعار معنی: وجود دارد، بنابراین مهم نیست، بنابراین مثل ما در در
تنظیمات ساده‌ای که قرار است انجام دهیم
دقیقاً همین الان اینجا، شاید تو هم همینطور باشی
دارم فکر می‌کنم که چرا باید از npm به خوبی استفاده کنم؟
در واقع لازم نیست دلیلش را بدانی
شاید بخوای ازش استفاده کنی، اممم
یکی از مزایای استفاده از bundler
کاری که می‌توانید با npm انجام دهید این است که
شما قادر خواهید بود که
کد به یک فایل واحد خلاصه شده است که
قرار است باعث شود سریعتر بارگیری شود
مرورگری که یکی از اصلی‌ترین‌هاست
مزایا اما در غیر این صورت ام و همچنین
این باعث میشه کد شما کوچیکتر بشه
برای کسی که می‌خواهد کپی کند، قابل خواندن باشد
شما اما حتی در آن صورت هم کوچک‌سازی کد اینطور نیست
واقعاً یک اقدام امنیتی خوب برای
از کد خود در برابر معکوس شدن محافظت کنید
مهندسی زیرا از آنجایی که کد شما
در مرورگر کاربران چیزی وجود ندارد
تقریباً همین الان می‌توانید این کار را انجام دهید اگر
می خواهم
یک بازی پولی بساز که من فقط توصیه می‌کنم
اوه، می‌دونی، اوه، اون رو به عنوان رومیزی بسته‌بندی می‌کنم
برنامه و فکر می‌کنم شما چیزهای بیشتری دارید
ویژگی‌های امنیتی اما به هر حال فکر می‌کنم اگر
هر کسی که انگیزه کافی برای معکوس کردن داشته باشد
مهندسی معکوس شما، شما هستید
قرار است این کار را انجام دهم، قادر به انجام آن خواهم بود
درسته، اما نباید باشه
مثلاً می‌گویم، چشمگیر
بازی‌های زیادی وجود دارد که شما در آن‌ها دارید
دسترسی به این کد منبع کامل برای
مثال balatro uh یک بازی است
با عشق و به زبان لوآ و به صورت دوبعدی ساخته شده و من دیدم، دیدم.
یه ویدیو تو یوتیوب هست که فکر کنم از اونجا بود
بازی‌های کانال از ابتدا که در آن
او به تو نشان داد که چگونه می‌توانی تو را داشته باشی
به راحتی می‌توانست به کد منبع دسترسی پیدا کند
چون اگه از عشق دوبعدی استفاده کنی که ...
چارچوبی که برای ساخت بازی با
عاشق لوا هستم، اوه، کدت واقعاً خوب نیست
شما می‌توانید محافظت کنید، زیرا روشی که شما
برای دریافت فایل اجرایی، کافیست فایل زیپ خود را دانلود کنید.
کد منبع شما و شما این کار را انجام می‌دهید
چیزی که دگرگون می‌کند
و بعد می‌تونی بازش کنی
دوباره آن را به صورت زیپ یا چیزی شبیه به آن باز کنید
اینطوری، تا بتونی کلش رو ببینی
کد بازی اما اینطور نشد
جلوگیری از بزرگ شدن بالایترو
موفقیت در دنیای بازی، پس این
چیزی که باید در نظر داشته باشید، پس من اینجا هستم
فقط می‌خواهم ماژول نوع را همانطور که من اضافه می‌کنم، اضافه کنم
قبلاً انجام داد
ماژول اینجا ما به اینجا می‌آییم ما
برو، حالا همه چیز آماده است
حالا وقتشه که capl رو نصب کنیم
کتابخانه، بنابراین K play کتابخانه‌ای برای
ساخت بازی‌ها، این یکی بود و برای
بازی که قراره انجام بدیم واقعاً
بیایید دقیقاً همین کار را اینجا انجام دهیم
بنابراین در اینجا آنها به شما نشان می‌دهند که چگونه یک کار اساسی انجام دهید
پلتفرمر در کمتر از سه خط ۳۰ خطی
از کد، پس بیایید ببینیم، پس بیایید واقعاً
آن کد را کپی کنید
اوه، فکر کنم هنوز به دکمه‌ی فشاری روشن/خاموش نیاز داریم، بله
بنابراین بیشتر در پریدن خواهد بود
مکانیک احتمالاً کمی گسترش خواهد یافت
در مورد آن اما بله، اوه، این خوب خواهد بود
اول با KL که یه کتابخونه است امتحان کن و
سپس برای محتوای عمیق‌تر در مورد
این تو هستی، تو می‌توانی، تو به خوبی خدمت خواهی شد
توی کانالم کلی چیزای دیگه هم دارم
ضمناً لازم نیست آموزش‌ها را انجام دهید
از KL استفاده کنید، کتابخانه‌های زیاد دیگری هم وجود دارد
راستی اگه بخوای، مثل فازر، اوه
از phaser استفاده کن، اوه، باید یه کم یاد بگیری
بیشتر در مورد برنامه نویسی شی گرا
چیزی که زیاد به آن اشاره نکردم
این اصلاً در این آموزش در این
البته می‌توانید از P5 هم برای ساخت استفاده کنید.
کدنویسی خلاقانه، اوه، مطالب خیلی خوبن و
این من هستم که اد پی ۵ هستم تا این بازی را بسازم.
ضمناً می‌توانید یک آموزش تماشا کنید
در کانال نحوه ساخت این ساخته شده است
بازی دقیقاً با P5 gz انجام میشه، پس اوه، فقط همین
فقط برای اینکه به شما بگویم تعداد زیادی وجود دارد
گزینه‌های دیگر و فقط این یکی نیست
به من برای ساختن ویدیو در کی پلی پول نمی‌دهند
اوه، بله، این فقط یک کتابخانه است، من واقعاً
مثل و به همین دلیل است که من از آن استفاده کرده ام
خیلی خب، حالا بیایید نصب کنیم
کتابخانه ما، بنابراین برای نصب K play باید این کار را انجام دهید
npm install C playay همین است و بعد
قراره نصبش کنه و داره انجام میشه
برای اضافه کردن آن به package.json خود، اینجا را کلیک کنید.
می‌توانید در بخش وابستگی ببینید که
قراره نسخه اضافه بشه
۳۰۰.۱ ۳۰۰ ۱.۰.۰ آلفا ۱۹۱ بنابراین این است
آخرین نسخه کتابخانه KL اکنون اگر
می‌خواهید آن را به یک نسخه خاص پین کنید
ضمناً اگر شخص دیگری از شما استفاده کند
پروژه را اجرا کنید و فقط با npm آن را نصب کنید
الان نسخه درست رو نصب می‌کنم
فرض کنید شما تا این حد به ماجرا نگاه می‌کنید
در آینده، شما با npm و نصب C این کار را انجام خواهید داد.
بازی کنید و سپس یک علامت AD خاص با
۳۰۰۰ انجام۰
انجام دهید0 داس
اگر این کار را انجام دهید، آلفا ۱۹.۱ را دریافت خواهید کرد
برای اینکه دقیقاً همان نسخه را داشته باشیم، الان...
هیچ چیز تغییر نخواهد کرد زیرا
در حال حاضر نسخه اما در صورتی که شما
تماشای این موضوع به اندازه کافی در آینده
می‌توانید از آن برای داشتن دقیقاً همان استفاده کنید
چیزی به عنوان
من، پس این، اون، اون، اشکالی نداره، پس
حالا ما KL را نصب کرده‌ایم و می‌توانیم برویم
به main.js بروید و دستور import kep playay را بنویسید.
از
که
بازی کن، اوه، تو اینجوری بازی کن، پس وقتی تو
می‌خواهید وقتی از nodejs استفاده می‌کنید، از آن استفاده کنید
نام کتابخانه در رشته‌ها نیست
مسیر کتابخانه مانند کاری که ما با آن انجام دادیم
تنظیمات دیگر، بنابراین حالا اگر من capl را انجام دهم
تابع capl رو یه چیز خوب صدا بزن
در مورد استفاده از شماره‌ها و V و غیره این است که شما
وقتی که شما به اسناد دسترسی دارید
روی چیزهایی مثل آن شناور بمانید
وقتی از دیگری استفاده می‌کنید، ندارید
تنظیماتی که داشتم، بنابراین این تنها دلیل برای
از آن استفاده کنید تا کلاه داشته باشیم که کدام است؟
قرار است بوم خود را مقداردهی اولیه کنیم، بنابراین اگر من
به اینجا برو، به خروجی برو
رفرش کردن، باشه، نسبی باید باشه
باشه به دلایلی کار نمیکنه
واردات
اوووووف اوه باشه میدونم چرا
ببخشید هرچی نوشتیم مشکلی نداره
مسئله این است که حالا که ما
با استفاده از تنظیمات دیگر، این دیگر کار نمی‌کند
مرتبطه، اوه، برای شروع به چی نیاز داریم؟
سرور توسعه محلی این است که شما
دیگر به سرور زنده نیاز ندارید، بنابراین شما
می‌توانید روی دکمه‌ی پخش زنده که قبلاً بود کلیک کنید
قبلاً و سپس قرار است
این را در میزبان محلی غیرفعال کنید، اما
وقتی از npm استفاده می‌کنید، یک سرور اجرا کنید
آیا وقتی این کار را انجام می‌دهید، آیا باید npm run Dev را اجرا کنید؟
قرار است سروری را که ارائه می‌دهد، شروع کند
آدرسی که من فقط کپی می‌کنم تویی
آن را وارد مرورگرم می‌کنم، همانطور که برای
شما فقط می توانید روی آن کلیک کنید
کلیک کنترل و آن را به ارمغان خواهد آورد
تو به چیزی که اینجا داری میری، اینجا داری میری
برای دریافت خطایی به نام favicon so
فاویکونی که معمولاً می‌توانم در صفحات HTML استفاده کنم
شما باید یک آیکون در بالا تعریف کنید
چون ما داریم بازی می‌سازیم، این [موضوع] درست نیست
لازم است و اگر قرار بود میزبان یک بازی باشید
در حاشیه. حتی بیشتر از این لازم نیست
من به شما یاد می‌دهم که چگونه آماده شوید
بازی شما برای برتری. احتمالاً نیستم.
قرار است وارد آن شوم. چیز iio
پورتال و غیره و مراحل را انجام دهید اما
فقط شامل فشرده‌سازی کد پایه شما خواهد بود
خروجی ساخت را زیپ می‌کنم و سپس
انداختنش روی ح. همین است، بنابراین ما یک
بوم نقاشی که کل صفحه نمایش را در بر می‌گیرد و
فضا، پس عالیه، حالا بیایید نگاهی به آن بیندازیم
کد اینجاست، بنابراین من آن را کپی می‌کنم
و من قصد دارم از آن عبور کنم، بنابراین و من هستم
قراره همه چیز رو توضیح بدم تا ما این کارو نکنیم
به این نیاز دارید، می‌توانید از load Bean استفاده کنید. من ... هستم
در یک لحظه توضیح خواهم داد که چرا
پس اگر نگاه کنم
تو، تو می‌تونی بپری، می‌بینی و حالا چی؟
شما می‌توانید انجام دهید، می‌توانید بیاورید
مربع‌های رو به جلو، مستطیل‌ها، و غیره، آن، آن
طوری عمل خواهند کرد که
موانعی که اکنون بر سر راهم قرار دارند
در مورد این است که من قصد دارم آن کد را نگه دارم
میدونی چی ممکنه گیج کننده باشه
برای شما گیج کننده است، بنابراین من فقط قصد دارم
همه چیز را به صورت دستی بنویسید تا capl یک ... باشد.
روش اوه، در واقع این نیست
سازنده، روش مقداردهی اولیه
بوم نقاشی، بنابراین بوم نقاشی است
عنصر بوم چیزی است که برای ساخت آن استفاده می‌شود
گرافیک در وب ظاهر می‌شود
صفحه‌ای که ترجیح می‌دهم آن را در یک مقدار ثابت نگه دارم
به آن K می‌گویند چون قرار است همه چیز را در خود جای دهد
چیزی که ما روش می‌نامیم، بنابراین روش‌ها
توابعی که می‌توانید از آن فراخوانی کنید
از یک شیء، پس یادت باشد که من صحبت کردم
در مورد این واقعیت که شما می‌توانید خلق کنید
اشیاء برای مثال شیء من و تو
می‌تواند ویژگی‌هایی داشته باشد و می‌دانید چیست
یادم رفت بگم ولی می‌تونی داشته باشی
خاصیتی که آن یک تابع است، بنابراین برای
به عنوان مثال، شما می‌توانستید تصمیم بگیرید که یک
تابعی به نام «بیایید بگوییم ام»
اضافه کنید و آن را مانند آن تعریف کنید
شما می‌توانید آن را به این شکل تعریف کنید یا
مانند استفاده از تابع arrow
که راه دیگری برای اعلام a است
فقط برای اینکه شما را گیج نکنم این کار را می‌کنم
فکر می‌کنم راه بهتری است، بنابراین داشتن این
مانند این اساساً یک روش است، یک روش
این یعنی شما می‌توانید از آن استفاده کنید
تابعی که این شیء می‌تواند
تماس بگیرید، بله، بنابراین این یک روش است، به طوری که
یعنی اینکه بعداً می‌تونی کار من رو انجام بدی
شیء را ایجاد کرده و سپس تابع را فراخوانی کنید.
مانند
که خب آره شاید خیلی خوب نباشه
ساده است اما اینگونه است
کار می‌کند، بنابراین اینجا کاری که می‌خواهم انجام دهم این است که چه هستم
دارم بوم کلاه رو درست می‌کنم
و من در حال ذخیره کردن زمینه‌ای هستم که به آن گفته می‌شود
زمینه درون این ثابت K که
یعنی از این به بعد برای همه روش‌ها
که از klea میاد، می‌تونید K Dot رو انجام بدید و
سپس نام آن روش را چگونه می‌دانم
این روش‌ها این است که شما باید نگاه کنید
در مستندات، بنابراین وقتی یک توسعه‌دهنده
یک کتابخانه ایجاد می‌کند، آنها چندین کتابخانه دارند
یک API، روشی برای استفاده از آن، بنابراین یک API
به معنای برنامه نویسی کاربردی است
رابط کاربری و نحوه استفاده از آن
توابع و روش‌های مختلفی وجود دارد
موجود یا نوشته شده توسط LI
نویسنده کتابخانه که می‌توانید در [مطالب] خود از آن استفاده کنید
پروژه خودتان، پس چه کاری قرار است انجام دهید؟
در اینجا مجموعه‌ای از روش‌ها وجود دارد
و توابعی که می‌توانید از آنها استفاده کنید و آنها
داخل مستندات ثبت شده است
در بخش اسناد اینجا دارید
نام‌های مختلف اسناد مرجع و شما
حالا اسم چیزهای مختلف را دارید
برای این آموزش نیازی به جستجو ندارید
در آن ما فقط یک کار ساده انجام خواهیم داد
بازی من فقط می‌خواهم که تو یک
اساساً سریع برنده شدن برای چیزی
پایان این آموزش و سپس بعداً
می‌توانید بازی K من در Crash Course را تماشا کنید.
جایی که من چیزهای بیشتری را با جزئیات به شما آموزش می‌دهم
یا میتونی بقیه‌ی منو تماشا کنی
آموزش‌ها، بنابراین کاری که من قرار است انجام دهم این است که من هستم
قرار است یک بازی خیلی ساده انجام دهیم که در آن
شما قرار است یک شخصیت را بازی کنید و
قرار است از روی موانعی بپرد که
از سمت راست بیا، پس به دیو فکر کن
بازی و شما می دانید که گوگل کروم دوئو
بازی اگر شما وقتی اینترنت ندارید
اتصال، بنابراین برای انجام این کار که من می روم
برای اولین بار به عنوان یک پم وارد یک شیء شدن
روش کلاه، راهی که چرا این فقط
نحوه کار این کتابخانه و آن
ویژگی‌هایی را می‌گیرد که می‌توانید به آنها پاس دهید، بنابراین
اگر شما از یک شیء با ... عبور کنید
ویژگی‌های زیر، سقف آن را نشان می‌دهند.
تا کاری برایت انجام دهم، پس اگر قبول شوم
ویژگی width و عرض را مشخص می‌کند
۱,۲۸۰ قراره بوم رو خیلی بزرگ کنه
صفحه‌ای که بازی در آن قرار دارد
عرض نمایش داده شده ۸ اهم
۱۲,۰۸۰ اوه آره ۱۰۰ اوه ۱۲۰۰ و ۱۸۰ پس
حالا اگر ارتفاع را ۷۲۰ تعیین کنم، داریم:
قراره یه تصمیم اساسی بگیریم، پس آره
فقط آن را حذف کنید تا کد کار کند
حالا اگر من اینجا بروم، می‌توانید نمای ما را داشته باشید.
اینجا من قصد دارم آن را همینطور نگه دارم، پس
که شما می‌توانید کل بازی را در من ببینید
صفحه نمایش مانند آن، اکنون تعداد زیادی از آنها وجود دارد
گزینه‌های دیگری که می‌توانستید از آنها بگذرید اما
من بهت میگم، توضیحشون نده
اینجا، بنابراین اینجا برای بارگذاری دارایی‌ها در cap شما
از یک تابع بارگذاری Sprite استفاده کنید، اما وجود دارد
یک پیش‌فرض به نام load Bean که یک
اسپرایت پیش‌فرض موجود که
شخصیت لوبیایی است که در آن دیدید
صفحه اصلی KL کدام است؟
پسر، پس به جای اینکه بدونی نگرانم
در مورد پیدا کردن دارایی‌های آنلاین و غیره، من فقط
قرار است از آن برای این پروژه استفاده کنم، بنابراین
دنبال کردنش آسان خواهد بود، پس
حالا من قصد دارم یک شیء بازی ایجاد کنم
که قرار است بازیکن ما باشد، پس
شیء بازی، موجودیتی در Klay است که
چیزی را که با استفاده از ... ایجاد می‌شود، در خود جای می‌دهد.
متد add از زمینه capl و آن را اضافه کنید
آرایه‌ای از اجزا را دریافت می‌کند.
قطعات توسط خود KL ارائه می‌شوند.
به همین دلیل است که می‌توانید از K Dot استفاده کنید.
و بعد بهشون زنگ میزنی، پس اینجا آره، پس
باشه و بعد از کامپوننت Sprite استفاده کنیم
من می‌توانم یک اسپرایت خاص را نمایش دهم، زیرا من
متد load Bean ارائه شده توسط KL را فراخوانی کنید.
من می‌تونم جن لوبیا رو صدا بزنم تا بین بتونه
با ارسال یک رشته، با این فراخوانی شود
به کامپوننت Sprite با
رشته بودن Bean به این صورت است که حالا اگر من
به این صفحه نگاه کنید و نتیجه را ببینید
خواهید دید که یک لوبیا در آن ظاهر می‌شود
حالا فرض کنید می‌خواهیم گوشه بالا سمت چپ
شخصیت بین ما در مرکز قرار خواهد گرفت
بنابراین capl راهی برای تغییر ارائه می‌دهد
موقعیت یک شیء بازی که توسط آن ایجاد می‌کنید
با استفاده از مؤلفه مکث، بنابراین همه اینها
دانشی که از K می‌آید
و غیره، K انجامش بده، از جاوا اسکریپت نیست، از ...هست
از کتابخانه، پس چیزی برای
جدایی بین آنچه را که باید بدانید در نظر داشته باشید
از کتابخانه می‌آید و آنچه ما
مفاهیم جاوا اسکریپت مهم هستند، بنابراین
اینجا می‌توانید از k استفاده کنید. مؤلفه مکث
و سپس یا عرض را وارد کنید، اوه نه
مختصات x یا مختصات y یا
می‌توانید متد center را از K فراخوانی کنید
برای مرکز آن بازی کنید تا ام
اوه، بهت موقعیت رو میدم
اساساً مرکز است، بنابراین اگر من بروم، می‌توانید اینجا باشید
ببینید که شخصیت در مرکز قرار دارد
و ضمناً اگر F1 را فشار دهید
با کلید F1 اشکال‌زدایی انجام میشه
حالت از کلاه که می توانید مانند آن را ببینید
چیزهای مختلف اما خیلی مهم نیست
فعلاً مهمه، فقط اینو یادت باشه
اگر از Edge استفاده می‌کنید، اگر F1 را فشار دهید
قرار است پشتیبانی مایکروسافت را باز کند
چیزی که ما نمی‌خواهیم
اما می‌توانید با استفاده از uh I آن را دوباره صحافی کنید
راستش یادم رفت، پس آره، می‌خوام انجامش بدم.
فعلاً ولش کن مثل اینکه
بنابراین اکنون ما سه جزء داریم، بنابراین
اگر فقط بخواهم این را در یک نمایش دهم
مد خواناتر است، بنابراین دو تا داریم
اجزایی که استفاده نمی‌شوند
سه و آه، همانطور که گفتم، این واقعیت است که این
آرایه‌ای از عناصر است، این است
جاوا اسکریپت با این حال، مرکز مکث اسپرایت
و غیره از کاپا هستند، بنابراین همه اینها
اجزای تشکیل دهنده
together به ما شیء بازی بازیکن ما را می‌دهد.
حالا ما از منطقه استفاده خواهیم کرد
مؤلفه‌ای که قرار است یک
یک هیت‌باکس برای بازیکن ما می‌تواند یک هیت‌باکس باشد
به طور پیش فرض به صورت مربع دیده می شود که
نشان دهنده بدن شخصیت ماست
چه قسمتی قراره چی بشه؟
مستعد برخورد است، بنابراین اگر فشار دهم
دوباره F1، اگرچه باز خواهد شد،
قرار است اینجا یک جعبه ایجاد کنیم که
مفید است زیرا K play به ما پیشنهاد می‌دهد
متدهایی که می‌توانیم استفاده کنیم و توابعی که می‌توانیم
برای برخورد استفاده کنید، بنابراین اتفاقاً هر
وقتی میگم روش، فقط کافیه خودت رو وارد کنی
توجه داشته باشید که این یک تابع است
در اصل خوبه پس
حالا ما این را داریم و بعد می‌توانید آن را ایجاد کنید
یک بدن
اوه، ما از آن استفاده خواهیم کرد
بدنه کامپوننت اوه، حالا این چیه؟
کمی مفید نیست، بنابراین من
قالب‌بندی کد من این کار را انجام می‌دهد.
بعد از پنج جزء یا بیشتر، این اتفاق می‌افتد
برای قرار دادن آنها به این شکل، قرار است
خواناتر باشد اما به هر حال من از آن استفاده می‌کنم
بدنه، اوه، کامپوننت از کیپا که هست
قرار است شیء بازی خود را بسازیم
مستعد جاذبه و برخورد هستم
بله، به گرانش و برخوردها به عنوان
خب، حالا اگر این را اضافه کنید، داریم
مثل این که اه، به گرا، در واقع نه به
گرانش فقط برخوردها اما
تا بازیکن ما تحت تأثیر جاذبه قرار بگیرد
شما باید از گرانش تنظیم شده استفاده کنید
روش و در اینجا می‌خواهم یک
گرانش ۱۰۰۰ بنابراین حالا اگر نگاه کنیم
نتیجه این می‌شود که شخصیت بین ما در حال سقوط است.
پایین، بنابراین ما باید بستری برای آن ایجاد کنیم
برای اینکه شخصیت روی آن فرود بیاید
کاری که من قراره انجام بدم اینه که تو نداری
برای ذخیره شیء بازی خود که شما
اگر نمی‌خواهید، در یک ثابت ایجاد کنید
تا بعداً اگر قصد ندارید از آن استفاده کنید
بعداً تماس بگیرید، پس من چه کار خواهم کرد؟
من فقط این متد را ... می‌نامم.
متد add مستقیماً در آرایه‌ای از موارد زیر ارسال می‌شود
اجزایی که قرار است از آنها استفاده کنم
کامپوننت مستطیلی برای ایجاد یک
مستطیل و این مستطیل قرار است
عرض صفحه نمایش را دارم، بنابراین من هستم
قرار است از k استفاده شود. عرض که یک متد است
از KL که به ما اجازه می‌دهد عرض را بدست آوریم
از صفحه نمایش، من قرار است قد داشته باشم
هرچند، فرض کنید فکر کنم ۲۰۰ یا
۳۰۰ باید باشه، پس حالا اگه من
به نتیجه نگاه کنید، همه چیز را خواهید دید
الان اونجام، من می‌خوام تغییرش بدم
موقعیت K دو k.
مکث کنید و من قصد دارم آن را روی یک Z قرار دهم
پس شاید ۳۰۰، شاید درست باشد
مختصات، بنابراین اتفاقاً در بازی
راستی، توسعه‌دهنده در Game Dev دورتر
هرچه مقدار y بیشتر باشد، پایین‌تر می‌روید، بنابراین
این یه چیز خیلی عجیبه اگه
اگر به آن عادت دارید، اهل کجا هستید؟
هرچه مقدار y بیشتر باشد، شما بالاتر هستید
باید بره، پس این چیزیه که باید بری
نگه داشتن
توجه داشته باشید، بنابراین اینجا k. مکث ۰ تا ۱۰۰ من هستم
قرار است آن را روی ۵۰۰ قرار دهم و بعد من هم هستم
قصد دارم یک جزء مساحت برای آن اضافه کنم
به همان دلیلی که من الان این کار را کردم
واقعاً مفید نیست، انگار که نمی‌شود
ظاهراً کل ماجرا را نمی‌بیند، پس
من فقط اندازه فونت رو کوچیکتر میکنم
بیت
شاید بدونی که من فقط دارم چی میکشم
فقط برای اینکه بتونی ببینی، افزایشش بده
مطمئن شوید که واقعاً می‌توانید
ببینید k. مساحت و سپس K جسم را تشکیل می‌دهند.
دو مؤلفه‌ای که می‌خواهیم به آنها بپردازیم
اضافه کن اوه، آیا اضافه کرد؟ نه
باشه، پس حالا تنها تفاوت اینجاست
که در ما
آرایه‌ای که باید به آن پاس دهیم
شیء و مشخص شده یک ویژگی استاتیک است
برای حقیقت داشتن
پس این یعنی بدن مشکلی ندارد
حالا می‌بینید که به درستی آن را فرمت می‌کند، بنابراین
اتفاقی که اینجا می‌افتد این است که KL
بدن
مؤلفه‌ای که یک شیء را می‌گیرد و
جسمی که وارد می‌کنید می‌تواند بگیرد.
تعریف ویژگی استاتیک IST و IST
اگر آن را روی true تنظیم کنید، چه اتفاقی می‌افتد؟
اتفاق می افتد آیا قرار است شما را خوشحال کند؟
پلتفرم، شیء بازی شما نیست
مستعد جاذبه است، بنابراین برای آن ایده‌آل است
پلتفرمرها برای پلتفرم‌ها، پس اگر من بروم
اینجا می‌بینی که کاملاً فرود میاد، حالا من
قرار است یک طرح کلی به پلتفرم اضافه شود
و شما می‌توانید این کار را با طرح کلی انجام دهید
جزء و ضخامت را در اینجا مشخص کنید
ضخامت سه باید خوب باشد
و تو روی آن فرود می‌آیی
پلتفرم خیلی خوبه، پس همه چی خوبه
و حالا بیایید پریدن را پیاده‌سازی کنیم
مکانیک برای یک بازیکن، بنابراین می‌توانید این کار را انجام دهید
ام
اینجا تا بتوانید بازیکن داشته باشید و سپس
اینجا می‌توانید با فشردن همزمان دکمه Onkey و فشردن همزمان دکمه Onkey، از آن استفاده کنید.
فشار دادن روشی است که توسط K play ارائه شده است
همچنین هنگام ایجاد در دسترس است
شیء بازی حاصل را که شما بازی می‌کنید، بازی کنید
ایجاد کنید، بنابراین با فشار دادن کلید، به عنوان ورودی عمل می‌کند.
اول کلیدی که می‌خوای رو پارامتر کن
گوش کن و این فضا خواهد بود
کلید من تصمیم گرفتم که وقتی شما را فشار می دهید
کلید فاصله رو بزن، می‌تونی... اوه، قراره اجرا بشه
تابعی که به عنوان تابع دوم ارسال می‌شود
پارامتر بنابراین در اینجا چون من تدریس نکردم
شما تابع پیکان را به شکل پیکان در نظر می‌گیرید
این روش دیگری برای نوشتن یک تابع است.
چون من بهت یاد ندادم که من چی هستم
قراره انجام بدم، فقط قراره انجام بدم
تابع را از داخل اینجا تعریف کنید، بنابراین
شما اینجا یک تابع تعریف می‌کنید، فرض کنید
اممم، در واقع مهم نیست کی می‌خوای
فقط یک تابع دور انداختنی داشته باشید
نمی‌خواهم برای نامگذاری آن وقت بگذارم
و غیره، می‌توانید از تابع arrow استفاده کنید تا
تابع arrow را می‌توان به این صورت تعریف کرد
تو وارد می‌شوی، تو پرانتز را داری
و بعد یک علامت مساوی دارید و بعد
علامت بزرگتر از که یک پیکان می‌دهد
و سپس شما اینجا براکت دارید، بنابراین اگر
اگر می‌خواهید تعریف کنید، باید
تابع فلش به سمت بیرون که ذخیره می‌کنید
داخل یک ثابت یا متغیر قرار می‌گیرد
معمولاً ثابت است، به آن یک نام بدهید و سپس
این کار را بکن، بنابراین این راه دیگری برای
یک تابع به صورت زیر تعریف کنید:
تفاوت ظریف بین استفاده از
معنی کلمه کلیدی تابع uh
تعریف تابعی مانند این با
کلمه کلیدی و استفاده از تابع خطا اما
فکر می‌کنم فعلاً فقط آنها را در نظر بگیرید
فعلاً همین است، بعداً اشاره خواهم کرد
شما به سمت یک منبع عالی جاوا اسکریپت هستید
که می‌توانید برای عمیق‌تر کردن خودتان از آن استفاده کنید
دانش در مورد آن، بنابراین در اینجا چه چیزی
اتفاقی که می‌افتد این است که وقتی کلید فاصله (space) است
فشرده شد که همان چیزی است که به عنوان گذشت
اول پم، روش فشار دادن کلید Onkey است
قرار است تابع دوم را اجرا کند،
تابع را به صورت گذشته اجرا خواهیم کرد
پم دوم، به روشی که می‌توانی رد شوی
توابعی مانند Pam برای توابع دیگر، بنابراین
شما نه تنها می‌توانید اعداد را منتقل کنید، بلکه می‌توانید آنها را نیز منتقل کنید.
آرایه‌ها
اشیاء رشته‌ها بولی
شما همچنین می‌توانید وارد شوید
توابعی که زیبا هستند
خیلی خب، حالا کاری که می‌خوام انجام بدم اینه که
انجامش اینه که منطق رو بنویسیم تا بتونم فراخوانیش کنم
بازیکن خارجی به یاد داشته باشد
جهانی در مقابل چیز محلی به دلیل بازیکن
خارج از تعریف تابع ما است
در واقع می‌توان از داخل از آن استفاده کرد، بنابراین
بازیکن نقطه و سپس شما می توانید از پرش استفاده کنید
روش اه از کی پلی که اهه
هنگام ایجاد یک شیء بازی ارائه می‌شود
با توجه به اینکه فکر می‌کنم جزء بدنه الان
اگر به بازی برگردم و فشار بیاورم
فضایی که اکنون می‌توانید بپرید، می‌توانید آن را ببینید
شما می‌توانید بی‌نهایت بپرید زیرا ما نیاز داریم
تا در واقع مطمئن شود که بازیکن
فقط وقتی بازیکن می‌تواند بپرد که
زمین گیر شده اند، در غیر این صورت می توانند پرواز کنند
مثل اون چیزی که نیست، اه، که نیست
ما چه می‌خواهیم، ​​پس چه خواهیم کرد
اینجا ما یک «اگر» خواهیم داشت
بیانیه، بنابراین اینجا جایی است که قرار است به آن برسد
مفید واقع می‌شود، بنابراین این دستور if توسط
روشی که اگر یک دستور if داشته باشید که
شما منطقی را که می‌خواهید درون آن اجرا کنید، انتخاب می‌کنید
اگر دستور فقط یک خط باشد، می‌توانید
لازم نیست براکت‌هایی مثل این داشته باشید
که شما در واقع می‌توانید فقط بدانید که انجام دهید
این همه چیز را در یک خط قرار می‌دهد، مانند
بنابراین من قصد دارم این کار را انجام دهم، بنابراین اگر
بازیکن محروم است، این یک روش است
ارائه شده توسط K play که به شما می‌گوید آیا
بازیکن زمین‌گیر شده است، آنچه برمی‌گرداند یک ... است.
مقدار بولی که می‌گوید اینجا نوشته شده است
بولی به این معنی است که قرار است
یا درست یا غلط را برمی‌گرداند و اگر
یادت هست این دقیقاً همان چیزی است که ما
در یک دستور if می‌خواهیم زیرا اگر این
اگر درست باشد، این اجرا می‌شود اگر درست نباشد
پس این نمیشه، این نمیشه
بدوم، بنابراین اگر برگردم، فقط می‌توانم
تا وقتی که هستم بپرم
زمین گیر شده، بنابراین اکنون تنها چیزی که باقی مانده است
موانعی از سمت راست وجود داشته باشد
و سپس به محض اینکه تصادمی رخ دهد
ما اساساً وارد یک بازی خواهیم شد
بیش از
ایالت، پس حالا بریم سر اصل مطلب، من چی می‌گم؟
برای انجام این کار، من یک حلقه خواهم داشت
تابعی که K واقعاً بتواند از k استفاده کند.
حلقه فکر کنم همینه
نام، بنابراین تابع حلقه چیزی است
از K، بنابراین شما اولین پارامتر این است که چگونه
ثانیه‌های زیادی، بنابراین هر بار، بنابراین هر یک
دوم
این تابع را به صورت گذشته اجرا می‌کند.
یک ثانیه
پم، راستی اگه چیزی داری
سوالات، چیزهایی که نمی‌فهمی
در صورت تمایل می‌توانید در کامنت از آنها بپرسید
فکر می‌کنم در این بخش، من سعی کرده‌ام
آموزش برنامه نویسی در چند ساعت، آه، به
احتمالاً کسی که هرگز چنین چیزی نداشته است
یک خط کد در زندگی ما نوشته شده است، بنابراین
اگر شما این مورد را دارید، ممکن است هنوز هم باشید
گیج شده‌ایم چون داریم کارهای زیادی انجام می‌دهیم
ما با سرعت زیادی در حال عبور از بسیاری از موارد هستیم
مفاهیمی که هنوز نیاز به تمرین دارند
آن مفاهیم اصلی اساسی که من بودم
تدریس به شما یاد داد اما حالا شما در واقع
پایه‌ای داشته باشید که از آن بتوانید پیشرفت خود را افزایش دهید
دانش، پس این چیزیه که تو، تو
اساساً شما می‌دانید چه چیزی را نمی‌دانید
میشه بدونی کجا باید دنبالش بگردی؟
اطلاعات و غیره شما می‌دانید که چه شرایطی را باید رعایت کنید
در جستجوی گوگل خود استفاده کنید، بنابراین این
یه چیز خیلی باحال که داره اتفاق میفته
برای کمک به شما یک
خیلی زیاد، بنابراین در اینجا هر ۱ ثانیه یک بار حلقه زده می‌شود
ما قصد داریم یک شیء بازی ایجاد کنیم که
ما قصد داریم اینجا چیزی ایجاد کنیم که در حال انجام است
مستطیل بودن، مثلاً ۵۰ در
اوه، استفاده از کامپوننت مستقیم قرار است
موقعیتی دارم که نمی‌دانم چیست
موقعیت
باش
ام بیایید
بگو اگه ۲۰۰ تا ۲۰۰ بریم چی میشه؟
من فقط میرم ببینم داره اتفاق میفته
تا تو را اینجا قرار دهم، پس اگر ما [مقدار] را افزایش دهیم
فرض کنید مقدار x را خواهیم داشت
۸۰۰۰ و حتی بیشتر
۱۰۰۰ و بعدش شروع می‌کنیم
پایین، بنابراین باید مقدار آن را افزایش دهیم
اگر به یاد داشته باشید که چرا، چون
هرچه مقادیر Y بیشتر باشد، مقدار آن کمتر است.
شما
خوب شو، پس اینجا می‌بینمش، اینجا یه کم کوچیکه
خیلی کم است و ضمناً من اضافه خواهم کرد
منطقه
کامپوننتی که قرار است بدنه را اضافه کنم
کامپوننت و من قصد دارم آن را اضافه کنم
جزء طرح کلی به روش سفارش
از اجزا مهم نیست
کلی و تو از کی ال استفاده می‌کنی
کتابخانه، پس شروع می‌کنیم و حالا من چی هستم؟
بله، قرار است این کار را انجام دهد، بنابراین در حال افزایش است
جایی که آن چیزی نیست که ما می‌خواهیم، ​​اما هست
خیلی باحاله
عاملی که خیلی خوبه، اینه که
ناخواسته اما واقعاً
عالیه، کاری که من قراره انجام بدم اینه که بعدش
با داشتن این، من واقعاً یک [چیز] خواهم داشت
حرکت را حرکت دهید
جزء این است که شما فقط تعیین می‌کنید
جهت، بنابراین جهت با چه سرعتی
بنابراین اولین پارامتری که فکر می‌کنم هست
جهت، بنابراین شما از یک بردار دو استفاده می‌کنید، بنابراین
بردار ۲ فقط یک مقدار X و Y است.
ساختار داده ارائه شده توسط capl و
برای مشخصات خاص بسیار مفید است
مختصات و غیره، بنابراین در اینجا بردار ۲ به صورت زیر است:
فقط قراره بشه، مثلاً یه صفر و
سپس
سرعت، آیا باید سرعت را مشخص کنید؟
بله، سرعت یک ثانیه برای هر R است. من هستم
توضیح خواهم داد که چرا یک صفر در یک
اینجا سرعت فوری است، بیایید با سرعت ۳۰۰ حرکت کنیم
سرعت، حالا ببینیم خیلی بهتر شده، بهتر شده
فکر می‌کنم قالب‌بندی بهتری داره، بهتره
متاسفانه برای فرمت اینجوریه
آن
بعد از مدتی به این نقطه میرسم توسط من
قالبی که این کار را انجام می‌دهد، بله
خودکار باشه
خب، پس بردار دو اینجاست
به عنوان یک جهت استفاده می‌شود، بنابراین جهت X
و سپس جهت Y تا X
جهتی که به معنای حرکت در آن است
جهت uh X1 به معنای
درست است، بنابراین اگر بخواهم این به ... منتقل شود
در سمت چپ، برای Y باید منفی یک باشد.
AIS ما نیازی به نقل مکان نداریم
جهت و سپس این را در ضرب می‌کند
سرعتی که ۳ است
ما اینجا ۳۰۰ نفر هستیم
برو، بنابراین ما اکنون پرش خود را کمی داریم
شناور
بنابراین شاید اگر بازی را به این صورت انجام می‌دادیم
به جای اینکه به محض اینکه گرفتی بمیری
اگه بازی بود چی میشد؟ تو اونارو داری؟
جعبه ظاهر می‌شود و هدف زنده ماندن است
و از چارچوب‌ها خارج نشود
از چیزی که قرار است اتفاق بیفتد
یه پیچش خوب تو بازی دینو باش، پس بیا اینجا
من قصد دارم گرانش رو کم کنم، اه، کم کنم
گرانش شاید به ۸۰۰ برسد، بنابراین من دارم
کاهش داد
جاذبه، اوه، هنوز یه کم زیادی شناوره
به سلیقه من شاید باید بیشترش کنم
جاذبه آن را کاهش نمی‌دهد، بیایید ۸ عدد ۱۰۰۰ تایی قرار دهیم
۲۰۰۰ تا، من میگم، فرض کنیم ۲۰۰۰ تا باید باشه
یک خوب
برای همه ارزش قائل شوید
آره درسته ۲۰۰۰ تا میشه
خوبه حالا می‌تونیم بدونیم سرعت داریم
که
متفاوت است، پس بیایید این کار را انجام دهیم، پس بیایید یک
چند سرعت مختلف روی جعبه‌ها
می‌تواند به سمت حرکت کند، بنابراین من اینجا قصد دارم
تعریف کنید
سرعت‌های ثابت آرایه اوه و بعد من
یا ۳۰۰۰ تا خواهی داشت یا نقل مکان می‌کنی
واقعاً سریع در سرعت ۵۰۰ یا حتی سریع‌تر در سرعت ۸۰۰
و سپس روشی که می‌خواهم تعریف کنم
کی انتخاب کنم چی قراره داشته باشم؟
یک انتخاب تصادفی، بنابراین در جاوا اسکریپت شما
ماژول ریاضی را که در دسترس است، داشته باشید
به طور پیش فرض در دسترس است، شما فقط محاسبات انجام می دهید
و سپس تصادفی روشی است که من دنبال می‌کنم
برای استفاده از آن، یک نتیجه تصادفی به من خواهد داد
حالا من دارم از ۰ تا یک عدد می‌سازم
برای انجام منطق انتخاب اینجا، پس آه
سرعت فعلی که من آن را سرعت می‌نامم
ثابت است و من قصد دارم از آن عبور کنم
سرعت فعلی اینجاست، بنابراین می‌توانید ببینید که چطور
تعریف ثابت‌ها و متغیرها
برای خواناتر کردن کد شما مفید است
بنابراین در اینجا سرعت فعلی چیزی است که من می‌خواهم
آیا این است که من قصد دارم سرعت را با
با استفاده از براکت های اینجا به خاطر بسپارید
یک شاخص خاص را انتخاب کنید و این راه است
ما قصد داریم شاخصی را انتخاب کنیم که
قرار است اینجا یک مفهوم جدید باشد، بنابراین اگر من هستم
قصد استفاده از
ریاضی.
روش تصادفی، بنابراین از
ماژول ریاضی که از جاوا اسکریپت است
این دفعه این محور رو داری
به طور پیش‌فرض چیزی برای وارد کردن وجود ندارد
به شما عددی بین این دو خواهد داد
صفر و یک و سپس این را در هم ضرب می‌کنید
با استفاده از ضرب به یاد ماندنی،
با نماد ستاره بر اساس طول سرعت
سرعت‌ها انجام می‌دهند
طولی که به یاد دارید، می‌توانید آن را دریافت کنید
طول هر آرایه‌ای با استفاده از DOT
طول، اوه، آره، طول نقطه، حالا این
قرار نیست یک عدد کامل به شما بدهد
به همین دلیل است که باید از یک فرمول ریاضی دیگر استفاده کنید
تابعی به نام ریاضی
کف و شما باید داخل پرانتز قرار دهید
چون ما از همه اینها عبور خواهیم کرد
به عنوان یک
پرام و قرار است مطمئن شود که
عدد گرد است، بنابراین قرار است
عدد را کف کنید، بنابراین اگر 0.5 باشد، ...
اگر ۱.۵ باشد، صفر خواهد بود
یکی بودن و غیره، قرار است آن را نابود کند
یعنی ما اینجا یک عدد صحیح داریم
که قرار است به عنوان شاخص عمل کند، بنابراین
حالا بیایید نتیجه را اینجا ببینیم
سرعت را می بینید
تغییر می‌کند و سپس
به محض اینکه از صفحه نمایش خارج شویم، به
از دست دادن، بنابراین حالا تبدیل به یک زمان قبل می‌شود
شما
از دست دادن، بنابراین در اینجا می‌توانیم سرعت‌های مختلفی اضافه کنیم
خب، چه چیز خوبی در مورد این قطعه کد وجود دارد؟
این است که صرف نظر از مقیاس،
طول، بنابراین می‌توانم به اضافه کردن ادامه دهم
عناصر و کد هنوز در حال انجام است
این یکی را کار کن، پس این چیزی است که
شما واقعاً می‌خواهید هنگام نوشتن کد این باشد که
کدی داشته باشید که بتوان آن را تطبیق داد
تطبیق می‌دهد با
وضعیت اوه، وقتی که می‌تونی انجامش بدی، وقتی که
در موقعیت‌هایی هستید که می‌توانید
کدی مثل این داشته باشید، این واقعاً عالی است
این کد عالی است، بنابراین من اینجا هستم
بگوییم
۲۰۰۰ تا، مثلاً یکی به
۴۰۰۰ تا، ببینیم چطوره، چقدر آسونه یا
بازی دشوار
خیلی سریع میشه که نمیشه
مانند سیستم جاذبه تأثیر نمی گذارد
سیستم فیزیکی برای مدیریت این موضوع به مشکل برمی‌خورد
بیایید ۱،۱ را جمع کنیم
ما اینجا ۱۵۰۰ نفر هستیم
خیلی خوب پیش برو، حالا یه بازی داریم
آخرین مراحل این است که شاید اضافه کنید
تایمر و
اوه
اوه، یک تایمر اضافه کن و
بله، من تعجب می‌کنم که آیا خیلی آسان است؟
هرچند
اینجا ما
باشه پس بیا یه چیزی بخوریم
تایمر، بنابراین روش نمایش متن این است
همون چیزی که شما از اشیاء بازی استفاده می کنید و ...
بله، بنابراین اساساً می‌توانیم از این استفاده کنیم
شمارنده داشته باشد
بیرون، پس بیایید بگوییم شمارنده ثابت
صفر و این خواهد بود
امتیاز و هر چه مدت بیشتری در آن بمانید
مرزها، امتیاز بالاتر و
هر بار که این حلقه قرار است اجرا شود، ما
انجام دادن
پلاس پلاس که قراره اجرا بشه، افزایش پیدا می‌کنه
و سپس اینجا می‌توانید در بالا اضافه کنید
گوشه سمت چپ، بنابراین کاری که می‌توانید انجام دهید این است که
اساساً چیزی ایجاد کنید که در واقع شما آن را انجام نمی‌دهید
می‌خواهید یک شیء بازی جدید در بازی ایجاد کنید
کاری که می‌توانید انجام دهید این است که یک بازی بسازید
اینجا شیء
ثابت
شمارنده
رابط کاربری و من قصد دارم از تابع add استفاده کنم
در اینجا من از ویژگی متن استفاده خواهم کرد
و چون به طور پیش‌فرض اشیاء بازی عبارتند از
موقعیت‌ها در بالا سمت چپ قرار دارند
گوشه ای که واقعاً نیازی به مشخص کردن آن ندارم
موقعیت یا هر چیزی که می‌توانید اضافه کنید
یک متن در اینجا صفر است، بنابراین مولفه متن
از طرف کی هست، یه پیامک لازم دارم، پس من میرم
فقط قرار است اینجا صفر بگذارم و
پس کاری که می‌توانید انجام دهید این است که بعد از
با افزایش می‌توانید شمارنده داشته باشید. رابط کاربری
و سپس به متن دسترسی داشته باشید
ویژگی و سپس می‌توانید آن را تغییر دهید
متن با شمارنده C جدید، اکنون به خاطر داشته باشید
اینجا یک عدد است و معمولاً شما می‌خواهید
برای انجام کاری مانند دو رشته با استفاده از این دو
روش رشته‌ای برای شبیه بودن
واقعاً چطور می‌گوییم واقعاً در ... باشیم
با این حال، به روش صحیح عمل کنید
جاوا اسکریپت برای تبدیل به صورت زیر کار می‌کند
یک متن به عنوان متن قرار داده شده، عدد
مستقیماً به این دلیل که اگر این کار را انجام دهید، به یاد داشته باشید
علامت بعلاوه که قرار است به هم بپیوندد
پس آره، پس فقط می‌دونی که فقط بذارش
شمارنده اینجا و اگر اینجا تکلیف را انجام دهم
به یک متغیر ثابت، به یاد داشته باشید که ما
نمیشه؟ منظورت چیه ثابت؟
متغیر اوه، باشه، پس این باید باشه
تبدیل به یک متغیر let
چون ما نمیتونیم زیادش کنیم
در غیر این صورت و پس از آن باید کار کند
در گوشه بالا سمت چپ می‌بینید که
سه چهار با شروع حلقه اوه و
بعدش باختم، حالا باید چیکار کنم؟
آیا قرار است بازی را تمام کنم؟
شرط، بنابراین آنچه اتفاق می‌افتد این است که ما نیاز داریم
در منطق بازیکن، در واقع یک ... وجود دارد
مؤلفه‌ای به نام
جزء خارج از صفحه نمایش، بنابراین اگر من بروم
اینجا اینجا در انتهای پخش کننده
تعریف اگر من خارج از صفحه نمایش اتفاقاً
از شماره خطوط برای پیدا کردن خودتان استفاده کنید
این جزء خارج از صفحه وجود دارد که
یعنی اگر قرار است چه زمانی ردیابی شود
تو رفتی
صفحه نمایش، بنابراین اکنون اینجا اینجا هستید که قرار است
که به شما اجازه می‌دهد داشته باشید
دسترسی به یک روش جدید به نام is
یا وقتی خاموش است
صفحه نمایش خاموش است
صفحه نمایش، این یک نوع داده بولی است، این چیزی نیست که
من
می‌خوای اممم چی شده؟
عملکرد در Destroyer روشن، خاموش است.
خروج
صفحه نمایش، بنابراین این روش طول خواهد کشید
در تابعی به عنوان peram آن و ...
قرار است آن تابع را هنگام بازی اجرا کند
شیء از صفحه نمایش خارج می‌شود، بنابراین شما اینجا هستید
کاری که می‌توانید انجام دهید این است که پیام را در آن نمایش دهید
تقریباً به همان روشی که از متن استفاده می‌کنیم
کامپوننتی که با فونت‌های بزرگ مثل این کار می‌کند
واقعاً مفید نیست زیرا پنهان است
کد واقعی، بنابراین امیدوارم در ویرایشگر شما باشد
هرچند تو اون رفتارها رو نداری، پس
اینجا بازی تمام شد
بنابراین در گوشه بالا سمت چپ قرار است
اگه به ​​خودم اجازه بدم، بازی الان تموم شده
بازی تمام شد، حالا می‌تونی ببینی، می‌بینی
با این حال، امتیاز همچنان ادامه دارد، که البته همینطور است.
یه جورایی عجیبه اما امم این چیزی نیست که ما
منظورم رو که اساساً می‌خوام، اممم، پس چی؟
اتفاق می افتد این است که ما می توانیم تصمیم بگیریم که
ام ما می‌توانستیم
تعریف کن تا من نخوام پیچیده اش کنم
چیزها، بنابراین کاری که می‌توانیم انجام دهیم تعریف کردن است
یک صحنه، بنابراین در KL صحنه‌هایی دارید، اه
تنها راه تعریف آنها این است که
فراخوانی متد صحنه با نام دلخواه
شما می‌خواهید برای آن صحنه بازی استفاده کنید
تمام می‌شود و سپس پارامتر دوم اجرا می‌شود
منطقی باشد که قرار است دنبالش بگردیم
آن صحنه و قرار است یک تیر باشد
تابع یا اینجا استفاده از آن راحت‌تر است
یک تابع خطا به عنوان یک فلش so
توابع واقعاً در K play مفید هستند.
شاید باید به آنها یاد می‌دادم
به هر حال شروع میشه، اوه، من الان یه لحظه ام، من
قراره بهت یاد بدم که من قراره
شما را به سمت یک منبع واقعاً عالی هدایت می‌کند
برای جاوا اسکریپت، پس آره، تو هستی
احتمالاً یاد می‌گیره
همه چیز به یکباره وجود دارد، بنابراین من
این بازی صحنه‌ای را نامگذاری کرد
و آنچه در اینجا اتفاق می افتد می توانید
به جای نمایش بازی روی متن
اینجا می‌توانید آن را نمایش دهید
موقعیت k را قرار دهید.
فراخوانی کامپوننت موقعیت از درون
روش تابع مرکز از Klay که
قرار است شیء بازی را در مرکز قرار دهد و
بعدش اینجا روی صفحه خروج، من فقط
قرار است K.O انجام دهم که روش مورد استفاده است
برای رفتن به یک صحنه خاص و من می‌توانم بروم
به صحنه‌ی پایان بازی مثل اون، پس الان
اگر من به اینجا بروم و اجازه دهم پون خود را نجات دهم، این است
قراره بازی تموم بشه و بعدش تو نیاز داری
برای انجام بازی، صفحه را رفرش کنید
دوباره حالا اینه که این بازیه و
اوه، امیدوارم چند تا چیز یاد گرفته باشی و اوه
بله، بازی کردنش خیلی لذت بخشه، این یه
هرچند کمی خیلی آسان است، بنابراین می‌توانید آن را تغییر دهید
ارزش‌ها اما حداقل شما اولین ارزش خود را دارید
اولین بازی، حالا وقت آموزش دادن است
چطور میشه اون بازی رو اکسپورت کرد؟ چطور میشه اوه؟
آن را به روشی که می خواهید انجام دهید منتشر کنید
که اه، ساده‌ترین راه برای گذاشتنش روی آن. من
که خروجی وب یا جالت بازی را می‌پذیرد
آن وب‌سایت‌ها، همانطور که شما می‌خواهید
این کار را انجام دهید، این است که ابتدا باید خودتان را باز کنید
دوباره ترمینال و سپس اینجا می‌توانید
ببخشید، از کنترل استفاده کنید، این ترمینال است.
پنجره‌ای که می‌توانید از کنترل C برای لغو آن استفاده کنید
اوه، اون سروری که راه انداختی اوه
خاتمه دادن، سرور I را خاتمه می‌دهد.
فکر کنید در سیستم عامل مک، دستور C یا
کنترل c هم همینطور من ندارم من ندارم
خوب یادش بخیر مدتی گذشته از وقتی که
از مک استفاده نکرده‌ام، بنابراین حالا اینجا هستید
قرار است npm run اجرا شود
اگر دستور npm run را اجرا کنید، اکنون می‌توانید بسازید.
ساختن آن قرار است این را تغییر دهد و
آن را برای تولید بسازید و در حال انجام است
برای ایجاد این پوشه دیسک اکنون به
بررسی کنید که آیا واقعاً کار می‌کند یا خیر
خروجی که قرار است بسازید
npm um را اجرا کنید
پیش‌نمایشی که قرار است پیش‌نمایش شما را نمایش دهد
ساخت آن باعث ایجاد یک Local دیگر خواهد شد
میزبان، من قصد دارم لینک را کپی کنم.
به صورت دستی چون قراره بپوشمش
مرورگر اج من و الان که می‌بینید کار می‌کند
کاری که باید انجام دهید این است که به سادگی باز کنید
این را در فایل اکسپلورر خود زیپ کنید
این سه را در یک پوشه قرار دهید
چیزها و سپس شما فقط می توانید بکشید و
اونا رو بنداز تو فایل .io تا هـ. آیو
راهنمای خودشان را در مورد چگونگی انجام این کار دارند
تو وب منتشر کن، تو فقط فایل زیپ رو داری
فایل و سپس شما که شامل
نقطه ورود
index.html دارایی‌ها و اساساً
خروجی شما، شما آن را قرار داده‌اید.
اونجاست که شما اون رو روی وب بازی وب تنظیم می‌کنید
صادرات و این اینگونه است که شما
بازی خود را منتشر کنید، اوه، چطور آن را دریافت می‌کنید؟
آماده برای
تولید، پس حالا قدم بعدی چیست؟
مراحلی که باعث میشه چیزهای زیادی یاد گرفته باشید و
شاید خیلی زیاده و وقتشه که بدونی
استراحت کنید و همچنین در مورد بعدی صحبت کنید
مراحل، بنابراین کانال من اینجاست، بنابراین من آن را انجام می‌دهم
توسعه‌دهنده بازی جاوااسکریپت و تایپ‌اسکریپت
بیشتر آموزش‌ها و می‌توانید ببینید که آنجا وجود دارد
آموزش‌های زیادی وجود دارد که شما هستید
اکنون برای شما قابل دسترسی است که نمی‌توانستید
قبلاً انجام دهید زیرا نمی دانستید
جاوا اسکریپت به عنوان همه و بنابراین من به شما توصیه می‌کنم
می‌تونم اینجا برم اما چیزی که من بیشتر توصیه می‌کنم اوه
شاید اولش این باشه که در واقع نه تو
می‌توانم آموزش‌هایم را فوراً تماشا کنم
بعد از این یکی اما می‌توانید بررسی کنید
این منبع جالب به نام
آموزش مدرن جاوا اسکریپت که
شامل همه چیز در مورد جاوا اسکریپت است
کلاس‌های مدیریت خطا، چیزهای promise
قول وزن سین چیزی که من انجام دادم را می‌دهد
در این پروژه اصلاً پوشش داده نشده است
متاسفم، این دوره فشرده خیلی مفید است، اما
فکر می‌کنم در آموزش‌هایم وجود دارد
مدتی را صرف توضیح آن کردم اما نه
همیشه نه در هر آموزشی
بنابراین این چیزی است که می‌توانید توصیه کنید
شما فقط نگاه می کنید و فکر می کنم اینطور است
واقعاً دانش شما را جمع آوری خواهم کرد
و چه چیز واقعاً عالی در مورد این
جاوا اسکریپت را ریسورس کنید. اطلاعات این است که
شما یک نوار جستجو دارید تا بتوانید جستجو کنید
مفاهیم خاص، بنابراین برای مثال اگر من ... ببینم
جستجو
قول می‌دهم که قرار است دقیق‌تر شوم، مثلاً
متن خاصی که نحوه آن را توضیح می‌دهد
الان کار می‌کنه، بله، پس این منبع همراهشه
با ام دی ان
MDM M mdn web
بله، من می‌گویم اینها اسناد مو هستند.
با کیفیت‌ترین اسنادی که می‌توانید پیدا کنید
در مورد جاوا اسکریپت، سلام به همه، خوش آمدید
به این ویدیوی جدید و امروز قراره پخش بشه
برای یک دوره فشرده در کتابخانه کلی
بنابراین Klay یک کتابخانه برای ساخت بازی است.
جاوا اسکریپت و در این ویدیو قصد داریم
برای مرور مفاهیم مختلف این
کتابخانه و قرار نیست باشد
آموزش‌های معمول مبتنی بر پروژه اما اگر
شما به موارد بیشتری بر اساس پروژه علاقه‌مند هستید
آموزش‌هایی که در آنها یاد می‌گیرید
مفاهیم را همانطور که می‌روید، آزادانه تماشا کنید
ویدیوی قبلی، بنابراین من از قبل آماده کرده‌ام
فهرست مفاهیم و چیزهایی که می‌خواهم
در مورد K playay صحبت کنید، بنابراین این
ویدیو بیشتر برای تماشا در نظر گرفته شده است
چیزی که شما به صورت منفعلانه تماشا می‌کنید و
شما بعداً به آن اشاره می‌کنید، بنابراین شروع می‌کنیم.
اول از همه من در وب‌سایت KL GS هستم
و این وب‌سایت KS بسیار مهم است
چون اینجا جاییه که قراره بری
مستندات را ببینید و به آنها دسترسی داشته باشید
زمین بازی و غیره، بنابراین کاملاً کامل نیست
هنوز کامله، پس قبل از ادامه دادن نیاز دارم
برای توضیح بیشتر و دقیق‌تر منشأ
داستان کلی، بنابراین کلی قبلاً
به نام کابوم جی‌زی و کابوم جی‌زی بود
کتابخانه‌ای برای ساخت بازی که
اگر مرا تماشا کنید، توسط تکرار نگهداری می‌شود
ویدیوی قبلی در مورد موضوعی که من در آن هستم
توضیح دهید که چرا قصد تغییر نام تجاری (ریبرند) دارید
می‌بینید که اینجا کمی زمینه وجود دارد
اما فعلاً همین است
کابوم اما فقط با یک چیز جدید
نام، پس بیایید مستقیماً به درون ام بپریم
فرآیند نصب، بنابراین برای نصب K
پلی، راه‌های زیادی وجود دارد و من دارم می‌روم
برای صحبت در مورد سه راه و فکر می‌کنم
دو راه وجود داره یا آره، فکر می‌کنم وجود داره
مانند دو یا سه روشی که در اینجا ذکر شده است
به هر حال من فکر می‌کنم هر سه راه درست هستند
ذکر خواهد شد، بنابراین می‌توانید از آن استفاده کنید
بسته‌ای به نام create K play برای ایجاد
شاید باید اندازه فونت را بزرگتر کنم
بفرمایید تا بتونید استفاده کنید
یک بسته به نام create capl برای ایجاد
برای داربست زدن به کاپل خود
پروژه و من شخصاً از آن استفاده نمی‌کنم
این روش فقط به این دلیل است که از es استفاده می‌کند
به عنوان بسته نرم افزاری بسازید و باید
برای دیدن، مرورگر خود را به صورت دستی رفرش کنید
تغییراتی که من ترجیح می‌دهم از vit استفاده کنم که ...
یک bundler دیگر اما این گزینه اگر
شما مبتدی هستید و تازه شروع کرده‌اید
با npm و تو اینو نمیدونی اه
bundler و غیره خیلی سرراست است
روش استفاده، بنابراین این یک ابزار CLI است، بنابراین اگر من
بنابراین فکر می‌کنم این فقط نکته خواهد بود
به سمت بسته روی npm، بنابراین اگر من
آن را باز کنید، می‌توانید موارد مختلف را ببینید
گزینه‌هایی که می‌توانید اضافه کنید، تایپ‌اسکریپت، شما می‌توانید
حتی توری را هم اضافه کنید که یک فناوری است که من
برای ساخت آموزش بازی دسکتاپ استفاده شده است
اوه، ویدیوی قبلی کدوم بود؟
کانال و این همان چیزی است که شما دارید
مثال‌هایی که می‌توانید با یک مثال شروع کنید
و غیره، خیلی خیلی... آیا می‌تواند خیلی... باشد؟
مفید فقط یک چیز که در موردش دوست ندارم
این واقعیت است که شما باید تجدید قوا کنید
به صورت دستی
مرورگر، حالا می‌توانید از CDN استفاده کنید، این
گزینه دوم و این گزینه‌ای که من دوست دارم
و من برای خودم خیلی ازش استفاده کردم
آموزش زیرا تنظیم آن بسیار آسان است
بنابراین اگر نمی‌خواهید از nodejs استفاده کنید
و شما فقط می‌خواهید از HTML CSS پایه استفاده کنید
و جاوا اسکریپت هم که خب میتونید از این استفاده کنید
روش، بنابراین این روش نحوه کار آن است
که شما به این لینک اشاره می‌کنید و اینجا هستید
نسخه را داشته باشید و بله، این اتفاق خواهد افتاد
فایلی را که معمولاً ترجیح می‌دهم بارگذاری کنم
به اون لینک برید و بعد فایل رو دانلود کنید
خودش به جای اینکه فقط لینک را پیست کند
اینجا اما شما می‌توانید هر دو را انجام دهید و
مزیت این روش این است که واقعاً
این به شدت به گره وابسته است و آن
فکر می‌کنم اگر این کار را نکنید، واقعاً کار خواهد کرد
به نظر من قابلیت نگهداریش بیشتره
حس می‌کنم، بنابراین منظورم این است که اگر من
مثل پنج سال پیش به پروژه دست نزن
سال‌ها و من برمی‌گردم، قرار است
هنوز هم دقیقاً به همان شکل کار می‌کند
چیزی برای به‌روزرسانی و غیره وجود ندارد، زیرا ...
هنگ می‌کند، نسخه خاصی را می‌گیرد و غیره
و بعد شما اما شما هم می‌توانید این کار را انجام دهید
با nodejs اما شما مانند آن را ندارید
چیزی که لازم نیست گره نصب کنید
گره و غیره بنابراین این مزیت است
بنابراین در اینجا از نوع ماژول uh in استفاده شده است
جاوا اسکریپت، پس این یک جاوا اسکریپت است
جاوا اسکریپت n ماژول‌های بومی، بنابراین می‌توانید
هر دو را اینجا یا به روش قدیمی انجام دهید، جایی که
این دفعه فقط اینجا بارگذاریش کن
در اطراف شما به جای GS به GS نیاز دارید
MG ها و سپس شما از آن در جای دیگری استفاده می کنید
تگ اسکریپت یا فایل JS دیگری که شما
از طریق یک تگ اسکریپت بارگذاری کنید یا از آن استفاده کنید
این روش جدید، روشی جدیدتر برای داشتن
ماژول را با تمام مواردی که به شما امکان می‌دهد تایپ کنید
استفاده از دستورات import
و در نهایت، این روش npm است
با vit که ابتدا باید نصب کنید
V و سپس از npm install K play استفاده می‌کنید
و سپس می‌توانید نسخه را با استفاده از آن مشخص کنید
با استفاده از این نمادگذاری اینجا و سپس اینجا
یه کم پیچیده‌تره که
توضیح بده چطور انجامش بدم، اوه، اما اگه نگاه کنی
به هر حال، توسعه‌دهنده وب من به عنوان یک بازی، آه
نمونه کارها من نمونه کارهای من آموزش بازی
یا حتی فکر می‌کنم از آن در تور استفاده کردم
آموزشی که در آن از VT استفاده شده است اما فکر می‌کنم
شما واقعاً باید به ساخت اه مراجعه کنید
نمونه کارهای توسعه‌دهنده به عنوان یک بازی دوبعدی
آموزش در کانال من که واقعاً مفید است
از طریق نحوه راه اندازی کی پلی با
خب کابوم، اما این همون چیزه، پس
با
خیلی خب، حالا که فهمیدیم چطور
نصب K play چگونه انجام می‌شود؟
بازی‌ها، بنابراین این سوالی است که شما دارید
ممکن است تعجب کنید که چگونه پاسخ دهید و
سپس البته بسته به ابزاری که استفاده می‌کنید
استفاده از آن متفاوت خواهد بود اما برای
ساده‌ترین، ساده‌ترین روشی که CDN وجود دارد
شما فقط آن فایل را زیپ می‌کنید و فایل خودتان را هم زیپ می‌کنید.
اساساً پایه کد را قرار دهید و سپس آن را قرار دهید
.io یا در صفحات GitHub و غیره تا زمانی که
یک فایل index.html وجود دارد که باید باشد
خیلی رک و راست، امم، قصد ندارم
واقعاً عمیقاً در مورد چگونگی انجام این کار غرق شوید
فکر کنم اینجا باشه چون شاید بتونه
بسته به شرایط می‌تواند در آینده تغییر کند
ابزارهایی که استفاده می‌کنید، بنابراین اگر می‌خواهید من
می‌توانم یک پست وبلاگ در مورد آن بنویسم، آه، همین الان
روشی که من آموزش‌های نوشتاری در مورد آن می‌نویسم
ساب‌استک که خبرنامه من است، می‌توانید آن را تهیه کنید.
پیوند را در توضیحات دنبال کنید، بنابراین اگر شما
محتوای نوشتاری و مکان بیشتری می‌خواهید
از محتوای نوشتاری این است که اگر می‌خواهید
یاد گرفتن انجام کاری خاص
خیلی راحت‌تره چون
به راحتی می‌توانید به یک متن مراجعه کنید
به جای یک ویدیو و برای پروژه بیشتر
آموزش‌های مبتنی بر این، به عنوان یک مورد بهتر است
ویدیو چون میدونی که فقط میتونم نشون بدم
شما چگونه می‌توانید یک پروژه را از ... بسازید
toz و نوشتنش خیلی طول میکشه
الان این ویدیو رو گذاشتم، من الان دارم اینو میبینم
ضبط استثنا است زیرا
معمولاً این در قالب متن خواهد بود
اما چون محتوای زیادی وجود دارد، من
می‌خواهم پوشش دهم، من هرگز این را نخواهم داشت
وقتشه بنویسمش، شاید این کار رو بکنم
بخش‌هایی از آن را در آینده به عنوان ... بنویسید
محتوای نوشته شده بسیار خوب است، بنابراین حالا که ما
روش‌های مختلفی را که شما استفاده کرده‌اید، پوشش داده‌ام
آیا می‌توان K play و غیره را نصب کرد؟ بیایید به سراغ
زمین بازی، بنابراین زمین بازی است
اساساً ویرایشگری که می‌توانید از آن استفاده کنید
آنلاین و بدون نیاز به نصب
هر چیزی فقط برای امتحان کردن کاپل، پس اینجا
می‌توانید ببینید که capl توسط ... وارد شده است.
به طور پیش فرض شما واردات را نمی بینید
جمله اینه که اه، اون یه چیزیه
مخصوص این زمین بازی اما در چه زمانی
شما از کد vs استفاده می‌کنید که باید انجام دهید
مثل بازی cap از capl و غیره، پس چطور؟
شما بوم را در یک Play مقداردهی اولیه می‌کنید
پروژه خوبی است که شما آن را K playay می‌نامید
روش تابع ببخشید و بعد این
تابع Klay گزینه‌های مختلفی دارد و
بیایید به سراغ آن گزینه‌ها برویم، پس
البته من نیاز دارم
برای افزایش اندازه فونت به این شکل
ببخشید تا ببینید دارم فرض می‌کنم
شاید شما این را از طریق موبایل تماشا می‌کنید و
بله، پس شروع می‌کنیم، ما یک متن بزرگ داریم
پس بیا بنویسیمش، پس این نمایشنامه‌ست
تابع به صورت اختیاری یک شیء را دریافت می‌کند.
که می‌توانید مجموعه‌ای از پارامترها را مشخص کنید
به طور پیش‌فرض، بوم هنگام مقداردهی اولیه
کل فضای موجود را اشغال خواهد کرد
با این حال اگر می‌خواهید موارد خاصی را مشخص کنید
عرض و ارتفاع را می‌توانید با استفاده از
برای مثال، ویژگی عرض
[موسیقی]
۱,۲۸۰ و ارتفاعی که قرار است استفاده کنم
۷۲۰ و اگر این کار را انجام دهید و خوب رفرش کنید
چون اگه این کار رو بکنم خیلی زوم می‌کنم
زوم، شاید بفهمم
بله، من رفرش می‌کنم، پس یک اشکال وجود دارد.
با توجه به اینکه زمین بازی به این بزرگی است،
آره
ببخشید میشه اندازه فونت رو بزرگتر کنید؟
به هر حال، می‌بینید که لازم است
اوه، عرض و ارتفاع مناسب
با این حال اگر می‌خواهید بوم نقاشی‌تان
مقیاس‌پذیر به این معنا که سازگار خواهد شد
اندازه آن صرف نظر از اندازه پنجره
و غیره، می‌توانید از گزینه جعبه نامه استفاده کنید
که مطمئن می‌شود بوم نقاشی
مقیاس خواهد گرفت
بر این اساس اما در حالی که باقی مانده است
نسبت ابعاد را حفظ کنید، بنابراین شما این کار را انجام می‌دهید
جعبه نامه درست است و قرار است اضافه شود
میله‌های سیاه، اوه، جاهای دیگه، کی، کی
وقتی چیزی برای انجام دادن نیست، پس من چی؟
یعنی اگر تا زمانی که
نسبت ابعاد رعایت می‌شود، بنابراین اگر
آیا بیشتر گسترش نخواهد یافت؟
در غیر این صورت، جنبه را نقض می‌کند
نسبت، بنابراین اینگونه است که شما یک مقیاس‌پذیر دریافت می‌کنید
بوم‌هایی که جنبه‌ای را حفظ می‌کنند
نسبت اکنون چیزی نیز وجود دارد
گزینه اشکال‌زدایی به طور پیش‌فرض درست است
گفت که روی درست تنظیم شده است و به شما اجازه می‌دهد
با استفاده از کلید F1 حالت اشکال‌زدایی را باز کنید
حالا، حالا، اینجا، من توصیه می‌کنم که وقتی شما
پروژه متاسفم، کابو اوه، کپل خود را تمام کنید
شما آن را روی false تنظیم می‌کنید تا از این امر جلوگیری کنید
بازیکن، کاربر نهایی، قادر به
به این حالت اشکال‌زدایی دسترسی پیدا کنید که توسط آن انجام می‌شود
با فشار دادن کلید F1، می‌توانم این را داشته باشم
آیا می‌توانم آن را اصلاح کنم؟
فونت، فونت، بزرگنمایی، باشه و بعد اگه من
فقط پنجره را همانطور که در ابتدا بود قرار دهید
ج- من قصد دارم
تازه کردن و سپس اینجا، بنابراین من فقط
این را کشف کرد
فونت را بزرگنمایی کنید و سپس می‌توانید داشته باشید
برای انجام این کار به صورت دستی، بله، می‌توانم یک ... داشته باشم.
میانبر
ویرایشگر فونت اخیراً استفاده شده، بزرگنمایی فونت
باشه، من فقط می‌خوام اینو تنظیم کنم، پس
که لازم نباشد پنجره را بزرگ‌نمایی کنم
کل ماجرا اه
بنابراین فکر می‌کنم از همان استفاده می‌کند، اه
ویرایشگر اصلی به عنوان BS
کد باشه، بیا بیشتر این کار رو انجام بدیم
سریع فکر می‌کنم اشکالی نداره، باشه
حالا خیلی خوبه، پس داری
کادر لایه عرض-ارتفاع و اشکال‌زدایی
گزینه و حالا چیز دیگری که می‌خواهم
mention خاصیت سراسری است، بنابراین توسط
بیایید ابتدا به حالت اشکال‌زدایی نگاهی بیندازیم، بنابراین اگر
شما قبل از اینکه روی بوم خود کلیک کنید، مطبوعات را فشار دهید
اف۱
اوه اوه، اول باید اینو حذف کنم
بخشی که کد نامعتبر است، درست تا اینجا
F1 را فشار دهید هیچ اتفاقی نمی‌افتد، چون من من
آن را روی false تنظیم کنید تا به طور پیش‌فرض true باشد.
بنابراین وقتی مشخص نکنید، قرار است
درست باشد و سپس می‌توانید FPS را ببینید
شمارنده و سپس می‌توانید جعبه‌های ضربه را ببینید
کی قراره ازش استفاده کنیم، پس فعلاً من هستم
قراره روی True تنظیمش کنم، اما وقتی که
پروژه‌ات رو تموم کن، من واقعاً واقعاً
توصیه می‌کنم که همین الان اینجا اشتباه کنید
آخرین گزینه‌ای که می‌خواهم در موردش صحبت کنم،
ویژگی گزینه جهانی و من معمولاً تنظیم می‌کنم
اگر نادرست باشد، این به این معنی است که اگر
شما این را روی متدهای playay نادرست تنظیم می‌کنید و
منظورم این است که فقط می‌توان از توابع استفاده کرد
متاسفم، می‌خواهم آن را به حقیقت تبدیل کنم.
به طور پیش فرض نادرست است اما اگر نه
بیخیال، ببخشید، خودمم گیج شدم
این نادرست است زیرا ما نمی‌خواهیم که چنین باشد
جهانی باشد، بنابراین اگر جهانی باشد، کدام است؟
به طور پیش فرض این است که می توانید از Klay استفاده کنید
متدها و توابع خارج از این
با این حال، اگر Global را روی context تنظیم کنید،
همه روش‌های کبوم، اوه، کلی، غلط هستند و
توابع باید از طریق این مورد استفاده شوند، بنابراین
شما K نقطه روی نام تابع قرار می‌دهید
و روش
و غیره، باشه، حالا که این موضوع رو پوشش دادم
بیایید به شما نشان دهیم که چگونه دارایی‌ها را بارگذاری کنید
فکر می‌کنم در حال بارگذاری دارایی‌ها هستم.
مثالی که می‌توانیم به آن نگاهی بیندازیم و ...
بذار یه نگاهی بهش بندازم تا دیگه نداشته باشمش
برای پیدا کردن دارایی‌های جدید و نشان دادن آنها به شما، اسپرایت
شاید اطلس اسپرایت، خود اسپرایت باشه
به عنوان مثال، از این سایت استفاده کنید
خیلی کاربردیه، مثال‌های زیادی داره
میشه نگاه کرد؟
سایه‌زن‌های ذرات خوب
افکت پست روشن
آر پی جی
بنه
باشه باشه پس
حالا ما این را داریم، باشه
پس اون چیزی که من میخوام نیست
حالا ما درست پیش رفتیم، پس این
مثال Sprite داخلی و واقعاً
به شما نشان می‌دهد که چگونه Spriteها را بارگذاری کنید، بنابراین اینجا
موارد C را نادیده گرفتید، در اینجا می‌توانید
مجموعه‌ای از مقیاس‌بندی و یک فونت پیش‌فرض که
گزینه‌های دیگری هم هستند اما احساس کردم که اینطور است
مقیاس خیلی مهم نبود
تا حدودی مهم است اما بقیه مهم نیستند
چون دارم یه فونت پیش‌فرض رو بارگذاری می‌کنم
می‌توانید این کار را در جای دیگری انجام دهید که می‌توانید بارگذاری کنید
F خاص را وقتی که به آن نیاز دارید، تحت
بعداً به مؤلفه متن خاص خواهیم پرداخت
به اجزای مختلفی که ما بررسی می‌کنیم نگاه می‌کنیم
نیاز دارید، بنابراین مهمترین بخش اینجاست
قسمت بار، پس اینجا اوه، چون کی پلی هست
به صورت سراسری و بدون زمینه استفاده می‌شود.
می‌تواند بلافاصله از بار Sprite استفاده کند
روش جالبی بود، اما اگر قرار بود استفاده کنید
تنظیماتی که قبلاً به شما نشان داده‌ام
می‌نویسم const
k.l من امر جهانی را اینجا به وجود می‌آوردم.
نادرست و سپس در اینجا باید انجام دهم
ک. بارگذاری و غیره اما من دوست ندارم دوباره انجامش دهم
کل ماجرا، کل مثال، اممم، تو
از آنجایی که ما لینک را داریم، می‌دانیم چیست
بیا اینجا انجامش بدیم تا تو واقعاً
همه چیز را می‌فهمم، پس من قصد دارم
همه اینها را حذف کنید و من نشان خواهم داد
شما اینجا هستید، ما اینجاییم
بنابراین اول از همه، من فقط می‌خواهم آن را کپی کنم
اینجا لینک به سمت اسپرایت است
بنابراین لازم نیست مراقب باشم، آه، دنبال چیزی بگردم
یک برگه Sprite دیگر، پس اول از همه
بیایید وارد کنیم، بیایید از آن استفاده کنیم
مقداردهی اولیه ما
بوم و سپس با یک ثابت K و غیره اکنون
اگر موقع نوشتن کد دکمه‌های کنترل s را بزنم
این شکلی خواهد بود
حالا کاری که قراره اینجا انجام بدم اینه که من
می‌خوام تنظیمش کنم، اوه، من فقط می‌خوام
تنظیم کنید
مالکیت جهانی برای بودن
غلط و همینه، و حالا من هستم
قرار است بارگذاری اسپرایت را شروع کنیم، بنابراین
ک. بارگذاری Sprite روش معمول شماست
برای بارگذاری دارایی‌ها از Sprite هم استفاده کنید
اطلس، اما فکر نمی‌کنم فعلاً این کار را بکنی
من فقط قصد دارم بار را ارائه دهم
تابع اسپرایت به دلیل اطلس اسپرایت
زمانی است که شما یک برگه Sprite با
یک تصویر متنوع با اسپرایت‌های متنوع
ورق ها در همان تصویر هستند و شما می خواهید
بخش‌های خاصی را برش دهید و آنها را بسازید
برگه‌های اسپرایت خودشان، بنابراین این چیزی است که
شاید برای من مفید باشد، من قصد دارم این کار را انجام دهم
به مثالی که استفاده می‌کند، عمیق شوید
بعداً اطلس اسپرایت اما فعلاً همینطور است
واقعاً مهم است که بفهمیم چگونه
صفحات Sprite و یا فقط صفحات پایه را بارگذاری کنید
اسپرایت، بنابراین شما از این بار اسپرایت استفاده می‌کنید
متد و سپس اولین پارامتری که می‌گیرد
کلیدی است که می‌خواهید از آن استفاده کنید، بنابراین ...
نامی که قرار است در آن استفاده کنید
کد شما برای ارجاع به آن اسپرایت در اینجا
من اسمش را دینو می‌گذارم چون...
دایناسور و سپس پارامتر دوم این است
مسیر منتهی به آن تصویر در فایل شما
سیستم در پایگاه کد شما اما در اینجا ما
از قبل چیزی توسط [چیزی] ارائه شده است
زمین بازی، بنابراین من قصد دارم از آن استفاده کنم و
پس فعلاً می‌توانید از هر دوی اینها استفاده کنید
دو کالسکه و تمام، پس حالا من هستم
قصد دارم یک شیء بازی ایجاد کنم
برای صحبت بیشتر در مورد اینکه اشیاء بازی چه هستند
بعداً در کابوم اما من فقط قصد دارم
در واقع من حتی نیازی به اختصاص دادن آن ندارم
به یک مقدار ثابت اما فقط برای ساده نگه داشتن آن
برای ایجاد یک شیء بازی در K، شما باید
از متد تبلیغ استفاده کنید و سپس وارد شوید
آرایه‌ای از اجزا، آن اجزا
بیشتر توسط K play ارائه می‌شوند اما شما
می‌توانید اجزای سفارشی خودتان را ایجاد کنید، بنابراین
یکی از اجزای ارائه شده است
کامپوننت اسپرایت و شما به عنوان
نام اسپرایتی که می‌خواهید را param کنید
الان نمایش داده میشه اگه کنترل رو بزنم نجاتت میدم
می‌توان دید که کل صفحه Sprite ایجاد شده است
به طور پیش‌فرض در اینجا نمایش داده می‌شود وقتی که شما
یک شیء بازی ایجاد کنید که در ... نباشد
موقعیت، شما آن را مشخص نمی‌کنید
مؤلفه موقعیتی که قرار است قرار دهد
الان گوشه بالا سمت چپه، اینجاست
جایی که شاید داشتن ترازو مفید باشد
اینجا ملک بگذارید و آن را چهار برابر مقیاس کنید تا
که بتوانید آن را بهتر ببینید، پس این
حالا کل صفحه اسپرایت چطور؟
آیا تنظیمات خاصی انجام می‌دهید؟
انیمیشن‌ها، بنابراین در اینجا شما یک گزینه اختیاری دارید
پم سوم برای بار اسپرایت در اه
متد spr را بارگذاری کنید که در آن می‌توانید مشخص کنید
ویژگی برش X و برش y
اساساً ویژگی برش X
بهش بگو چند تا فریم داره
در محور x به صورت افقی، بنابراین یک ۲ ۳ ۴
۵ ۶ ۷ ۸ نه، نه فریم وجود دارد، بنابراین من هستم
قراره اینجا نه تا داشته باشیم و بعد برش بزنیم
Y یکی از آنها خواهد بود زیرا ...
فقط یکی اوم اوه یکی
فکر کنم برای هر ردیف، یک فریم باشه
ستون، بنابراین به طور پیش‌فرض اینطور است
قسمت اول را می‌گیرم و حذف می‌کنم
حالا بقیه‌اش را چطور تعریف می‌کنید؟
انیمیشن، خب، شما می‌توانید انیمیشن‌ها را داشته باشید
ملک و سپس در اینجا شما انتخاب می کنید
نام، بنابراین در اینجا من فقط می‌خواهم این کار را انجام دهم.
انیمیشن دویدن، من قراره صداش کنم
اجرا می‌شود و شیء دیگری است و سپس
شما دو کلید جلویی را مشخص می‌کنید که
فریم اولیه‌ای است که قرار است باشد
فریم صفر تا آخرین فریم که
شاخص فریم ۸ خواهد بود زیرا در cap
بازی ام
باشه یه لحظه صبر کن چرا هایلایت شده؟
از این طرف از دو تا باشه پس یکی یه چیزی
نکته‌ای که لازم است به آن اشاره کنم این است که در اینجا
فریم‌ها محاسبه می‌شوند و تعدادی دارند
یک برگه اسپرایت که همیشه با
صفر است، بنابراین با اندیس صفر نمایش داده می‌شود، بنابراین در اینجا از ۰ تا ۸ است
در واقع نه فریم است، بنابراین حالا من چه هستم
حالا که این را دارید، قرار است چه کار کنید؟
شما می‌توانید در کامپوننت Sprite این کار را انجام دهید.
یک پارامتر دوم و مشخص کردن یک انیمیشن
و شما از نام انیمیشن Run استفاده می‌کنید و
سپس می‌توانید اینجا را ببینید، اکنون اینجا توسط
به طور پیش فرض، انیمیشن فقط پخش خواهد شد
یک بار و سپس توقف، می‌توانید از سرعت استفاده کنید
ویژگی، اه، نه سرعت، ببخشید، حلقه
خاصیتی که اگر فقط یک بار اجرا شود، تعریف می‌شود
یا بی‌نهایت حلقه می‌زند، بنابراین حالا حلقه می‌شود
و
بالاخره الان یه مشکلی پیش اومده
انیمیشنش که خوب به نظر نمیاد
خب، کاری که من قراره اینجا انجام بدم اینه که من
من این کار را خواهم کرد، نظر خواهم داد
من قصد دارم در مورد آن نظر بدهم
به عنوان
خب پس ما
پریدن داشته باشید
فرود آمدن، پریدن و بعد همینطوری
این یک انیمیشن عجیب است که من نمی‌بینم
آغاز و پایان کجاست
خب، آیا این تنها انیمیشنی است که من ساخته‌ام؟
فکر کن
اشکالی نداره، انیمیشن خوبه، مهم نیست
این فقط یه دایناسوره که
پرش و
بعدش دوباره بپرم، به هر حال حدس می‌زنم، پس من هستم
آن را سر جایش خواهد گذاشت و
سپس من آن را حلقه می زنم اما این انیمیشن
به وضوح به نظر نمی‌رسد که برای این طراحی شده باشد
حلقه زده شود اما به هر حال شما همچنین می‌توانید
نرخ فریم را اینجا افزایش می‌دهم
برای داشتن سرعت 10 اهم 10 و سپس برای
مثلاً هر چه بالاتر بروید مثلاً 60
خیلی سریعه، سه فریم در ثانیه
دوم خیلی کند و غیره پس آره، پس حسش کن
رایگان برای پیکربندی آن به دلخواه شما
اینگونه است که Sprite ها را در KL بارگذاری می کنید
شما دارایی‌ها را به طور کلی در آنجا بارگذاری می‌کنید
روش‌های دیگری برای بارگذاری دارایی‌ها وجود دارد، بنابراین برای
فونت‌ها اگر به مثال فونت بروم این است
یک متن وجود دارد
شاید بتوانید ببینید که می‌توانید یک
فونت را با وارد کردن کلیدی که می‌خواهید
استفاده کنید و سپس مسیر آن را مشخص کنید و تمام
و سپس دو نوع فونت وجود دارد
فونت بیت مپ هم وجود دارد که
می‌توانید تصویری از آن را بارگذاری کنید
کاراکترها و سپس شما مشخص می‌کنید
عرض و ارتفاع هر یک از آنها
شخصیت‌ها، بنابراین این‌ها گزینه‌های شما هستند
وقتی صحبت از فونت‌ها می‌شود، بنابراین به جز
برای تصاویر و غیره تصاویر و
متن و همچنین فایل صوتی وجود دارد که شما
می‌خواهید یاد بگیرید که چگونه می‌توانید بارگذاری کنید، می‌توانید از آن استفاده کنید
روش صدای بار و سپس در اینجا
همان ساختار، نامی که می‌خواهید
برای استفاده از کلید و سپس مسیر به سمت
صدا
خودش و سپس شما همچنین می‌توانید اینجا باشید که
برای بارگیری، برای بازی کردن اگرچه شما اد به
از نمایشنامه استفاده کنید
تابع C playay این شما را اجرا می‌کند
نباید این را با نمایشنامه اشتباه گرفت
روش را بعداً بررسی خواهم کرد
پخش انیمیشن، بنابراین یک چیز من
باید در نشان داده می‌شد
مثال اسپرایت این است که می‌توانید مشخص کنید
انیمیشن به طور پیش فرض در ...
پارامتر دوم کامپوننت Sprite
اما می‌توانید یک متد play را نیز فراخوانی کنید
هدف بازی شما، بنابراین شاید بعداً من باشم
قصد دارم یک مثال برای بازی نشان دهم
صدایی که در نام کلید قرار می‌دهید
و سپس به عنوان پم دوم، شما ...
گزینه‌هایی که می‌توانید به صورت اختیاری از آنها عبور کنید
شما می‌توانید تصمیم بگیرید که هر چیزی را در حلقه قرار دهید یا اگر
متوقف شده و حتی حجمی که می‌توانید
میزان صدا را تنظیم کنید یا می‌توانید آن را تنظیم کنید
حجم جهانی با استفاده از روش حجم
در K خیلی خوب بازی کن، پس حالا بیا نگاه کنیم
در بعضی موارد، بیایید کد خودمان را بنویسیم، بنابراین من هستم
فقط می‌خواهم کوتاه‌ترین مثال را بزنم
اینجا ممکن است و فقط همه چیز را دوباره انجام دهید
بنابراین، بازی کنید و سپس
جهانی جهانی
همه نادرست
خب، حالا یه چیز دیگه که می‌خوام
صحبت در مورد این است که صحنه‌ها در K چگونه کار می‌کنند
playay، حالا می‌دانید که چگونه فونت‌ها را بارگذاری کنید
حالا وقتشه که ببینیم چطور میشه
صحنه‌ها را مدیریت کنید تا به طور پیش‌فرض آنچه می‌بینید
روی بوم، صحنه پیش‌فرض است
با این حال می‌توانید صحنه‌های خاصی را مشخص کنید
بنابراین، روشی که شما این کار را انجام می‌دهید با استفاده از
متد scene در Klay به عنوان
اولین پارامتر نامی است که می‌خواهید استفاده کنید
این الگویی است که اغلب می‌بینید
کجا برای بسیاری از چیزهایی مثل
بارگذاری اسپرایت بارگذاری فونت بارگذاری فونت بیت‌مت
بارگذاری صدا و غیره، شما اولین پارامتر را دارید
که همیشه نامی است که می‌خواهید استفاده کنید
برای آن چیز خاصی که خلق می‌کنید
و سپس پارامتر دوم مسیر است اما
برای اینجا، برای خلق یک صحنه
پارامتر اول نامی است که می‌خواهید استفاده کنید
بیایید آن را صحنه آزمایش بنامیم و سپس
پارامتر دوم یک تابع خواهد بود
اینجا ترجیحاً از پیکان استفاده شود
عملکرد به دلیل جمع و جورتر بودن و
کد درون آن تابع در اینجا آمده است
منطق آن صحنه خواهد بود، بنابراین
یه چیزی هست که می‌خوام نشون بدم، اوه
ویترین این است که در K playay وجود دارد
اسپرایت‌های پیش‌فرضی که می‌توانید استفاده کنید و یکی از
فکر می‌کنم این تنها مورد موجود است
با فراخوانی تابع بارگذاری Bean می‌توان به آن دسترسی پیدا کرد.
روش و سپس شما به اجازه دسترسی دارید
من اینجا یک شیء بازی ایجاد می‌کنم. (k)
اسپرایت اولین کامپوننت من را اضافه می‌کند
اینجا و بعد اینجا من قراره تماس بگیرم
آن
ام بین به طور پیش فرض وقتی از آن استفاده می کنید
نام متد Bean به صورت زیر خواهد بود:
بین، پس حالا اگه اینو رفرش کنم دیگه نیستیم
در آن صحنه هنوز به همین دلیل است که هیچ چیز
اینجا در صفحه Klay ظاهر می‌شود
اوه، من هم قراره یه مقداردهنده اولیه بسازم
مقیاس چهار برابر است، بنابراین همه چیز
به وضوح قابل مشاهده است و سپس برای رفتن به اینجا
صحنه خاصی که شما K.O انجام می‌دهید و سپس
نام صحنه و اینجا می‌توانید ببینید
شخصیت لوبیا، بنابراین حالا اگر اضافه کنید
صحنه دیگری ک.
صحنه ام، پس دو تا رو امتحان کن و بعدش می‌تونی
یکی دیگه اینجا داشته باشم و بعدش اینجا بتونم
استفاده از
متد uh را اضافه کنید و سپس این بار اضافه کنید
اطراف یک کامپوننت متنی و hello
دنیا، پس الان اینجا به جای رفتن به
تست دو، من قصد دارم برای تست یک بروم، بنابراین
کاری که می‌توانید انجام دهید برای مثال این است که ما
ابتدا به صحنه آزمایش بروید و سپس ما توسط
با استفاده از متد wait در KL می‌توانیم
فقط ۳ ثانیه صبر کنید و سپس به تماس بروید
تابع زیر
K.O با تست دو، بنابراین حالا اگر تست بگذارم
اینجا تازه کردن، پس یک، دو و سه
ثانیه و سپس به دیگری می‌رود
صحنه، بنابراین در اینجا نحوه آن آمده است
کار می‌کند، بنابراین صحنه‌ها به این شکل کار می‌کنند
حالا بیایید ببینیم که اشیاء بازی چگونه هستند.
من در Klay کار می‌کنم، بنابراین اشیاء بازی هستند.
مفهوم اصلی Klay را اینگونه بیان کنید
همه چیز یک شیء بازی است، یک شیء بازی
همانطور که قبلاً اشاره کردم، توسط ... ایجاد می‌شود.
با استفاده از تابع تبلیغ، متد تبلیغ، و
معمولاً روشی که شما انجام می‌دهید به عنوان مثال
من یک بازیکن، یک شیء بازی و ... ایجاد می‌کنم.
از k استفاده کنید. اضافه کنید و سپس یک مورد را می گیرد
آرایه‌ای از کامپوننت‌ها که قرار است
تعیین رفتارهای مختلف و
ویژگی‌های آن شیء بازی و آن دسته از ویژگی‌هایی که
اجزایی که بعداً خواهیم دید
من قصد دارم در مورد رشته اصلی صحبت کنم
اجزایی که به آنها نیاز خواهید داشت
وقتی دارید یک بازی می‌سازید، تعداد زیادی از آنها وجود دارد
از آنها اما من قصد دارم در مورد یک ... صحبت کنم
زیرمجموعه بسیار خاصی است، بنابراین در اینجا از آن استفاده می‌کنید
تابع ad را اجرا کرده و آرایه‌ای از موارد زیر را به آن ارسال می‌کنیم:
اجزا و سپس به عنوان مثال من اینجا هستم
قراره یه بازیکن به این روش بسازن
اجزایی که معمولاً برای آنها استفاده می‌کنم
اولویت با بازیکنان، موقعیت آنهاست
بنابراین من یک موقعیت را روی آن مشخص می‌کنم
بوم، مثلاً ۱۰۰ در ۱۰۰، من معمولاً
من معمولاً این کار را آخر انجام می‌دهم، اما همیشه
ابتدا با Sprite شروع کنید و اگر وجود دارد
اسپرایتی نیست، می‌توانید از مستطیل استفاده کنید
مؤلفه‌ای که قرار است به
یک مستطیل رسم کنید که قرار است عمل کند
به عنوان پایه ما، گرافیک‌های جایگزین ما
حدس می‌زنم و بعد اینجا هم می‌توانم از
مؤلفه مساحت که ایجاد می‌کند
به طور خودکار یک هیت باکس برای بازیکن ما
می‌توانید بعداً آن را پیکربندی کنید، بنابراین چه زمانی
من قصد دارم در مورد رشته اصلی صحبت کنم
اجزای موجود در K play که قرار است انجام دهم
و سپس اینجا مستطیل و غیره بنابراین
اگر فقط این کار را انجام دهم، می‌توانید ببینید
مستطیلی که اینجا ظاهر می‌شود و اگر شما
F1 را فشار دهید، می‌توانید کادر مربوط به ضربه را اینجا ببینید.
بنابراین اینگونه است که شما یک شیء بازی ایجاد می‌کنید.
به صورت اختیاری، شما گزینه دیگری نیز دارید
به جای اینکه مستقیماً آن را اضافه کنید
‎‏ ...
صحنه‌ای که در آن نمی‌توانید کاری انجام دهید، کاری که می‌توانید انجام دهید
استفاده از تابع make است، پس هر چه می‌خواهد بسازد
آیا شیء بازی را ایجاد می‌کند؟
آن را روی صحنه قرار ندهید، بنابراین باید
بعداً در کد خود یک k انجام دهید. اضافه کردن
خودتان و سپس بازیکن را وارد کنید
مرجع و سپس آن را اضافه خواهد کرد
این در موارد خاصی مفید است که در آن
شما می‌خواهید یک سازنده (Constructor) بسازید.
توابعی که موجودیت را می‌سازند
برای شما و سپس بعداً آن را به آن اضافه کنید
صحنه‌های مختلفی که می‌خواهی، بنابراین ترجیح می‌دهم
هرچند بیشتر اوقات از تبلیغ استفاده کنید و سپس
بعد از ایجاد تبلیغ، بعد از استفاده از
تابع ad آن را ارسال می‌کند و مقدار a را برمی‌گرداند.
ارجاع به شیء بازی که می‌تواند
ذخیره در یک متغیر یا
ثابت و سپس یک چیز که می‌خواهم
ویترین این است که شما نه تنها می‌توانید از آن عبور کنید
فقط کامپوننت‌ها، اما می‌توانید آن‌ها را هم ارسال کنید
اشیایی که می‌توانید برای افزودن موارد سفارشی از آنها استفاده کنید
خواص مربوط به شیء بازی شما، بنابراین توسط
اگر این کار را انجام دهم و فقط به طور پیش فرض انجام دهم
console.log بازیکنی که قرار است به او بدهیم
بتواند شکل آن را ببیند
خب، راستش کجایی؟ کجایی؟
قرار است console.log در آن ظاهر شود
زمین بازی، پس آره، پس شاید دوست داشته باشی اگه
از این کنسول H به جای log استفاده کنید، بنابراین
حالا باید توی کنسول ظاهر بشه، آره
می‌تونی ببینی، پس من اینجا فقط می‌خوام
اندازه فونت را افزایش دهید تا بتوانید
به وضوح ببینید، بنابراین در اینجا یک شیء است و
سپس روش‌های مختلفی دارید
موجود است، بنابراین می‌توانید ببینید که وجود دارد
متد add در پخش‌کننده به این دلیل که شما
می‌تواند کودکان را به اشیاء بازی اضافه کند، بنابراین شما
می‌تواند بازیکن انجام دهد. اضافه کنید و سپس ایجاد کنید
یک شیء بازی دیگر به عنوان یک کودک و سپس
شما کلی ویژگی و چیز دارید
مانند آن که اساساً پیش‌فرض هستند
برای مثال، عرض ارائه شده توسط کی اوه
یا موقعیت صفحه نمایش که می‌توانید
برای مثال به ویژگی موقعیت دسترسی پیدا کنید
اگر من می‌خواهم بدانم چیست؟
موقعیت فعلی بازیکن
من فقط می‌توانم بازیکن باشم. مکث کن و خواهد شد
به نظر می‌رسد می‌توانید اینجا ببینید x 100 y 100 باشه
بنابراین حالا که یک پایه دارید
درک اینکه یک شیء بازی چیست
و چگونه یکی بسازیم، بیایید بیایید
در واقع یک مثال از یک کودک به شما می‌دهم
شیء بازی، بنابراین اگر بخواهم یک
شیء بازی کودک، کاری که قرار است انجام دهم
کاری که من انجام می‌دهم این است که برای مثال،
پخش کننده و دوباره از روش تبلیغ استفاده کنید
این بار متد add از
شیء بازی و نه شیء سراسری
یکی از کلاه اما آنها به یک شکل کار می‌کنند
تا بتوانم یک بازی مستطیلی دیگر بسازم
شیء ۱۰ در ۱۰ با این حال موقعیت برای
به عنوان مثال، اگر من بتوانم منطقه را نیز مشخص کنم
می خواهید و سپس اینجا
موقعیت چه اتفاقی می‌افتد چه چیز خاصی است
در اینجا این است که موقعیت نسبت به
والد، بنابراین اگر من 0 0 انجام دهم، قرار است
به نظر می‌رسد روی والدین به روشی که من هستم
فقط می توانید رنگ را تغییر دهید
این کار را با استفاده از رنگ انجام دهید
کامپوننت و شما می‌توانید از آن استفاده کنید.
مقادیر RGB را مشخص کنید، اما می‌توانید
مقادیر هگزادسیمال را با استفاده از
رنگ از هگز و سپس عبور از آن
کد هگزادسیمال اما اینجا فقط برای نگه داشتن
خیلی ساده‌ست، فقط می‌خوام انجامش بدم ۰ ۰ ۰
پس باید مشکی باشه
و می‌توانید ببینید که روی ... قرار دارد
حالا اگر این را آفست کنم، شیء بازی والد
تا ساعت 10 می‌توانید ببینید که به ... منتقل می‌شود.
سمت 20 و غیره اما نسبت به
والد که بسیار مفید است و بنابراین
مواردی که مثلاً می‌خواهید بیایید
بگو یه بازیکن داری، یه بازیکن داری
با سلاحی که آنها را دور می زند
و آنها را دنبال می‌کند تا تو بتوانی تو را داشته باشی
این را پیاده‌سازی کنید
خیلی خب، حالا وقتشه که
اجزای اصلی را معرفی کنید، بنابراین
کامپوننت اسپرایت کامپوننت اصلی بود.
می‌خواستم در مورد اولی صحبت کنم
در واقع، بیایید بگوییم که من خودم را دارم
بازیکن و بعد من لوبیای خودم را دارم، بنابراین من هستم
فقط می‌خوام لوبیا رو اینجا بار کنم
لوبیا و بعد اینجا من قصد دارم k را انجام دهم.
اضافه کنید و سپس در اینجا من قصد دارم از آن استفاده کنم
همانطور که توضیح دادم، اسپرایت بین اینجا یک
اسپرایت پیش‌فرض در K playay موجود است، بنابراین
به همین دلیل است که من از آن استفاده می‌کنم، بنابراین ندارم
برای جستجوی آنلاین یک برگه Sprite آه
همچنین برگه Sprite که استفاده کرده‌ام وجود دارد
در مثال دایناسور که موجود است
در زمین بازی، بنابراین می‌توانید از آن به عنوان
خب، اینجا من از لوبیای اسپرایت استفاده کردم و
پس خب، در واقع من به یک [چیز/چیزی] نیاز خواهم داشت
انیمیشن در غیر این صورت موفق نخواهد شد
کار کن، بنابراین من فقط این را کپی می‌کنم و
فقط برای اینکه بتونم دوتا داشته باشم، چسبوندش
نمونه‌هایی از زمین بازی که در آن می‌توانم
کد را در اینجا ببینید
اسپرایت فقط به مسیر نیاز دارد
اینجا، پس اگر به اینجا برگردم، قصد دارم
فقط آن را بارگذاری کنید، دارایی‌ها را به درستی بارگذاری کنید، بنابراین
بار
اسپرایت
دیو و
سپس مسیر و
بعدش گفتیم که برش X عدد نه هست،
نه فریم نه فریم ببخشید برش Y چیست؟
یکی به این دلیل که ما برای هر ستون یک فریم داریم
و بعد انیمیشنی که فقط یکی داشتیم
بنابراین انیمیشن ها و سپس اینجا من می خواهم
انیمیشن اجرا (Run) را به این صورت مشخص کنید
تا وقتی که نداری، مجرد داری
کلمه در خواص شما فقط می توانید از شما استفاده کنید
پس لازم نیست از علامت نقل قول استفاده کنید
از صفر ۲ ۸ و سپس بیایید حلقه را حل کنیم
انیمیشن، انیمیشن را همین‌طوری حلقه‌وار تکرار کن
به روشی که احتمالاً چیزی را فراموش کرده‌ام
بگو من فقط از دینو استفاده خواهم کرد
این است اگر من
فقط اونو اینجا بذار تا این قاب بشه
صفر یک ۲ ۳ ۴ ۵ ۶ ۷ و هشت پس میشه
از صفر شروع میشه فقط خواستم نشون بدم
بصری، بنابراین شما متوجه نمی‌شوید
گیج
اوه، باشه، حالا فرض می‌کنیم که ما ...
پخش کننده اسپرایت، اسپرایت، بیایید یک [دستگاه] اضافه کنیم
مساحت آن یک مؤلفه موقعیتی به عنوان
خب، بیایید آن را ۱۰۰ در ۱۰۰ در نظر بگیریم، بنابراین
پارامتر اول مختصات x است
پارامتر دوم مختصات y است، ببخشید
اگر قبلاً به این موضوع اشاره نکرده بودم، پس
اگر F1 را فشار دهم، اسپرایت ما اینجاست.
می‌توانید ببینید که هیت‌باکس کمی تغییر کرده است
بلندتر از خود اسپرایت و این
جایی است که شما نیاز به توییت کردن خواهید داشت
خودت درستش کن
بنابراین بیایید در مورد مؤلفه مساحت صحبت کنیم
و همچنین مؤلفه مساحت که می‌توانید
با وارد کردن یک شیء، شکل آن را تغییر دهید
و سپس مشخص کردن ویژگی شکل
و شما باید از سازنده re استفاده کنید
تا بتونی از جدید استفاده کنی ک. درست است، این از
KL و این قرار است یک مورد را مشخص کند
اولین پم، هیت‌باکس مستطیلی است
قرار است یک بردار دو باشد، بنابراین یکی دیگر
مفهوم عقل سلیم، من باید صحبت کنم
تقریباً اما معمولاً بردار ۲ در K فقط
مقادیر X و Y درست مانند یک داده
ساختاری که مقادیر X و A و Y را در خود نگه می‌دارد
بنابراین در اینجا می‌توانید یک بردار ۲ مانند ایجاد کنید
این کار فقط با فراخوانی کامپوننت انجام می‌شود
خودش و بعد اینجا فقط می‌خواهم
آن را روی 0 0 قرار دهید زیرا این پارامتر اول
مستطیل فقط قرار است
موقعیت نسبت به بازی
شیء من نمی‌خواهم که آن را جابجا کنم. من
فقط می‌خواهم موقعیت یکسان باشد
به همین دلیل است که من اینجا صفر گذاشتم، پس
قراره 0 0 باشه، قرار نیست اینطور باشه
تغییر کن، فرقی نخواهد کرد
از موقعیت اولیه ۱۰۰ در ۱۰۰
شیء بازی، شیء بازی بازیکن
و بعد پم دومی که اینجاست قرار است
باش
الف) عرض و ارتفاع جعبه ساعت
بنابراین عرض به صورت زیر خواهد بود:
بیایید با ۱۶ در ۱۶ شروع کنیم و بعد اگر من
F1 را فشار دهید، می‌بینید که کمی ...
بلندتر، به همین دلیل است که در اینجا می‌توانید
تصمیم بگیرید که این را با ۱۶ جبران کنید و این
قراره بیاد پایین، پس ۱۶ هم زیاده
اتفاقاً در توسعه بازی
هر چه پایین‌تر بروید، ارزش آن بیشتر می‌شود
آره، پس هرچی جلوتر بری
شاید شهودی نباشد اما بله
اینجوری کار می‌کنه، پس اینجاست
ما هیت‌باکس خودمان را داریم که نسبتاً
موقعیت POS خوب است، می‌توانید تصمیم بگیرید
اینکه آیا با شاید کاهش یابد یا نه
به
۱۲ و سپس فشار دهید
ضربه گیر به جلو توسط
دو و یا شاید سه یا چهار، بیایید
بیا شروع کنیم، چهار چهار خیلی زیاده، پس
بیایید با سه شروع کنیم، بنابراین این تغییر
بازی چیزی است که شما باید انجام دهید تا واقعاً
هد باکس خود را تنظیم کرده اید
درست است، خیلی خب، پس شما ... دارید
هیت‌باکس، بازیکن رو داری، باشه
همه چیز خوب است
و حالا فقط برای اینکه بهت نشون بدم که میتونی بازی کنی
انیمیشن‌ها با انجام دادن کار توسط بازیکن انجام می‌شوند
playay و سپس انیمیشن را مشخص کنید
نام شما می‌توانستید این کار را در
پارامتر دوم در اینجا به عنوان پیش‌فرض
انیمیشن اما فقط اگر دارید به شما نشان دهید
چندین انیمیشن که می‌توانید آنها را تغییر دهید
بین آنها با استفاده از این، بنابراین بازی کنید و
سپس نام انیمیشن را وارد کنید تا
انیمیشن قراره یه دایناسور باشه نه نه
این اسپرایت هست، ببخشید، ران
انیمیشن متاسفم و بعد شما دارید
انیمیشن درست پخش میشه، اینجوریه
شما از مؤلفه مساحت و ... استفاده می‌کنید
کامپوننت اسپرایت حالا وجود دارد
جزء بدن و جزء بدن است
قبلاً تصادف وجود داشت، بنابراین در حالی که
کامپوننت area یک hitbox ایجاد می‌کند که
فقط مطمئن شوید که می‌توانید لایک‌ها را بررسی کنید
همپوشانی بین شیء بازی شما و
اشیاء دیگر بازی با استفاده از برخورد سازمان ملل
روش‌ها اما می‌توانید از بدنه استفاده کنید
جزء برای محکم کردن آن یا
تحت تأثیر جاذبه قرار می‌گیریم، بنابراین بیایید از
به عنوان مثال، بیایید یک پلتفرم اضافه کنیم
درست در زیر، بنابراین من قصد دارم یک
بازی
شیء که قرار است زیر آن قرار گیرد
من از یک مستطیل برای پلتفرم استفاده خواهم کرد
من قصد دارم عرض آن را ۱۰۰۰ تنظیم کنم
شاید ۱,۰۰ تا
۵۰ من قصد دارم از مولفه مساحت استفاده کنم
کاملاً مناسب خواهد بود
مستطیل، بنابراین نیازی به مشخص کردن a ندارم
شکل سفارشی برای موقعیتی که من هستم
قرار است آن را به عنوان X روی صفر تنظیم کنیم و
اینجا شاید ۴۰۰ تا باشه، شاید هم همینطور باشه
خیلی زیاد
۱۰۰ ۱۰۰ خیلی خوبه، خیلی زیاده، ۱۵۰ خوبه، پس
ما علاوه بر این، پلتفرم خودمان را نیز اینجا داریم
اگر از کامپوننت مساحت استفاده کنید، می‌توانید
از اه استفاده کنید، بنابراین اگر از مستطیل استفاده می‌کنید
جزء مستقیم و جزء ARA
با هم می‌توانید از طرح کلی استفاده کنید
کامپوننت و سپس یک خط now مشخص کنید
بنابراین با جسارت سه به عنوان مثال
الان خیلی از این جور چیزا هست
در K playay اتفاق می افتد که در آن نمی توانید از آن استفاده کنید
اجزای خاص اگر اجزای دیگر
به آرایه کامپوننت اضافه نمی‌شوند
اینجا، بنابراین شما با خطایی مواجه خواهید شد
پیامی که قرار است به شما بگوید چه چیزی
اشتباه است، بنابراین می‌توانید به راحتی آن را اصلاح کنید، پس همین حالا
اینجا در پخش کننده ما، بنابراین من این کار را نکردم
آن را به یک ثابت اختصاص دهید زیرا من این کار را نمی کنم
بهش نیاز دارم، اوه، این فقط یه چیز دور ریختنیه
شیء بازی پلتفرم
بنابراین بیایید بگوییم که من بدنه را اضافه می‌کنم
بنابراین با اضافه کردن بدنه، کامپوننت
مؤلفه‌ای که تحت تأثیر آن قرار خواهد گرفت
جاذبه اما شما می‌توانید ببینید که هیچ چیز
اتفاق می افتد به این دلیل است که شما باید تنظیم کنید
جاذبه و اتفاقاً در صحنه
مثالی که قبلاً نشان دادم، شما
تمام این منطق را بنویسید نه دارایی را
منطق بارگیری اما برای مثال این منطق
درون صحنه خودش، پس بیایید این کار را انجام دهیم
فقط برای اینکه تمیز باشم، پس من می‌روم
صحنه‌ای را تعریف کن که من آن را بازی می‌نامم
هر طور که دوست داری می‌توانی تعریفش کنی، من
قرار است در این مورد به عنوان قانون دوم تصویب شود
تابع و بعد من اینجام
شامل هر چیزی که داریم خواهد شد
اینجا درون، پس حالا و بعد بالاخره
فراموش نکنید که از آنجا به آن صحنه بروید
زمینه اصلی از ریشه
بنابراین بازی، بنابراین اساساً این هم همین کار را می‌کند
چیزی که من فقط می‌خواستم همه چیز را روشن کنم
بنابراین شاید مجبور شوم این را دوباره فرمت کنم
کد، اوه نه، این همون چیزی بود که اشتباه بود
اینجا ما
خب، حالا برای جاذبه زمین، برو جلو
معمولاً باید آن را تنظیم کنید، من نمی‌توانم آن را تنظیم کنم
چیزهای خاصی وجود دارد که شما
باید از داخل صحنه، تنظیمات را از نو تنظیم کنم
صحنه، بنابراین اگر سعی کنم جاذبه را تنظیم کنم
با استفاده از روش گرانش مجموعه ارائه شده توسط
برای مثال، کلاه بگذارید و تنظیم کنید
۱۰۰۰ تاش واقعاً خوب کار می‌کنه، پس جواب می‌ده.
بنابراین می‌توانید گرانش را خارج از آن تنظیم کنید
صحنه خیلی خوبه، پس اگه تو
می‌خواهم یک جاذبه جهانی داشته باشم که در آن باشد
این همه سطوح را می توانید یک بار انجام دهید و
سپس کد خود را تعریف کنید، بنابراین معمولاً این
عملکردی که اگر بخواهید ممکن است به آن نیاز داشته باشید
برای سازماندهی کد خود بعداً باید
یک فایل جداگانه SE ایجاد کنید و سپس
آن تابع را وارد کنید و سپس آن را ارسال کنید
در اینجا به عنوان مثال به عنوان پارامتر دوم، بنابراین
حالا می‌توانید ببینید که بازیکن ما فقط
از سکویی که
زیرا ما باید بدنه را نیز اضافه کنیم
با این حال، جزئی از خود پلتفرم است
اینجاست که «یک مفهوم جدید» به سراغش می‌رود.
این اتفاق می‌افتد که می‌بینید هر دو تحت تأثیر قرار گرفته‌اند
توسط جاذبه اما اگر می خواهید استفاده کنید
پلتفرم‌ها و غیره، شما باید مشخص کنید
پارامتر از درون بدنه body
جزء و در اینجا این پم نامیده می‌شود
استاتیک است و باید آن را تنظیم کنید
درست است، بنابراین در اینجا می‌توانید ببینید که ما
دایناسور روی سکو است، بنابراین
بدنه را به صورت پیش‌فرض تنظیم کنید، فقط بدنه را اضافه کنید
جزء و مشخص کردن یک گرانش
شیء بازی را پویا یا داینامیک کنید
تحت تأثیر جاذبه قرار می‌گیرد، بنابراین سقوط خواهد کرد، اما
می‌توانید گزینه‌ای به نام is را مشخص کنید
استاتیک از درون کامپوننت بدنه
و این تضمین خواهد کرد که
شیء بازی بدون پوشش باقی خواهد ماند
توسط جاذبه و به عنوان یک عمل خواهد کرد
اساساً دیوار یا سکویی در آن
خب، قضیه همینه، پس همینه و بعدش
بیایید نگاه کنیم، بنابراین من قبلاً صحبت کرده‌ام
در مورد اجزای اصلی مانند رنگ
کامپوننت uh برای تغییر رنگ طرح کلی
مؤلفه‌هایی که به آنها نیز اشاره کردم
کامپوننت مستطیلی کامپوننت متنی
دیدی که من ازش استفاده می‌کنم، آره، بیا شیرجه بزنیم
کمی بیشتر به مؤلفه متن بپردازید
در اینجا مثالی وجود دارد که مانند G استفاده شده است
K playay جهانی، بنابراین بدون داشتن K playay جهانی
غلط و غیره، یه چیزی که می‌خوام بهش اشاره کنم
آیا این بعد از بارگذاری فونت شماست؟
در اینجا کاربرد اساسی آن آمده است، بنابراین من فقط
سعی می‌کنم فقط بگیرم، فقط می‌گیرم
این نسخه
این یک مثال جدید ایجاد می‌کند که باید داشته باشم
من این کار را نکرده‌ام، در واقع
فهمیدم میشه برگردم نه نمیتونم باشه
برگردیم به بازنویسی نوشته‌هایمان
به عنوان مثال، به جای استفاده از K، از K استفاده کنید.
نوع دومی که داشتم را باز گذاشتم تا فقط انتخاب کنم
چیزهایی که نیاز داشتم را از دست دادم
پیشرفت، پس اینجا
جهانی نادرست
و بعد اینجا فقط قراره پیست کنم
بیانیه ای که اینجا داشتم، فقط دارم میرم
برای اضافه کردن K به جلوی آن، بنابراین من قصد دارم
فونت طرح گل را بارگذاری کنید
طرح‌ها ttf این مسیر کامل است
و بعد اینجا فقط برای اینکه به شما نشان دهم چگونه
از آن استفاده کنید، من قصد دارم یک شیء بازی ایجاد کنم
و از کامپوننت متنی استفاده کنید، بنابراین نیاز دارید
برای ایجاد یک شیء بازی که بتواند
از مؤلفه متنی استفاده کنید که نمی‌توانید فقط
با ک تماس بگیرید. پیامک بده، من این کار رو نمی‌کنم چون تو لازم داری
همچنین موقعیت آن متن را مشخص کنید
برای مثال، اگر این کار را نکنید، به طور پیش‌فرض
مشخص کنید که در بالا قرار خواهد گرفت
گوشه سمت چپ اما اینجا بیایید آن را در
مرکز این است که چگونه می‌توان با آن کار کرد
قطعه مرکزی یه چیز جدید اینجاست
فعلاً تعریف نشده است زیرا هیچ چیز
مثل اینکه ما اینجا متنی را مشخص نکرده‌ایم، بنابراین
در اینجا محتوای خود را مشخص می‌کنید
به عنوان اولین پم که فقط می خواهم به آن پیامک بدهم
اصلاح کردن
اوه، این را اصلاح کن تا واضح باشد
فکر کنم بیشتر شبیه خوشگله، قابل دیدنه، اوه
معمولاً ویرایشگر کد من این کار را انجام می‌دهد
این کار را انجام می‌دهم اما از آنجایی که من این را آموزش می‌دهم
کل مسیر فشرده در زمین بازی، بنابراین
من باید این کار را به صورت دستی انجام دهم، بنابراین بیایید اینجا را ببینیم
به عنوان متن پیش‌فرض، عبارت hello world را تایپ کنید.
اگر این کار را انجام دهم، می‌توانید ببینید که
سلام ما در مرکز اما شما می‌توانید
ببینید که منشأ متن است
در گوشه بالا سمت چپ قرار خواهد گرفت
اشیاء بازی پیش‌فرض منشأ خود را دارند
در گوشه بالا سمت چپ اگر بخواهید چه؟
مبدأ در مرکز باشد به طوری که
جایگاه کلمه hello در واقع این است
متن در مرکز قرار خواهد گرفت
برای اینکه در مرکز قرار بگیرید، اینجا جایی است که لنگر قرار دارد
مؤلفه قرار است وارد عمل شود، بنابراین
اینجا باید از لنگر استفاده کنید
کامپوننتی که باید یک ناحیه را مشخص کنید
کامپوننت از قبل، بنابراین به طور پیش‌فرض در اینجا
فقط باعث میشه یه هیت باکس دور و برمون درست بشه
متن ما و سپس درست در زیر می‌توانید
در واقع منظور از
اجزایی که آنها را در آرایه قرار می‌دهید عبارتند از
مهم نیست، می‌توانید آنها را در هر جایی قرار دهید
سفارش دهید، فقط این است که معمولاً ترجیح می‌دهم
همانطور که می‌دانید من از کامپوننت متن استفاده می‌کنم
کامپوننت آرایه‌ای که معمولاً قرار می‌دهم
آنها را به ترتیب استفاده اما شما
آزاد هستید که آنها را هر طور که می‌خواهید جابجا کنید
خب، حالا چیزی که می‌خواستم
آیا منطقه ما مشکلی ندارد؟
حالا می‌توانم کامپوننت لنگر را فراخوانی کنم و
سپس می‌توانید لنگر بودن را مشخص کنید
ارسال شده
و به این ترتیب مبدا خواهد بود
در مرکز، حالا متن ما در مرکز قرار گرفته است
می‌تونی بالا چپ بالا راست داشته باشی اما
همچنین می‌توان از بردار دو استفاده کرد، بنابراین با فراخوانی
بردار دو، شما می‌توانید یک مورد خاص را مشخص کنید
موقعیت، اوه، شاید اون شاید یه موقعیت قدیمی بود
رفتار، فکر نمی‌کنم دلیلش این باشه
اینجا کار می‌کنه پس فراموشش کن اما شروع می‌کنیم
پس سلام دنیا
و غیره، حالا که سلام دنیا رو داریم، اه
کاری که می‌خواستم انجام دهم این است که به شما نشان دهم چگونه
برای تغییر، فونت را تغییر دهید تا بتوانید انجام دهید
همانطور که در مثال دیدیم، پیش‌فرض دارند
فونت اینجا هست اما من ترجیح نمی‌دهم این کار را انجام دهم
ترجیح می‌دهم فونت را برای هر متن تغییر دهم
بنابراین، در اینجا به عنوان پارامتر دوم، کامپوننت
می‌توانید یک شیء را ارسال کنید و سپس مشخص کنید
نام فونت با ارسال هر یک از فونت‌ها
ویژگی و قرار دادن دقیقاً همان کلید
ما از این کلید برای بارگذاری اسپرد خود استفاده می‌کنیم، بنابراین
این فونته، اوه، خیلی گلداره
فونتی که به شما می‌دهم را می‌توانید افزایش دهید
اندازه فونت توسط
فکر می‌کنم با اضافه کردن این اندازه‌ها
شاید ۳۲
۶۴ آره، همینه
۹۶ سلام دنیا، پس این فونت همه چیز است
درست است، شاید پس‌زمینه به طور پیش‌فرض
شما می‌توانید پس‌زمینه را به این شکل تنظیم کنید
سیاه، بیا بریم، تو می‌تونی این کار رو بکنی اما
معمولاً ترجیح می‌دهم یک شیء بازی بسازم
که کل صفحه را می‌گیرد و سپس
فقط رنگ مستطیل را تغییر دهید
مستطیل، بنابراین این شیء بازی مستطیلی است
تمام صفحه را خواهد گرفت
زیرا اگر از پس‌زمینه‌ی تنظیم‌شده استفاده کنید
روش ارائه شده توسط KL قرار است به ام
همه چیز را رنگ کنید و اگر از آن استفاده می‌کنید
صندوق پستی پادشاه، من قبلاً به تو اشاره کردم
دیگر میله‌های سیاه نخواهند داشت
فقط همین رنگ خواهد بود
حتی با این وجود، خیلی هم به نظر خواهد رسید
عجیبه که شخصیت اسپرایت شما کجاست؟
مثال به خارج از صفحه نمایش حرکت خواهد کرد اما ...
به نظر خواهد رسید که انگار
پس‌زمینه یکسان است، بنابراین صفحه نمایش
باید ادامه پیدا کند اما اینطور نخواهد شد، پس
چرا ترجیح می‌دهم فقط یک مستطیل ایجاد کنم؟
شیء بازی که از یک مستطیل استفاده می‌کند و
اندازه مستطیل، کل آن است
عرض و ارتفاع این
بوم نقاشی، خیلی خب، پس یه چیزی که می‌خوام
همچنین ذکر کنید و من فراموش کردم که این کار را انجام دهم.
قبلاً بهت گفتم که این کار رو نمی‌کنی
لازم نیست فقط اضافه کنید
ام کامپوننت، بنابراین شما فقط نیازی به
اجزای آرایه G را اینجا اضافه کنید
شما همچنین می‌توانید یک شیء اضافه کنید که می‌تواند
ذخیره ویژگی‌های سفارشی مورد نظر شما
طوری تعریف کن که انگار خودت هستی (یا: طوری بهش فکر کن که انگار خودت هستی)
با استفاده از برنامه نویسی شی گرا و شما
خواص مختلف شما را داشت
ویژگی‌هایی که می‌توانید آنها را اینجا تعریف کنید، بنابراین
برای مثال می‌توانید HP یا
اسم شما و غیره و سپس شما وارد می‌شوید
ارزش‌هایی که می‌خواهید و سپس بعداً روی شما
می‌تواند فقط با دسترسی به آن ویژگی‌ها
ذخیره کردن آن شیء بازی، بنابراین فرض کنید من
فکر کنم قراره تو متنم ذخیره اش کنم
تماس بگیرید، سپس می‌توانید مانند یک ثانیه داشته باشید
متن یا متن دوم و سپس اینجا سلام
جهان
دوباره و سپس
همین پایین، می‌تونم کار خودمو بکنم
متن و سپس دسترسی به متن فعلی توسط
انجام دادن. متن
و سپس آن را با متن جدید جایگزین کنید
با یک پیامک دوم و می‌توانم به آن دسترسی داشته باشم
با استفاده از متن من و سپس نام
خاصیتی که اینجا تعریف کرده‌ام، بنابراین
متن دوم این است
هست و شما می‌توانید دوباره سلام دنیا را ببینید
این خیلی قدرتمنده چون این
به شما امکان می‌دهد تا نیاز به استفاده از آن را نادیده بگیرید
کلاس‌ها و در حالی که هنوز کدی داریم که
به نظر می‌رسد
ظاهر تمیز، قابل فهم و آسان است
برای خواندن و اصلاح
بسیار خوب، بنابراین یک نکته که می‌خواهم به آن اشاره کنم
دوباره این است که اینجا مرکز است
مؤلفه‌ای که می‌توانید از آن برای داشتن آن استفاده کنید
مرکز بوم، اوه، موقعیت
کامپوننت یا دو مقدار می‌گیرد، مانند
که یا یک بردار دو می‌گیرد، بنابراین بردار ۲
چیزی است که زیاد پیش می‌آید، بنابراین اینجا
شما می‌توانید همین کار را ۱۰۰ در ۱۰۰ ام انجام دهید، بنابراین
این ساختار داده است، آه، هیچ چیز دیگری وجود ندارد
دلیلی برای انجام این کار به این روش به جای فقط
۱۰۰ از ۱۰۰ به ۱۰۰ عبور می‌کند، پس باید این کار را بکنی
آن وقتی که
چه زمانی هر زمان
ممکنه، باشه، پس آره، اما ک. مرکز
اگر به مقدار برگشتی نگاه کنید، شاید
نه در این ویرایشگری که خواهید دید
یک بردار به همه برمی‌گرداند
خیلی خب، حالا می‌خوام در موردش صحبت کنم
برچسب‌ها نیز همینطور هستند، بنابراین این اتفاق خواهد افتاد
در تشخیص برخورد مفید است، بنابراین من هستم
بعداً در مورد این کامپوننت صحبت خواهیم کرد
بنابراین، نکته بعدی که می‌خواهم بگویم این است.
آموزش، نحوه‌ی ساخت بازی است.
اشیاء، چگونه آنها را به دست آوریم، چگونه دوست داشته باشیم
اساساً از آنها پرس و جو کنید، بنابراین بیایید بگوییم من
یک دسته بازی ایجاد کنید
اشیاء در واقع برچسب ها قرار است به
همین الان به کار میاد، پس بذار بگم
من اشیاء بازی را ایجاد می‌کنم، فرض کنید من ایجاد می‌کنم
سه بازی
اشیاء، آنها فعلاً خالی هستند و ...
بیایید بگوییم که همه آنها مستطیل‌هایی با ابعاد 10x هستند
۱۰ تا، پس همه آنها مربع‌های ۱۰ در ۱۰ هستند
بنابراین، شاید قالب‌بندی این باشد:
خوب نیست، می‌دانی، اما اینطور نیست
مهم است و برای هر یک از آنها قصد دارم
به آنها برچسب بزنید تا نه تنها بتوانید اضافه کنید
اشیاء در آن ناحیه از اجزا اما
همچنین می‌توانید رشته‌ای اضافه کنید که در حال انجام است
به عنوان شناسه آن بازی عمل کند
بنابراین فرض کنید من قصد دارم
یک تگ به نام Square ایجاد کنید و من می روم
برای اختصاص دادنش
به تمام اشیاء بازی که من ایجاد کردم
اینجا مربع مربع
مربع، بنابراین ما مربع خود را اینجا داریم
همه در یک موقعیت هستند، خیلی مهم است
کوچک است، بنابراین شاید بهتر باشد بوم را مقیاس‌بندی کنیم
بارها و بارها، بنابراین واضح است
قابل مشاهده است، خیلی کمکی نمی‌کند اما
میدونی، اونقدرا هم مهم نیست؟
شاید خاموش، بیایید جبران کنیم
باشه، من که مشخص نکردم
موقعیت، پس به همین دلیل است که
بیایید کامپوننت موقعیت را اینجا نگه داریم
راستی اگه یه 0 0 می‌خوای، 0 0
موقعیتی که نیازی به مشخص کردن آن ندارید
جزء موقعیتی اما بیایید این کار را انجام دهیم
فقط برای اینکه واضح باشه و بعد بیایم
آن را کپی کنید
اوه، پس بیایید آن را روی ... کپی کنیم.
چیزهای دیگر اینجا می‌رویم و بعد اینجا هستیم
بنابراین بیایید این را با 50 جبران کنیم و
سپس اینجا با ۱۰۰، بنابراین حالا ما داریم
سه مربع اینجا، این جایی است که
برچسب‌ها مفید هستند، این منم، اینم
قصد دارم ذخیره کنم
مربع‌ها و استفاده از متد get ارائه شده
توسط Klay برای درخواست دریافت تمام بازی
اشیایی که برچسب مربع به آنها اضافه شده است
به آنها، بنابراین روشی که این کار را انجام می‌دهید، آن را نیز انجام می‌دهید.
مربعی که در تگ قرار می‌دهید و آن
قرار است یک آرایه برگرداند، بنابراین اگر از k استفاده کنم.
debug.log این روش دیگری برای ثبت وقایع است
چیزها و سپس فقط در میدان عبور کنید
وقتی می‌توانید شیء را ببینید
شیء شیء و شیء شیء که دارید
سه شیء شما، بنابراین k.
debug.log زمانی است که می‌خواهید نمایش دهید
چیزهایی که روی بوم نقاشی می‌کنی
اگر فقط می‌خواهید از console.log استفاده کنید
آن را در کنسول اینجا نمایش دهید تا ما
یک آرایه از سه تا از آنها داشته باشید و هر کدام از آنها
اشیاء ما اکنون آنها را داریم یک نکته ظریف
من اینجا می‌خواهم در مورد متد get صحبت کنم.
اگر یک شیء بازی داشتید که ... باشد چه؟
ظاهراً فرزند یک شیء بازی دیگر است
بنابراین بیایید بگوییم که من اضافه می‌کنم
این اولین شیء بازی است
والد آن بازی دوم
بنابراین اگر به نتیجه نگاه کنم، اعتراض می‌کنم
با فشار دادن F12 می‌توانید ببینید که ما فقط
اگر دو شیء بازی داشته باشید، دیگر سه شیء نخواهید داشت
شما می‌خواهید تمام اشیاء بازی را دریافت کنید
صرف نظر از اینکه آیا وجود دارد یا خیر
فرزندان سایر اشیاء بازی مورد نیاز شما
برای ارسال پارامتر دوم به عنوان یک شیء
شیء و مشخص کردن حالت بازگشتی
اگر این کار را انجام دهید، ویژگی درست بودن چیست؟
اگر F12 را فشار دهم، این اتفاق خواهد افتاد
آرایه خود را با هر سه مورد خود داشته باشید
اشیاء اگر بخواهید استفاده کنید چه اتفاقی می‌افتد
یک جزء پس از واقعیت، پس از داشتن
شیء بازی خود را ایجاد کردید، پس بیایید آن را حذف کنیم
همه از
این و فرض کنید مربع خودمان را داریم
بیایید اینجا به عنوان یک شیء بازی واحد
افزایش ۱۰۰ در ۱۰۰ فقط به همین دلیل است
همه چیز CLE است
قابل مشاهده است و من پس از ایجاد
شیء بازی را بعداً در پایگاه کد خود قرار می‌دهم
می‌خواهید به صورت پویا یک کامپوننت جدید اضافه کنید
فرض کنید می‌خواهم رنگش را تغییر دهم
بعد از این اتفاق، مثلاً اگر بازیکن
روی آن کلیک کنید، من هستم، بعداً به آن خواهیم پرداخت
ببینید چگونه ورودی را در جایی که هستیم مدیریت کنیم
قراره ببینم چطور میشه چیزهایی رو درست کرد
مثل کلیک کردن، کلیک کردن، حرکت کردن
فشار دادن کلیدها و غیره اما فعلاً اگر شما
مربع خود را اینجا داشته باشید و می‌توانید از آن استفاده کنید
از تابع uh برای اضافه کردن یک متد استفاده کنید.
کامپوننت جدید، بنابراین در اینجا می‌خواهم اضافه کنم
ک. مولفه رنگی که به آن نگاه کردیم
اوه، قبلاً و من قصد دارم آن را در
یک رنگ RGB از دو قرمز، بنابراین این باید باشد
قرمز، بنابراین اکنون از آن کامپوننت استفاده خواهد کرد
جزء بعد از این واقعیت نیز وجود دارد
مربع. استفاده نکنید و سپس می‌توانید عبور کنید
به نام رنگ
مؤلفه‌ای که استفاده می‌کنید و قرار است
از آن کامپوننت استفاده نکنید، بنابراین فرض کنید من هستم
قصد استفاده از
وزن چیزی ارائه شده توسط کابوم
به جای استفاده از set timer set
به هر حال اسم را فراموش کرده‌اند، آنها پیشنهادهای ویژه می‌دهند
تایمرهای خودشان را دارند، بنابراین می‌توانید از آنها استفاده کنید
این مثل آن است، پس چه اتفاقی خواهد افتاد؟
قبل از لغو استفاده، ۳ ثانیه صبر می‌کنیم
مولفه رنگ و این یعنی
مستطیل به حالت اولیه خود باز خواهد گشت
شکل اینجا ما
خیلی خوب پیش برو، بنابراین اولین پارامتر ... است.
تعداد ثانیه‌هایی که باید منتظر ماند و سپس
پارامتر دوم این است
تابعی که پس از اتمام تایمر اجرا می‌شود
و همچنین یک شکل غیرهمزمان از آن وجود دارد
آن تابعی که در آن از await استفاده می‌کنید و
پس فقط کافیه یه پارامین داشته باشی
سپس شما این را آنها در زیر می نامید
بنابراین من قصد ندارم از این موضوع عبور کنم، شما می‌توانید
در ضمن، همه آموزش‌های من را ببینید
آموزش‌های Kaboom برای Kay قابل اجرا هستند.
بنابراین می‌توانید آنها را دنبال کنید، فقط این کار را انجام دهید
تنظیمات اولیه را به طور متفاوتی انجام دهید
همین الان به جای KaBoom، K play را نصب کنید
بیایید نگاهی به نحوه مدیریت برخوردها بیندازیم
بنابراین
شما می‌دانید که چگونه برخوردها را مدیریت کنید، بیایید اممم
راهی که من قراره انجامش بدم اینه که میرم
همچنین کامپوننت move را معرفی کنیم
که کاری است که من انجام ندادم، پس بیایید
بیایید به آن بپردازیم، بنابراین فرض کنیم که ما
هنوز مربع R داریم، بیایید آن را کاهش دهیم
اندازه تا ۵۰ اینچ
۵۰ و حالا این مربعی که قراره استفاده کنم
اوه، حذفش کن که دیگه لازم نیست و
من قصد دارم کامپوننت مساحت را به آن اضافه کنم
بنابراین، قرار است یک پیش‌فرض داشته باشد
به یاد داشته باشید که می‌توانید به hitbox دسترسی داشته باشید
با فشار دادن دکمه، به حالت اشکال‌زدایی بروید.
کلید F1 فکر می‌کنم حالت اشکال‌زدایی یکی از موارد زیر باشد
قدرتمندترین و مفیدترین چیزی که
پیشنهادهای K play که در سایت‌های دیگر نمی‌بینم
کتابخانه‌های لی برای ساخت بازی‌هایی که بلد نیستید
به نظر من، یک حالت اشکال‌زدایی مفید است.
پس حالا که این و آن را داریم، بیایید
منطق خود را بنویسیم، پس چه کار خواهیم کرد؟
آیا این است که ما قصد داریم یک ثانیه ایجاد کنیم؟
شیء بازی که من آن را می‌نامم
هدف قرار خواهد گرفت و کوچک خواهد بود
مستطیل 20x 20 و ما قصد داریم
آن را قرار دهید، بنابراین من هم مشخص خواهم کرد
‎‏ ...
منطقه و من همچنین قصد دارم آن را در یک
موقعیت 30 در کنار صفر، بنابراین شاید 30 نباشد
شاید بیشتر از آن ۱۳۰ تا باشد، پس ما
دومین میدان ما را داشته باشید
خب، بله، حالا که اینو داریم، چی؟
قراره انجام بدم.
اولین منطق برخورد را می‌نویسیم، بنابراین
چگونه تشخیص برخورد را در cap انجام می‌دهید؟
playay روش‌های زیادی وجود دارد که می‌توانید
استفاده کنید اما مهمترین مورد این است
روش بدون برخورد و انتهای بدون برخورد
روشی که انتهای بدون برخورد، یک روش است
که به شیء بازی متصل است، بنابراین
بیایید بگوییم که می‌خواهم بررسی کنم که آیا هدف
برخورد کرده است، بنابراین شما در برخورد این کار را انجام می‌دهید
با و سپس پارامتر دوم، پارامتر اول را
پارامتر آن تابع، تگِ
شیء بازی، اوه، از شیء بازی که شما دارید
می‌خواهم برخوردها را بررسی کنم، بنابراین اینجا
هدف در برخورد با برچسب مربع است، بنابراین
می‌بینید که فقط به یک برچسب برای ... نیاز دارید.
دومین شیء بازی که می‌خواهید بررسی کنید
برخورد با و سپس دوم
param تابعی خواهد بود که
قرار است هنگام برخورد اجرا شود
اینجا اتفاق می‌افتد، من فقط می‌خواهم لاگ را دیباگ کنم
اوه، تصادف پیامی را نشان داد که
می‌گوید
که بنابراین در اینجا هیچ اتفاقی نمی‌افتد زیرا
مربع حرکت نمی‌کند و ما باید حرکت کنیم
بنابراین راه حرکت دادن یک
مربع این است که می‌توانید از کامپوننت move استفاده کنید.
بنابراین شاید یک مثال داشته باشم
وقتی قرار است از تشخیص ورودی استفاده کنیم
بنابراین من قصد دارم در مورد نحوه برخورد صحبت کنم
منظورم از ورودی، جابجایی اشیا با استفاده از ... است.
کلیدهای جهت نما و و در آن حرکت
کامپوننت واقعاً زیاد استفاده می‌شود، بنابراین شما این کار را انجام می‌دهید
حرکت KLA و این اولین شکل از
و بعد شما می‌توانید حرکت کنید، من واقعاً
یادت نیست
اممممم چی شده؟
[موسیقی]
‎‏ ...
ذره، بیایید امتحان کنیم، بیایید امتحانش کنیم و
پس اگر مشکلی وجود داشته باشد، تا ۱۰۰
صفر شاید این پارامتر دوم باشد
سرعت من
فکر می‌کنم خیلی خب، پس اگه من اینو بذارم
خب، پارامتر دوم سرعت است.
فکر می‌کنم اولین پم از نظر SEC یک بردار است
۲ و بیایید بگوییم بله، پس اینجا وکتور ۲ است
مفید واقع می‌شود، بنابراین اولین پارامترِ
مولفه حرکت در اینجا جهت در است
که شما می‌خواهید برخورد به آن منجر شود، آه
شیء بازی که باید به سمت آن حرکت کرد
به سمت و سپس رام دوم است
سرعت، بنابراین در اینجا با سرعت 10 می‌توانستم
آن را به ۵۰ افزایش دهید و سپس می‌توانید ببینید
وقتی برخورد می‌کند، پیام را می‌بینید
برخورد در پایین اتفاق می‌افتد
صفحه نمایش، پس آره، اوه، دلیلش اینه که
همپوشانی به این دلیل است که ما Haven برای استفاده داریم
اجزای بدن، بنابراین اگر قرار بود از آنها استفاده کنیم
جزء بدن برای هر دوی آنها بنابراین
فرض کنید کامپوننت بدنه را اضافه می‌کنم
اینجا و من همچنین کامپوننت بدنه را اضافه می‌کنم
به سوی هدف
آنها همدیگر را هل خواهند داد، هل خواهند داد
فکر کنم بله، می‌تونی ببینی
خیلی خب، پس شکل دیگه‌ی ...
در مورد برخورد (Collide) می‌توانید از آن استفاده کنید.
مستقیماً از درپوش یخ بزنید اما باید
برچسب اولین شیء بازی را مشخص کنید
می‌خواهید برخوردها را با و سپس بررسی کنید
دومی هم قبل از اینکه وارد شود
تابعی که من به ندرت از این فرم استفاده می‌کنم
چون اغلب فقط بیشتر است
راحت و آسان برای استفاده از آن، بنابراین
بفرمایید، پس اون یکی هم روی تارگت هست
برخورد
پایان می‌یابد و زمانی اجرا خواهد شد که برخورد رخ دهد
به پایان می‌رسد و می‌تواند وقتی که می‌خواهید مفید باشد
برای مثال، برای اتمام یک حمله
مثلاً آره، اوه، این برای ... مفیده
مثلاً وقتی می‌خواهید یک کار را تمام کنید
حمله، بازیکن شما حمله را تمام می‌کند
و بعد اوه، چطور می‌گی سر جایش بگذارم؟
شمشیرهایشان یا چیزی شبیه به آن، پس من اینجام
من فقط می‌خواهم یک گزارش اشکال‌زدایی قرار دهم
پیام هم
برخورد
تمام شد و دیگر هرگز تمام نخواهد شد
به دلیل هل دادن اجسام اتفاق می‌افتد
یکدیگر به خاطر بدن
اجزا اما اگر مثلاً حذف کنم
برای تارگت، من آن را حذف می‌کنم، می‌توانید ببینید
تصادف اتفاق افتاد و سپس تصادف
تایپ کردم، تمام شد
خیلی خب، پس این اوه، این همونه
حالا شما ایده‌ای دارید که چگونه باید رفتار کنید
حالا چطور؟ (یا: چطور؟)
ورودی کاربر را مدیریت کنید تا کلید روشن/خاموش روی کلید
روی دکمه‌ی رهاسازی کلید فشار دهید و حتی می‌توانید
من از کنترلر و غیره پشتیبانی می‌کنم.
قرار نیست به کنترلر شیرجه بزنم
راستی، این آموزش واقعاً پشتیبانی می‌کنه
به عنوان یک نقطه شروع در نظر گرفته شده است اما
بعد از آن می‌توانید بررسی کنید
مستندات و به هر حال اگر
مدارک شما هنوز کامل نیست
هنوز هم می‌تواند به کابوم اصلی اشاره کند
مستندات JS، بنابراین اگر به Kaboom بروم
JS اوه، من نوشتم، دوباره اینجا اشتباه تایپی داشتم.
بنابراین اگر به Kaboom JS بروم، می‌توانید جستجو کنید
و اتفاقاً یک ترفند اینجاست که
جستجو کردن کارآمدتر است، استفاده نکنید
این کار شما آنقدرها هم مؤثر نیست
کنترل F و سپس آنچه را که می خواهید جستجو کنید
به عنوان مثال به دکمه نیاز دارید و سپس خواهید
با استفاده از دکمه‌هایی که اینجا می‌بینید، می‌توانید استفاده کنید
مثل سند، خیلی مهمه
جستجوی جامع‌تر، بهتر است
جستجو از این به دلیل موارد خاص
هنگام استفاده از جستجو، ظاهر نمی‌شوند
اینجا را انتخاب کنید، بنابراین توصیه می‌کنم هنوز از آن استفاده کنید
مستندات Kaboom JS در صورت وجود
چیزی که در نمایش کاپ از قلم افتاده
مستندات زیرا هنوز وجود ندارد
تمام شد اما تقریباً مثل قبل است
چیز، پس آره، پس حالا ببینیم چطور
مدیریت ورودی کاربر، من قصد دارم به این موارد بپردازم
نسخه اولیه آن و اکنون K playay دارد
یک سیستم جدید برای ورودی‌های uh که
به شما امکان می‌دهد دکمه‌ها را برای هر دو مشخص کنید
چندین دکمه مختلف برای
صفحه کلید برای کنترلر و برای
ماوس همه را همزمان استفاده کن، اوه
چون این ویژگی نسخه آلفا است، من آن را خواهم ساخت
در این ویدیو آن را پوشش نمی‌دهم، بنابراین می‌روم
منتظر انتشار بازی کلاه خود باشید
راستی نسخه ۳۰۰۱، روشش هم همینطوره
کار می‌کند این است که در هزاران مورد کار می‌کند، بنابراین
اوه، وقتی کابوم بود، وجود داشت، همینطور بود
کابوم ۲۰۰۰، سپس کابوم ۳۰۰۰ و حالا
فکر کنم نسخه کابوم اینجاست
هنوز هم هست
[موسیقی]
۳.۱.۷ و سپس نوبت به توسعه می‌رسد
نسخه سه 01 فعال است و ...
فعلاً
خیلی خوب ادامه داره، پس حالا بیایید بارگذاری کنیم
لوبیا، اوه، من قصد دارم از آن به عنوان ... استفاده کنم.
دارایی جایگزین و من قصد دارم
ما را ایجاد کنید
بازیکن را انتخاب کنید و شیء بازی را برای آن ایجاد کنید
و سپس در اینجا من از آن به عنوان
لوبیای اسپرایت
حالا اسپرایت می‌کنم، شاید بخوام مقیاسش رو تغییر بدم
دو بار به جای همه، الان اینجام
قرار است پس‌زمینه سیاه را حذف کنیم
فقط برای اینکه چیزها را بهتر کنیم
قابل مشاهده است و سپس من قصد دارم
فکر کنم همینه، اضافه کن
خیلی خیلی فقط
برای مدیریت موقعیت‌ها و بنابراین برای مدیریت ورودی
ترجیحاً باید از
کلید روشن پایین، فشار دادن کلید روشن، رها کردن کلید روشن
روش‌ها مستقیماً از بازیکن دریافت می‌شوند، بنابراین
شیء بازی، بنابراین شیء بازی پیشنهاد می‌دهد
این روش‌ها اما شما همچنین می‌توانید از
نسخه جهانی آن اشیاء بازی اکنون
دلیل اینکه من واقعاً مطمئن نیستم این است
اگر به مستندات مراجعه کنم، یک مورد وجود دارد
راهنما، بنابراین بخش راهنما را در اختیار دارید
اممم، بنابراین نصب مفاهیم اولیه داده‌ها
بین صحنه‌ها و غیره حالت اشکال‌زدایی تا داده‌ها
بین صحنه‌هایی که شاید باید بدی
که یه مطلبی هست که من هنوز بهش نپرداختم، اه، اینه
خیلی ساده است، بنابراین شاید بعداً به آن بپردازم
اما در صورتی که اتصال ورودی را فراموش کنم
فکر می‌کنم این جدیده که چیه؟
ویژگی و غیره و سپس سایه‌زن‌ها که
چیزی که قرار نیست در این مورد پوشش دهم
آموزشه اما درست کردنش خیلی راحته
بازی‌های شما خوب به نظر می‌رسند اما یک چیز من را نگران می‌کند
قرار است در مورد بهینه‌سازی‌ها صحبت کنیم
بنابراین در اینجا آنها توصیه می‌کنند که از این کار اجتناب کنید
نام جهانی خیابان اوه نه، تو کجایی؟
آیا از ورودی محلی شیء بازی استفاده می‌شود؟
اغلب اوقات، هندلرهایی مشابه بالا وجود دارند
بهتر است از کنترل‌کننده‌های ورودی محلی استفاده کنید.
مخالف جهانی‌ها هستم، اوه، یه چیزی
اگرچه این توضیح نمی‌دهد که چرا
چرا بهتر است، فقط به این نکته اشاره شده است
بنابراین احتمالاً دلیلی وجود دارد اما من
نمی‌دانم چرا و اگر تو...
لطفا به مسئول کتابخانه KL اطلاع دهید
چرا، اوه، چرا؟ و من ممکن است این را بپرسم
راستی، دیسکورد هم یه کم زیادیه
برای تبلیغ این دیر شده اما دیسکورد
آیا سرور دیسکورد برای K وجود دارد؟
بازی کن و لینک قراره بیاد
توضیحات و در نظرات من
توصیه می‌کنم به آن بپیوندید زیرا
جایی که می‌توانید سوال بپرسید
سوالاتی که توسط دیگران پرسیده شده است را ببینید
مردم در گذشته و واقعاً همینطور است
اوه، کارآمدترین راه برای دریافت کمک، اوه
من می‌گویم بیایید به مثال خودمان برگردیم
بنابراین اینجا من با بازیکن تماس می‌گیرم. آنکی
پایین و سپس روش Onkey down در K
بازی اشکال مختلفی دارد که دو شکل اصلی آن عبارتند از
به نظر من یا خودت هستی
کلید مورد نظرتان را به عنوان اولین کالسکه مشخص کنید
می‌خواهید گوش دهید یا فقط مشخص کنید
مستقیماً تابعی که در حال انجام است
برای اجرا شدن در زمانی که هر کلیدی پایین است و ...
قرار است از عبور به [بخش] مراقبت کند
اولین پارامتر تابع شما این است
شما به کلید unkey down key منتقل می شوید
این چیزی است که من ترجیح می‌دهم از آن استفاده کنم
بیشتر برای اینکه نکته‌ی خاص را آنجا داشته باشیم
برای داشتنِ چیزِ خاص، برای داشتنِ این
به جای فرم دیگری که در آن هستید،
شما یک کلید خاص را مشخص می‌کنید تا بتوانید
لازم نیست چندین بار با Onkey تماس بگیرید
بارها چنین است، اما ممکن است مواردی وجود داشته باشد
جایی که ترجیح داده می‌شود شاید از
فرم اول، بنابراین در این آموزش من فقط
قرار است از مورد دوم استفاده کنیم، بنابراین اگر در اینجا
برای مثال، اگر کنسول را دیباگ کنید، این کار را انجام می‌دهید
بلاگ ک. اشکال‌زدایی
لاگ کنید و سپس کلیدی که می‌بینید را لاگ کنید.
که وقتی فشار می‌دهم، می‌توانی فضا داشته باشی
پایین چپ راست
و غیره، بنابراین همانطور که گفتم، قصد ندارم در آن مکث کنم
خیلی روی این سیستم ورودی سیستم آه
زیرا یک مورد جدید وجود دارد که ...
گسترش در آن و قرار است
احتمالاً بیشتر برای کارهای حرفه‌ای استفاده می‌شود
بازی‌ها چون شما می‌خواهید بتوانید
چندین ورودی را مشخص کنید چیزها در در
یک بار چندین کلید مختلف و غیره و غیره
کلید پایین و غیره به شما اجازه انجام این کار را نمی‌دهد
که خب، فقط برای یادآوری بهت میگم که فقط
به اتصالات ورودی بروید که این در آن ارائه شده است
جدیدترین نسخه اینجاست، بنابراین شما B را دارید
شما یک عمل را مشخص می‌کنید، سپس شما
می‌تواند کلیدهای مختلفی را برای
صفحه کلید مختلف برای GamePad و
حتی برای ماوس اما همانطور که گفتم اینطور است
هنوز در
توسعه باشه، پس کلید رو پایین بیار، تو داری
کلید اینجاست و من قراره چیکار کنم
آیا قرار است یک اگر ساده داشته باشم؟
اگر کلید برابر باشد، عبارت زیر را اجرا کنید:
حق را بگوییم
کلید، پس من می‌خواهم بازیکنم را بردارم و
قرار است از متد move استفاده کنیم تا بتوانید
نه تنها اونجا، بلکه از روش جابجایی هم استفاده کن
یک جزء حرکتی بود که در آن فقط می‌توانید
حرکت فوری که اتفاق می‌افتد را مشخص کنید
به محض اینکه شیء بازی ایجاد شد
اما می‌توانید از متد move برای
در واقع بازیکن را در یک مسیر مشخص حرکت دهید
جهت اکنون در رابطه با آن
همانطور که گفتم می‌توانید یک شیء را به عنوان ورودی ارسال کنید
آرایه‌ای از کامپوننت برای تعیین مقدار سفارشی
خواص و اینجاست که من دوست دارم
یک ویژگی سرعت ایجاد کنید و a را مشخص کنید
ارزش و سپس در اینجا می‌توانم به آن اشاره کنم.
بازیکن در حال انجام. سرعت و سپس می‌توانید
به عنوان اولین کالسکه، سرعتی را که
قرار است حرکت کند که بازیکن
قصد داریم روی محور x حرکت کنیم و سپس
اوه، صفر روی محور y، چون ما فقط
می‌خواهم به صورت افقی حرکت کنم، بنابراین اگر فشار دهم
شاید کلید جهت‌نمای سمت راست
فهمیدم، اوه، اشتباه کردم
اوه، احتمالاً به این خاطر است که دلم برای خودم تنگ شده است
حرکت بازیکن یک جزء از دست رفته نیست.
تابع، بنابراین این روش فقط
اگر از من استفاده کنید، در دسترس است.
جزء بدن و شما فقط می‌توانید از آن استفاده کنید
اگر از ناحیه استفاده می‌کنید، جزء بدن
کامپوننت بنابراین باید هر دوی آنها را اضافه کنیم
در اینجا این حرکت یک تابع نیست
واقعاً اممم، چیه؟
مشکل امم، بذار اینجا رو رفرش کنم، باشه
یک وجود دارد
این حرکت یک
پخش کننده عملکرد. حرکت کن، باشه، خوبه
باید کاری باشد که من انجام می‌دهم
این قبلاً اشتباه کار می‌کرد، پس آه تو
احتمالاً باید موقعیت را مشخص کنید
همچنین مؤلفه موقعیتی و شما
باید ویرگول‌هایتان را اضافه کنید، پس مراقب باشید
با آن و اگر اینجا فشار دهم، ما به این سمت می‌رویم
اجزای موقعیتی اجباری هستند
حتی اگر قرار نیست مشخص کنید
موقعیت، بنابراین قرار است آن را قرار دهد
در گوشه بالا سمت چپ اما اگر این کار را نکنید
از مؤلفه موقعیتی که نمی‌توانید استفاده کنید
پس از وقوع، موقعیت را اصلاح کنید
زیرا به یاد داشته باشید که به موقعیت دسترسی پیدا کنید
وقتی از مؤلفه موقعیت استفاده می‌کنید،
میتونه از پلیر استفاده کنه مکث کن اما اگر این کار را نکنی
حتی از مؤلفه موقعیتی استفاده نکنید
اگه می‌خوای خوشت بیاد، حتی نرو
خالی است، پس بازیکن. مکث ادامه ندارد
برای کار کردن به این معنی که زیر کاپوت آن است
به شما اجازه داده نخواهد شد که بازیکن را جابجا کنید
بنابراین اینجا من به سمت راست فشار می‌دهم و می‌توانم
حرکت کن، به سمت راست حرکت کن، پس این اه
راستی، خیلی باحاله، من فقط می‌خواستم
برای نمایش پست وبلاگ جدیدی که نوشته‌ام
در مورد چگونگی اصلاح حرکت مورب به داخل
بازی‌های بالا به پایین از بالا به پایین به دلیل دوبعدی بودن
بازی‌های تاپ‌اون اگر با استفاده از a پیاده‌سازی شوند
رویکرد ساده‌لوحانه چیزی که اتفاق می‌افتد این است که
شما به صورت مورب سریع‌تر حرکت خواهید کرد
از هر طرف، بنابراین شما قصد دارید
اگر به صورت مورب سریع‌تر حرکت می‌کردید،
برای مثال، فقط به سمت راست حرکت کردن
اینجا من یک پست بلاک در مورد چگونگی آن نوشته‌ام
اینو درست کن، امم، قرار نیست توش شیرجه بزنم پس
در صورت تمایل لینک زیر مجموعه من را بررسی کنید
همچنین در توضیحات است و امیدوارم
در کامنت پین شده به عنوان
خب، شروع می‌کنیم، پس این روشیه که باید انجام بدید
مثل کلید روشن/خاموش، همین کار را با کلید روشن/خاموش هم می‌توان انجام داد.
مطبوعات واقعاً به همان روش کار می‌کنند، تنها
تفاوت این است که فشار دادن کلید روشن است که
اینطوری نوشته شده که فقط اجرا میشه
یک بار بلافاصله و سپس بله، پس
تو میتونی تو میخوای تو فقط دوست خواهی داشت
لرزشی شبیه به این، بنابراین برای موارد زیر مفید است
حملات و غیره و Y و غیره کلید پایین روی کلید
فشار دهید و همچنین در انتشار کلید وجود دارد، بنابراین
برای مثال اگر می‌خواهید فقط به
سمت راست وقتی کلید راست رها می‌شود
قرار است این کار را انجام دهد، بنابراین عجیب است
رفتارم اما فقط می‌خوام خودمو نشون بدم
شما چگونه از آن ها استفاده کنید
روش‌ها کاملاً درست هستند، پس همین است و
سپس برای انیمیشن‌ها همانطور که به شما نشان دادم
در این مثال شما هیچ کدام را ندارید
اما شما از روش بازی روی خودتان استفاده می‌کنید
بازیکن، بنابراین تصور کنید که لوبیا داشته است
انیمیشن، بنابراین شما بازی می‌کنید و سپس
آن انیمیشن را پخش کنید اما مثلاً شما
یک کنترل‌کننده ورودی دیگر برای آن خواهد داشت
بازیکن مثال در انتشار کلید که برای
مثال، انیمیشن را به عقب برمی‌گرداند
به طور پیش فرض روی انیمیشن پیش فرض تنظیم شده است، بنابراین شما
مثل بازیکن عمل می‌کند. متوقف کردن یا متوقف کردن
انیمیشن را تغییر دهید یا آن را با انیمیشن دیگری عوض کنید
انیمیشن با بازی و در عوض Idol برای
به عنوان مثال، بنابراین اینگونه پیش خواهید رفت
در مورد آن، نکته‌ای که می‌خواهم به آن اشاره کنم
البته عاقلانه است که همیشه بررسی کنید
از قبل مشخص کنید که انیمیشن فعلی چیست
بازی کردن و شما می‌توانید این کار را با داشتن
بازیکن کُرن انیم و قراره بده
شما نام انیمیشن فعلی را انتخاب می‌کنید
و سپس می‌توانید آن را تا زمانی که
با انیمیشنی که شما می‌خواهید برابر نیست
برای اینکه واقعاً همین الان بازی کنید، می‌توانید
دلیل اینکه چرا این کار را انجام می‌دهید، آن انیمیشن را پخش کنید
این به این دلیل است که شما نمی خواهید
وسط پخش یک انیمیشن، آن را قطع کن، پس بیا
انیمیشن بگو آیدل من همین الان داره پخش میشه
و در فریم سه است که شما نمی‌خواهید
انیمیشن را دوباره راه اندازی کنید، نمی خواهم
خیلی خب، پس همینه و اممم بله
حالا من قبلاً نحوه بازی را پوشش داده‌ام
صداها و رفتن به جلو وجود دارد
چند چیز چند چیز پیشرفته تر
ویژگی‌های پیشرفته‌ای که به نظرم باید داشته باشید
بهتر است پروژه من را بر اساس آن تماشا کنید
آموزش‌ها یا فقط به مثال‌ها نگاه کنید
اینجا یکی از آنها بین دو نفر است، اممممم
ویژگی، پس بذار فقط بینشون پیداش کنم
خیلی مفیده، به شما این امکان رو میده که مثل
انتقال‌هایی مثل این، خیلی شبیه
و بعد او از آن دسته‌های مختلف خارج می‌شود
انتقال‌های ترنس خیلی مفید هستند، پس
در اینجا مثالی از نحوه استفاده از آنها آورده شده است
همچنین فشار دادن ماوس و کلیک کردن هم وجود دارد
اوه، هندلرها، یادم رفت به onclick اشاره کنم
فقط مثل این است که کلید را پایین نگه دارید و کلید را فشار دهید
فقط از کلیک استفاده می‌کنی، پس چیز زیادی برای گفتن نیست.
برای مثال اینجا اگر روی
بازیکن، اوه، تو احتمالاً به این منطقه نیاز داری
بیایید بگوییم کامپوننت برای این onclick
داره میره
برای انجام ک. debug.log و بعد فرض کنید
آزمایش کنید تا هر بار که روی آن کلیک می‌کنم
شیء بازی قرار است این کار را انجام دهد، پس
بله، می‌توانید از k سراسری هم استفاده کنید. روی
همچنین کلیک کنید اما همانطور که گفتم به نظر می رسد
برای استفاده از روش‌ها، عملکرد بهتری داشته باشید
ارائه شده توسط خود شیء بازی
خیلی خب، پس برگردیم به تویین
بنابراین در اینجا توصیه می‌کنم مانند نگاه کردن به
مثال بنابراین
بین این یک بین است، بنابراین این چیز
اینجا بین این دو است، چهار یک دو سه دارد
چهار تا، پس شاید باید فونت رو بزرگتر کنم
اینجا، بنابراین کاری که قرار است انجام دهم این است که من هستم
دکمه F1 رو میزنم و بعد زوم میکنم
و من این کار را دوباره انجام می‌دهم
پس فقط همه این شلوغی را نادیده بگیر و نگاه کن
در این بخش، این واقعاً همان چیزی است که
بخش مهمی است، بنابراین اولین پم است
مقدار شروع دوم است، بنابراین
موقعیت فعلی لوبیا، مقدار اولیه
موقعیت لوبیا، پس شما دارید
ارزش مقصد نهایی که می‌خواهید
مقدار، موقعیت ماوس است، بنابراین ماوس
مکث یک روش بازی است که می‌توانید از آن استفاده کنید
موقعیت فعلی ماوس را دریافت کنید، بنابراین شما این کار را انجام می‌دهید
اگر استفاده نمی‌کنید، اگر این کار را نمی‌کنید، K
شما در حال انجام بازی جهانی K هستید. ک، پس آره
ام و سپس مدت زمان بر حسب ثانیه است
بنابراین شما یک مقدار را مشخص می‌کنید، مثلاً سه
ثانیه انتقال بین
موقعیت اولیه و مقدار نهایی
شما می‌خواهید و سپس مقدار به این صورت است
مقدار باید به‌روزرسانی شود، این است
جایی که شما در واقع تابع را می‌نویسید
که قرار است مقدار را تغییر دهد
به تدریج، بنابراین در اینجا موقعیت را تغییر می‌دهیم
از لوبیا به عنوان تغییر مقدار در اینجا و
سپس تابع درون‌یابی در آنجا
انواع مختلفی از تسکین وجود دارد و نحوه‌ی شما
دسترسی شما می‌توانید این کار را مانند این انجام دهید، بنابراین در اینجا
ک. بنابراین اگر از غیر جهانی استفاده می‌کنید